Previously on Bobamex quasi Control Shift Eject.
Control Shift Eject.
Control Shift Eject. Hier nimmt alles auf, sieht gut aus.
Ich bin gerade mal wieder im Rahmen umfangreicherer Umstellung, wie ihr euch denken könnt.
Von daher, eine Geringfüge regieren.
Ich bin froh, dass es läuft. Ich hab mir schon wieder alles hier irgendwie verbastelt.
Das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Du musst bedienen, mann. Du kannst nicht einfach irgendeine Karte drauflegen. Du musst schon bedienen, was da liegt.
Ja, das kann irgendwie sein. Es gibt hier Kommunikationsprobleme. Wieso?
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Es geht nicht.
Der Chat geht auch nicht mehr.
Was habt ihr wieder angestellt? Leuchtet.
Leuchtet irgendwas.
Oh, und das Stream ist gerissen.
Darf man mal, dass mein Recording richtig funktioniert, wa?
Jetzt hast du dich...
Und alle eventuell? Er hat nur sich selbst... Oh, der Tim hat sich totgeschallt. Und?
Jetzt ist er wieder zu hören.
Verstehe, es geht nur mit... Tim hat seine Stimme verloren.
Herzlich willkommen bei BUMZACK RETURN. Wenn es kein Schneider ist.
Ich bin wieder raus aus dem Keller.
Noch!
Ein schönes Intro, ja doch.
Wie immer, von David.
Flatter den David jetzt, wenn du das hörst. Und dich unterhalten gefühlt hast.
Macht ihn flatt.
Aber dieses Bombsack-Return-Ding ist für uns das...
Das ist ja nicht mehr so für...
Naja, wir haben ja diese Unbenennung nun abgeblasen.
also es ist ja... Das ist ja sozusagen unser FUBAR-Buzz.
Aber das könnte man eher als Outro oder so, ich weiß nicht, so ein Intro und dieses Bombsack-Return. Aber herzlich willkommen als Ende. Also irgendwie...
Also ich bin ja offen für neue Initiativen. Wir hatten ja auch schon eine andere, aber die gefiel euch ja auch nicht so gut. Nicht so gut wie die. Also die finde ich hat einfach Schwung. Und positive Grundeinstellungen. Das macht diesen Podcast ja auch aus.
Durchaus, ja. Außer wenn es um Nokia und Kodex geht.
Oder irgendwas anderes, was uns wirklich wichtig ist.
Na gut, ich ertrag's auch. Aber es könnte auch knackiger dann dadurch sein, wenn dann einfach nur dieses Intro und dann so einmal Drrrr, Trommelwirbel. Neue Lieblingsseite von mir ist ja instantrimshot.com. Hab ich kürzlich erst wieder entdeckt. Ja, der Name ist Programm. Kannst du so eine schöne Autoplay URL jemanden zuschicken, wenn es gerade geklappt hat, dann macht es auch Tusch.
Katsching habe ich jetzt hier gerade nicht zum Abrufen, aber man kann ja auch nicht alles haben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall hier sind wir alle so auf... haben uns ins Studio geschleppt bei diesem wunderbaren Sommerwetter.
Und sind alle so ein bisschen krank.
Tim wird uns den Rest geben.
Tja, naja, ich muss mich ja überhaupt erst mal erholen. Ich war ja vier Tage im Off. Ich hatte kein Internet, nicht ein Bit.
Nichts.
Wo warst du denn?
Ich war im Pazifik gewesen. Ich war ja selbst an der Antarktis. Haben die ein Netz?
Na, ich war außerhalb des deutschen Mobilfunknetzes. Es gab kein WLAN nirgendwo. Und ich hatte keine entsprechende SIM-Gastkarte und hab mich mal wieder entsprechend aufgeregt. Aber es hat alles nichts geholfen. Erst mit wieder Eintritt in die deutsche Grenze hier. Hatte ich Netz.
Ohne Internet kann man dann noch schlecht auf Twitter ranten, ne?
Ja, das ist überhaupt das Schlimmste, ne? Dass man ohne Twitter sich nicht darauf veraufregen kann. So ein Scheiß. Ja, wie soll ich denn an der Empörungsgesellschaft teilnehmen? Na ja, gut, ich dachte, ich werde schon nichts verpassen, aber komm, weil ich dann wegkam, irgendwie alles raus. Line, neue Computer, tra la la. Was weiß ich, was alles noch passiert ist. Ja, Fußball, Weltmeisterschaft, Finale, alles verpasst.
Wo warst du denn, in welchem antikapitalistischen Ausland?
Na, also Norditalien gilt, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt als antikapitalistisch, aber am WLAN können sie noch arbeiten.
InfNorthitalien, so so.
Genau, InfNorthitalien. Man könnte auch von der Südschweiz sprechen. Na, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist hier erstmal Mobile Max-Ausgabe, Nummer 69 und wie es der informierte Hörer wahrscheinlich schon selbst herausdistilliert hat. Heute in dreier Besetzungen mit Dennis und Huckel und Tim. Mit ohne Max, leider, der auch gerade irgendwo ist, wo es vielleicht kein Internet gibt, ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht hörst du uns ja auch, Max. Vielleicht kannst du uns ja auch noch irgendwas zuwerfen, wenn wir uns mal wieder total verrannt haben. Und wenn nicht, reden wir einfach, wie uns der Schnabel gewachsen ist.
Wir werden dich gar nicht lassen heute, wir sind jetzt in einer Überzahl. Ich und Hucke.
Ach so, ich bin raus. Ich hab ja auch meinen Siracusa noch nicht zu Ende gelesen.
Ja, deswegen regnet es nämlich jetzt auch. Du hast mir den Siracusa nicht aufgelesen.
Ja, naja, also ich meine, so ist das halt. So ist das halt. Dafür gibt es heute viele Streams. Ich hab mich mal bemüht, hier dieses lose Versprechen einzuhalten. Und wir streamen tatsächlich jetzt in drei Formaten.
In 3D.
Ja, genau. In drei Stream-Dimensionen.
Die heilige Stream-Falschigkeit.
Genau, also für den Mainstream, für die Elite.
Mainstream. Wir machen hier den Mainstream.
Und für die Kellerkinder. Gibt's für jeden was.
Die Dreistreamigkeit.
Die Underground-Stream.
Heilige Dreistreamigkeit. Das fängt ja schon wieder an hier.
So, Linux 3.0, ne? Erstes Thema.
Ist draußen.
Ja, ist draußen.
Aber ist ja nicht so richtig 3.0. Warum?
Weil es eigentlich die 2.6.40 ist.
Ja, Linus hat gesagt, jetzt... Wie viel 20 Jahre?
Keine Ahnung.
20 Jahre auf dem Buckel. Die Stable-Versionsnummern, die zählen ins Unermessliche. Und jetzt so langsam könnte man noch einfach mal den Deckel zumachen und sagen, ab jetzt geht es 3.0 weiter.
Das heißt eigentlich ist gar nichts Besonderes passiert? Nur wieder ein paar Patches.
Ein paar Patches hier, ein paar Patches da.
Aber es war doch immer so, dass die ungeraden Zahlen, also hier 2.5 war doch immer so ein Beta-Könne, und dann haben die alle noch 2.4 benutzt, oder? Dann gab es 2.5, das ist immer so ein Beta-Ding. Und wenn es dann Stable ist, machen sie 2.6. Das heißt, der nächste wäre jetzt eigentlich 2.7 gewesen, als Beta oder als Un-Stable, oder sind die von diesem Konzept runter?
Was weiß ich?
Die ungeraden sind die Developer-Versionen, und die geraden sind die Release-Versionen.
Haben die sich damit über einen Haufen geschmissen, oder wie?
Nee, es ist halt 3.0. Also ich meine, das heißt dann wohl nicht 2.8, oder?
Ja, aber wo waren denn die 2.7? Also wo waren die Beta-
Weiß ich nicht, auf dem Server irgendwo vermutlich. Oder in Git? Ich weiß es nicht, ich verfolge das Thema Linux-Qualität ehrlich gesagt wenig. Am Rande.
Auch nicht.
Aber die Mailing-Nist ist bisweilen recht unterhaltsam.
Ja.
Aber ich lese auch immer nur, wenn es auf Hacker-News irgendwie...
Und darauf hingewiesen wird, dass gerade wieder irgendjemand sich mit jemand anderem die Koffer einschlägt, oder was?
Ja, manchmal gibt ja der Linus noch was zum Besten auf der Liste. Der kann das ja auch mit unterhaltsamen Mails.
Ja, und was für geile neue Features gibt's mit Linus 3.0?
Mehr Bloat.
Versionskontrolle, moderne Dokumentenarchitektur, irgendwas?
Bloat, Bloat und nochmal Bloat. Resolution Independence. Es gibt ja Leute, die sich jetzt auch schon beschweren, dass das Butterriff S irgendwie nicht super performt. Kann man sich jetzt wohl aussuchen, glaube ich, mit dem neuesten?
Ja, ich war schon seit einer Weile dabei. Aber sagen sie das immer noch nicht in Production, also production-reif. Aber ich glaube, sie benutzen trotzdem schon alle.
Das kriegen ja andere auch nicht hin mit dem Fallsystem. Ja gut, und ansonsten hat jetzt, weiß ich nicht, also Linux selbst Features ist ja auch nicht so viel, was man da so haben kann. Also das meiste passiert ja wahrscheinlich so ein paar Ebenen drüber.
Ja, ist ja auch nur der Kernel, ist ja getrennt. Ja, wir haben ja so ein getrenntes Modell.
Genau, das heißt nämlich eigentlich GNU-Linux. Tja, Mobamex, der etwas andere Linux-Podcast.
Der Stumbleweed rollt euch das Studio.
Aber es ist doch so, dass der Stolman ist schuld, oder? Weil der Stolman sein Hurtbetriebssystem nicht fertig gekriegt hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der da überhaupt noch dran mitentwickelt in irgendeiner Form. Ja, keine Ahnung. Aber ich hab gerade kurz vor der Sendung hat die Wikipedia mich mit einer interessanten Information versorgt, nämlich, dass UTF-8 jetzt auch in Linux drin ist. Nee, UTF-8 wurde ursprünglich mal im Rahmen von Plan 9 entwickelt. Was seht ihr das? Bist du noch was Plan 9?
Die Zuhörer denken jetzt, genau.
Ja, dieser furchtbar schlechte Film. Der schlechteste Film aller Zeiten, der dann halt von dieser Developer-Community seinerzeit mal herangezogen wurde, um als Titel für das Next OS, was sie sich so vorstellten, so Beyond Unix. Also es gibt auch Plan 9 und Plan 9 ist halt irgendwie, alles ist ein Pfeil. Nee, aber also irgendwas hat die da geritten, dass sie der Meinung waren, man müsste das ein neues OS auf dem Basisprinzip, dass alles ein Pfeil ist. Alles mit kleiner und größer und alles mit Streams und so weiter. Halt so dieses reine Unix-Ding. So quasi in seiner Vervollkommnung. Ich hab mir das nie genauer angeschaut. Ich hab irgendwann mal, glaube ich, einen relativ schlechten Vortrag zu Plan 9 von irgendjemand gehört. Das hat mich auch hinten und vorne nicht überzeugt. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir dann Mac OS 10.7-Line, wo jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr ein Pfeil sein wird, bald, wenn das so weitergeht.
Alles in SQLite 3 Datenbanken.
Ja, wenn überhaupt. Auf jeden Fall wird kräftig daran gearbeitet, alles schön abzuschirmen und wegzuhalten und Platz zu machen und zu verallgemeinern und zu abstrahieren, etc.
Ja, da war ja sowieso schon immer der Plan vom Olin Steve, dass die Leute gar nicht wissen müssen, wie ein Computer funktioniert. Die müssen ja auch nicht wissen, wie ein Auto funktioniert und eine automatische Gangschaltung.
Wer weiß schon, wie ein Computer funktioniert. Also ich glaube, da gibt es zunehmend weniger Personen, die diesen Titel für sich in Anspruch nehmen.
Aber da gab es jetzt, hat man ja gerade schon im Vorgespräch, dass jetzt Gizmodo gerade dieses Playboy-Interview mit Steve rausgekramt hat und da erklärt er, wie Computer funktionieren neben Interviewer. Und das schafft er auch ganz gut. Jetzt muss ich das hier nochmal... Na ja, irgendwie meint er so, wenn du jetzt nicht weißt, wie du den Milchshake da drüben vom Tresen holst im Restaurant, dann kann ich dir jetzt Anweisungen geben. Also winkel deinen Knie an, mach 300 Gramm Gewicht nach vorne, mach den Fuß nach vorne und so weiter und in jedem möglichen Detail. Und es dauert halt 20 Minuten, bis ich dir vollständig und präzise erklärt hab, wie du den Milchshake holst. Und jetzt stell dir vor, du könntest das jetzt in millionenfacher Geschwindigkeit tun und für mich als Beobachter würde das dann irgendwie Magie sein. Musst ja nochmal genau lesen. Also ich kann das jetzt auch nicht so frei, aber irgendwie so. War auf jeden Fall sehr anschaulich. Und naja, ist natürlich auch eine sehr abstrakte Beschreibung davon, aber...
Ja, ich glaub, ich hab das doch nicht gelesen.
Ich auch nicht.
Gut, dann also paste ich jetzt wohl doch nochmal.
Ja, wirf mal den URL irgendwo hin.
Wo ist er denn hier? Steve's Lays it down for Playboy.
So, irgendjemand meinte im Chat, wir dürften nicht über die Quaterliresalz reden.
Okay, hier ist der Link stattdessen.
Also ich lass mir ja sehr ungern irgendwas verbieten, ne?
Also schon deswegen jetzt so.
Also deswegen sollten wir jetzt erst recht über die Quaterliresalz vorden. Von Nokia und Microsoft reden.
Ein bisschen aufgerundet, ca. 1% dieser Firma gehört. Und das natürlich erfreuliche Ergebnisse.
Nokia geht's nicht wirklich gut, ne? Also mittlerweile machen die ja Verlust.
Ja, hatten sie ja letztes Mal schon, oder? Verlust? Und jetzt doppelt so viel Verlust.
Ich glaub, die hatten nur weniger Gewinn oder so, aber dass die jetzt auch wirklich so Verlust machen, ist neu.
Guck mal nach. Obwohl, willst du über Nokia reden?
Ach so, ich wollte über die Quarterly Results reden.
Ich dachte von Nokia.
Na, ich kann mir das mal kurz nachstellen. Ich meine, jetzt hab ich schon so lange nicht mehr über Nokia geredet, aber... Nee, also die haben jetzt... Tatsache. Also Ende 2009 hatten sie mal so ein Quartal, wo sie irgendwie auch eine knappe Milliarde in den Sand gesetzt haben.
Ja, das ist dann nun schon zwei Jahre her fast.
Das ist zwei Jahre her. Das mag auch irgendwelche besonderen Gründe gehabt haben, aber das stagniert auf jeden Fall alles ganz ordentlich. Und vor allem alle Zahlen zeigen nach unten. Also Umsatz, Verkaufszahlen und so weiter. Ja, ich meine, ich muss ja gar nicht...
Aber scroll mal doch ein bisschen zurück. Ich meine, wenn man hier guckt, sind ja alle Zahlen hier irgendwie ganz schön... Also das Größte, was man mal so sieht, sind da diese 2,8 Milliarden in 2007. Aber sonst dümpeln die ja schon die ganze Zeit irgendwie so zwischen 1, so um die 1 Milliarde rum. Also eigentlich...
Das geht jetzt hier auch 10 Jahre zurück, ne?
Obwohl man sagen muss, dass der Umsatz ist reichlich gestiegen, aber der gewinnt nicht.
Also da tut sich halt nicht viel. Ja, aber auch in den letzten beiden Quartalen. Also dafür, dass sie eigentlich der, noch bis vor kurzem als der Player im Telefonmarkt galten. Und dieser gesamte Markt gerade wie bekloppt wächst. Also der Smartphone-Markt ist der Computer-Markt derzeit der Zukunft oder zumindest einer der Zukunfts-Märkte mit unglaublichem Zuwächsen bewegt sich bei Nokia eigentlich gar nichts. Und ich glaube auch, dass nach wie vor das, was ich schon vor, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Jahren hier schon mal verkündigt habe, dass es halt einfach vorbei ist. Es ist vorbei, wir haben einfach keine Strategie.
Doch, wir haben doch Windows-Mobile-Phone-7-Dings-Bombs. Das fand ich ja ganz...
Na, sie haben ja nicht Windows-Phone.
Aber das fand ich ganz lustig, als John Gruber da drüber gezwittert hat über die Microsoft-Quartalzahlen. Dass sie, ja, hat er irgendwie so geschrieben, ja, irgendwie haben sie komischerweise die Windows-Phone-7-Zahlen in ihrem Quarterly Results vergessen. So, kleine spitze Bemerkung, die ich doch ganz amüsant fand. Scheint wohl auch da an der Front sich wirklich sehr wenig zu tun haben.
Du hast mir das in den Chat geschmissen.
Ich hab's in alle Chats geschmissen, die nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen waren.
Ja, naja, also lassen wir vielleicht Nokia erstmal beiseite. Aber was sich bei Apple abspielt, das ist ja schon wirklich absurd. Also irgendwie erwartet man ja geradezu, dass sie jetzt jedes Quartal immer wieder so ein Record-Quarter bringen. Aber diese Zuwachszahlen, die sind einfach wirklich enorm. Was war das jetzt irgendwie über 100% Umsatz und Gewinn, Zuwachs, lalala.
Unstoppable.
Wobei ich ja also bei diesen Quartalzahlen, was ich ja immer am interessantesten finde, außer diesen üblichen aufgerechnen, was jetzt wofür, was jetzt wie viel ausmacht, ich meine okay, ist interessant. iPhone macht halt die Hälfte aus, das ist der iPod, der mal irgendwie der Gewinnbringer überhaupt für Apple war, also der ja quasi diese ganze Siegesstrecke der letzten 10 Jahre begründet hat.
Hat dann noch 5% Anteil.
Genau, macht gerade mal 5%. Was interessant ist, weil da ja auch der iPod Touch mit reingehört. Sie haben halt beim iPhone auch massiv andere Margen, aber das Ding ist einfach erfolgreich. Was ich aber interessant finde, sind diese Conference-Call-Geschichten. Sie verkündigen ja immer diese Zahlen und danach gibt es diese Telefonen-Konferenz, wo es dann immer so schlechte Aufnahmen von gibt. Ohne Bild und Ton. Mit Ton, aber ohne Bild. Und da kommen dann manchmal ganz interessante Fragen. Und auch ein paar interessante Antworten. Sie geben ja dann auch immer so eine Guidance ab, was sie quasi im nächsten Quartal erwarten.
Weil man bei Apple sagt, dass sie immer sehr überkonservativ sind.
Richtig. Trotzdem haben sie gesagt, unser Revenue geht 12% zurück. Das muss nicht so stattfinden, aber es ist eine andere Aussage, als wenn sie sagen, es bleibt oder nimmt zu oder so. Und die Antwort darauf ist, einerseits bla bla bla, nächstes Quartal ist dann hier so Education, Verkaufsseason etc. Und sie erwarten dieses und jenes. Und dann sagt er noch, Oppenheimer ist das glaube ich, was ist das, der guckt, weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht. There is also a future product transition that we are not going to talk about today. Product transition, klingt aber nicht wie, also wenn sie von Product Transition reden, dann reden sie meistens, also das ist jetzt meine Interpretation der Sprache, so wie ich das so in Erinnerung hab, dann reden sie wirklich davon, dass sich irgendwas ändert.
Ja, iPhone 4 nach iPhone 5.
Ja, das ist aber keine Änderung. Das ist ja auch keine Änderung, das ist ja eine Transition. Nee, eine Transition ist, dass sich die Produkt-Gemenge-Lage generell irgendwie ändert und verschiebt. Dass sie irgendwas komplett droppen. Ja, sowas wie die Einführung des iPod Touch, das ist irgendwie so eine Product Transition, dass sie irgendwie weggehen von dem alten iPod oder dass sie irgendwas fallen lassen.
Ist natürlich jetzt blöd, weil wir kann nicht vorspulen und gucken.
Wir können ja ein bisschen orakelen und unsere Glaskugel rausholen, ein bisschen wienern. Da lagen wir ja nun zuletzt nicht so schlecht. Da können wir uns ja auch mal wieder ein paar Minuspunkte einheimsen. Ich dachte als erstes an den Mac Pro. Weil alles andere ist jetzt aktualisiert. Also MacBook Pros, Airs, Mini, iMac. Da erwarte ich keinerlei Nennt. Also weder erwarte ich dann noch irgendwelche Updates, noch erwarte ich irgendwelche Transitions. Die sind eigentlich alle aktualisiert worden. Alles ist aktualisiert worden, außer den Mac Pros. Und die Mac Pros sind extrem teuer im Vergleich zu allen anderen. Das ist die extreme Nische. Sie haben den Server schon fallen gelassen.
Ja, aber da machen wir auch kaum noch Umsatz mit, oder?
Jetzt kommt Zanderbolt, PCI-Steckplätze sind vielleicht nicht mehr so.
Die Filmschnittleute brauchen sie auch nicht mehr. Na ja, also zumindest... Das sind die 3D-Leute und die Filmschnittleute. Das sind die einzigen, die noch dicke Maschinen brauchen.
Ja, es ist halt wirklich so dieser totale Profi-Bereich. Also wann kaufst du einen Mac Pro? Also sogar ich. Also der einzige Grund, für mich jetzt einen Mac Pro zu kaufen, derzeit wäre halt so eine spezielle PCI-Karte, die ich gerne hätte. Die mir allerdings noch einen Funken zu teuer ist. Genau, eine Audiokarte. Bis dann müsste ich mir dazu halt noch einen Mac Pro kaufen. Und dann noch einen Bildschirm dazu kaufen. Genau, das heißt eine Karte, die mir sowieso schon zu teuer ist, kostet mich nochmal 3000 Euro nochmal viel mehr zu teuer, weil ich sie halt nicht mal eben an meinen iMac ranbammeln kann. Andererseits mit Thunderbolt. Thunderbolt, genau. Eigentlich müssten wir ja hier, wenn irgendwie von Thunderbolt die Rede ist, auch... Mit Thunderbolt könnte man sowas ja auch anschließen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich bin auch... Ich meine, ich finde ja eigentlich so PCI-Karten ganz elegant. Aber vielleicht zurück zu dieser Product Transition. Also vielleicht ist das alles nur Quatsch, aber ich habe so Gerüchte gelesen von New Enclosure. Das Ding ist ja auch riesig groß und so ist ein richtiger Klopper und so. Eigentlich hätten wir schon lange lieber was gehabt, was man auch so 19 Zollig mal einbauen könnte, wenn man eh schon so ein Spezialgerät hat. Das leistet das Teil halt auch nicht.
Meinst du, wie so ein Rack hier, wie bei dir, mit deinem Audio-Equipment, dass du dann so neben dir einfach so deinem Schreibtisch, weil du willst ja auch eine CD mal vielleicht noch reinstecken oder irgendetwas dranstecken. Also wenn das irgendwo im Rack im Serverraum steht, nützt dir das ja nicht so viel. Und guck mal, hier so ein kleines Rack, wo du deine Blades reinschieben kannst.
Also ich fand die Spekulation ganz interessant, dass es halt ein neues Geheurisse sein könnte, was ähnlichen Zwecken dient wie das derzeitige auch. Also noch Slots hat etc. und vielleicht auch so Plattentausch. Aber was eben anders gebaut ist, was vielleicht einen Zacken kompakter ist und keine Ahnung, vielleicht in 2 HE reinpasst, auch noch. Also wenn du es da reinschrauben willst, das du es kannst. Aber es nicht musst, weil es auch an sich gut aussieht. Und dann hätten sie quasi auch wieder diesen Server, also diesen Firmen-Server, Mac hängt hinten im Rack, im Computerraum, da wo er auch ein bisschen durchlüften kann, wo es gekühlt ist, wo die großen Platten eh dran sind und die schnellen Netzwerks-Switcher hängen usw. Weil du willst das nicht irgendwo bei der Sekretärin auf dem Schreibtisch stehen haben. Also auf der einen Seite ist immer die Rede von Konsumer, Prosumer, Tralala. Und diese ganzen Geräte werden immer kleiner und kompakter und passen besser auf den Tisch. Und die meisten wollen sowieso nur noch Laptops haben. Es sei denn, man hat halt ein iMac. Auf der anderen Seite fällt der Server weg. Aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass sie nicht riesige Fortschritte machen würden so im Firmenbereich. Und sie haben jetzt Mac OS X Server schön billig für 50 Euro zum Klicken dazu usw. Und vielleicht würden wir sowas ja auch mal betreiben.
Die Frage ist, worauf?
Auf ein Mac Mini? Ja gut, aber ein Mac Mini...
Da ist halt keine Platte drin, ne?
Ja, gut, dann kannst du halt jetzt Thunderbolt, externes Gehäuse, aber irgendwie ist das alles so... Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber das ist so eigentlich ja auch so die Frage, auf deren Antwort wir jetzt ja alle so ein bisschen noch warten, was sie so mit diesen Pros, Jumans da eigentlich überhaupt genau vorhaben.
Na, die wollen sich irgendwie ihre Software verkaufen. Ich glaube, das klappt auch mit Final Cut Pro ganz gut. Meiner Meinung nach waren es jetzt so 10, 20 High-End-Leute. Vielleicht sind es auch 300 oder vielleicht sind es auch 1000. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, dass das Ding ganz gut läuft.
Noch lastet immer. Warte mal, wenn es dich erstmal erwischt.
Ach, mich erwischt ist ja auch ja am laufenden Meter. So ist ja nicht... Ja, ich leide ja schon unter dem Ist-Zustand. Ich muss ja vor der Zukunft gar keine Angst haben.
Ich finde es nicht so gut, dass Apple die ganzen Pro-User immer so ein bisschen hinten fallen lässt, damit sie alle anderen bedienen können. Es ist schon so ein zweischneidiger Weg irgendwie fahren. Oder vielleicht mal so ein... Vielleicht wirklich mal so ein Advanced OS X rausbringen. Wo irgendwie...
Du weißt, das ist ja alles nicht advanced, genau.
Ja, ich fühle mich schon bei vielen Sachen ganz schön beschränkt. Naja, jetzt zum Beispiel machst du eine Platte mit diesem neuen Core Storage. Formatierst du die, kriegst du sie nicht wieder runter. Musst du wieder irgendwie... Deine Platte ist dann getaggt. Zum Beispiel. Hab ich bisher noch nicht geschafft. Ich muss länger gucken. Ich muss ja zugeben, man muss ja bei diesem Line, so wie bei allen Transitions, muss man ja immer erstmal ein bisschen gucken machen und probieren, bis man wieder Sachen rausfindet und so.
Aber, ja.
Naja, aber auf jeden Fall, also ich bin auf jeden Fall auch sehr gespannt, wie lange sie diesen fetten Mac Pro-Klotz noch so mitschleifen und ob es da nicht mal was Neues gibt. Aber, also immer wenn ich dann so einen neuen Mac Pro mal doch auspacke und in den Händen halte, ist das dann schon immer noch so dieses nerdige Hardware-Streiche. Oh, der Monolith, der... Das ist schon eine geile Hardware, keine Frage.
Aber die Frage ist, wofür braucht man das Teil eigentlich wirklich so? Okay, Platten, SSD... Es entwickelt sich jetzt irgendwie auch anders.
Wie gesagt, echt 3D und Videoschnitt, die viele Karten im Zweifel auch reinstecken wollen. Also mehrere Grafikkarten, mehrere Videoschnittkarten, was auch immer, die irgendwie so viel Chores und RAM haben wollen, wie es überhaupt nur geht. Und die sich halt auch ihre eigenen Monitore da noch ranflanschen wollen.
Naja, also meine Flat ist auch dieser ganze Mac Pro-Teil. Ich glaube, die verkaufen gar nicht mehr so viel, dass es in den Verkaufszahlen nach dem Lenswert niederschlägt, sodass es nicht unbedingt jetzt auf ihren Gesamtumsatz solche Auswirkungen hat. Ich fabuliere nur ein wenig. Man muss ja auch mal fabulieren dürfen.
Aber so eine Keynote, wo sie dann den neuen Mac Pro als das neue Feature-Product rausfällt, kann man sich auch gar nicht mehr richtig vorstellen. Ups da hier in dem Kanal. Ich hätte ja auch bei dieser Transition eher ans iPhone oder iPad gedacht. Wenn wir hier mal die Glaskugel rubbeln wollen.
Na gut, wir können ja mal das Thema abschließen. Und vielleicht mal so oft die anderen Dinge gehen. Aber wo wir gerade bei Hardware sind. Es gab Hardware.
Ja, es sind deine Stoßgebete erhört worden. Hast du schon geklickt?
Ja.
Wie viele?
Ich hab sofort eine Mail geschrieben.
Eins.
Eins nur?
Ja, aber das bräuchte mehrere Laptops.
Die sind doch so klein, da können wir noch zwei nehmen.
Das stimmt, aber.
Und was machst du mit dem alten?
Verkaufen.
So schnell, einfach nur so, weil das neue noch so viel geiler ist.
Na, das neue behebt die einzigen Dinge, die ich so, also wo ich mir gedacht hätte, da könnte man mal was dran drehen. Das ist alles gekommen. Also ich kann jetzt die SSD auf 256 GB aufblasen. Im 11 Zoll.
Und das ist immer noch, weil vieler vermutet, dass es raufgelötet ist, aber es ist immer noch dieser Streifen zum 11 Zoll.
Ich hab da unterschiedliche Berichte gehört.
Bei Mac fix it ist auseinander genommen, da ist wieder dieser Streifen.
Geht das auch für diese 256er Optionen? Das ist die Frage, weil es kann sein, dass es nicht darauf geht.
Ich denke schon, weil die werden da nicht 1000 verschiedene Wasserbords machen.
Ja stimmt.
Ja, aber das 11 Zoll kann ja nur bis 128.
Nee, das gibt's, nein.
Aber hier steht es. 64 oder 128.
Ja, was ist hier?
Apple. Ach nee, da steht es doch. Im Kleingedruckten.
Im Kleingedruckten, genau.
Da ist Kleingedruckten. Configurable. Only at Apple Online Store. Genau.
Extra Markt, extra Fleisch.
Und du hast eine Mail an den Apple Store geschrieben.
Ich hab eine Mail an meinen Händler meines Vertrauens geschrieben. Hab gesagt, ich möchte das erste Gerät in dieser Konfirmation...
An den David schon wieder.
Einen anderen David in diesem Fall.
Ach, echt?
Du hast zwei Apple-Händler deines Vertrauens.
Nein, der andere David macht uns die Intros.
Ja.
Und dann klickt der im Apple Store, damit du die 257 kriegst.
Du lässt.
Na, der kann ja als Händler Ach so. kann ja ja sich die selben Konfigurationen auch zukommen lassen.
Du lässt klicken.
Ich lasse klicken. Na, ich bestell halt immer bei meinem... Ich hab da immer eine Gründe. Auf jeden Fall das. Dann haben sie halt schnellere Prozessoren, weil man den ersten Benchmarks, die so auf dem Tisch liegen, glauben darf.
Da geht's ab.
Gehen die Dinger los, dann kannst du noch die i7-Option klicken bei dem Teil.
Ja, wie viel Gigahertz?
1,8.
Ja, entspannt. Jetzt sind die schneller als ich.
Das 13 Zoll ist angeblich sogar schneller als das Mac Pro.
Aber die sind ja auch nicht Quad-Core.
Außerdem, und die haben auch nur 1,8, steht hier.
Ja, ich hab hier 2,3, Alter.
Check das einfach mal aus.
Damit muss es jetzt auch gar nicht mithalten. Aber Performance schadet ja so generell nicht. Und das Ding wird ja jetzt auch nicht nur beim Professor schneller geworden sein, sondern dann auch bei Bus und so weiter. Keine Ahnung. Hab ich mir im Einzelnen noch nicht so angeschaut. Und natürlich das super Teil hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur ist back.
In der Hausjahr.
In der Haus.
In der Gehäuse.
Ja, das ist Fint.
Glaubst du, wir hätten Chancen, wenn wir diesen ganzen Podcast einfach durchrappen?
Weiß nicht.
Nicht mit mir, glaube ich.
Ja, in dem Chat meint einer, ich hätte UMTS vergessen. Tja, ich muss zugeben.
Das fehlt noch.
Ist obsolete.
Ich fände es nach wie vor cool, wenn es drin wäre, aber... Doch eigentlich fände ich es cool, wenn es drin wäre. Es ist nur so, dass mit der iPhone-Tethering-Option ist der Schmerz nicht sehr groß derzeit.
Und in Italien hat es ja auch nichts gebracht.
Ich fände es immer noch gut, wenn sie es machen, aber ich gebe langsam auf. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass sie diesen Weg nicht gehen wollen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Es kann nicht so schwer sein, dass so ein Popel-Chip, der ins iPhone passt, auch noch hier ins Gehäuse zu quetschen.
Ich finde mir vorstellen, dass sie erst bereit sind, das zu machen, wenn sie auf diese SIM-Karte komplett verzichten können.
Wie lange hält die Batterie von dem Air? Weil jetzt ist ja der Sandy Bridge drin und der hat ja die Grafikkarte von Intel, die HD 3000. Dadurch fällt ja der Nvidia-Chip-Satz weg, was die da vorher hatten.
Aber angeblich immer noch 5 Stunden.
Richtig.
Und vorher auch schon 5 Stunden.
Dafür haben sie das ganze Thunderbolt-Grafel mit dabei, was ja auch nochmal das nächste Feature ist.
Schon cool, weil man sich dann nämlich diese dicke Display kauft, das Thunderbolt-Display.
Dreh doch mal dein Mikrofon so ein bisschen, weil du nimmst gerade dein Auge auf. Aber dann kommt wieder der DARS. Nee, der DARS.
Da auf dem DARS an der Nordsee.
Das eine ist ja sozusagen, wohin das Mikrofon zeigt. Jetzt sprich noch mal.
Hallo, hallo.
Das ist schon viel direkter. Ja, der DARS finde ich nicht nur. Das ist einfach so.
Ich hör das nicht so.
Aber jetzt ist das ja fast...
weit weg.
Weit weg, ja.
Ist ja wie bei dir. So ist das, ja.
Du kannst auch noch ein bisschen näher ran machen. Was wollte ich gerade erzählen?
Ja, hier mit dem Thunderbolt-Display. Weil gerade hier bei dem MacBook Air, da sind ja nun mal nicht so viele Anschlüsse.
Ich mach dich lauter, Dennis.
Mach doch. Weil es ja jetzt weiter weg ist, das Mikro. Jedenfalls sind da nicht so viele Anschlüsse an dem Thunderbolt-Display. Und... Jetzt hast du mich völlig durcheinander gemacht. Da sind nicht so viele Anschlüsse an dem MacBook Air. Und deswegen wollen wir jetzt nur noch einmal Strom anschließen und den Thunderbolt-Stecker vom Display. Und dann geht da USB drüber. Ethernet geht da drüber. Was war noch? Audio? Das Thunderbolt-Display hat einen Ethernet-Anschluss.
Nein.
Alter, hast du gar kein Netz gehabt in die Kamera?
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich mir das Display noch gar nicht angeschaltet hab.
Also ich dachte ja immer, dass da so ein Thunderbolt-Gerät rauskommt, wo alle möglichen Anschlüsse dran sind und man da dann sein Display anschließt. Aber nein, die haben gleich dieses Thunderbolt-Display zu diesem Gerät gemacht. Ganz schlau natürlich.
Pfiffig.
Und das sogar, ist das Firewire? Sehe ich das richtig?
Ja, Firewire 800.
Really Tatsache.
Ja, aber da geht es doch ab, oder?
Und noch einen weiteren Thunderbolt-Anschluss. Also du kannst da gleich das nächste Display, na wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber, ja, also das wär's. Ich bin nicht erfroh, dass ich mir vorher kein LED-Display gekauft habe. Weil das wär auch ein bisschen unnötig gewesen. So mit dem Mini-Display-Port.
Ja, aber nach wie vor mit diesem scheiß kurzen Kabel. Also dafür habe ich für dich überhaupt keinerlei Verständnis.
Was für ein scheiß kurzes Kabel? Vom Display selbst zum...
Aus diesem Bildschirm kommt einfach ein Fixed-Length-Kabel.
Ja, was ich noch viel schlimmer finde, ist, dass ja die Stromversorgung ist ja... Also jedenfalls bei meinem U-Alten-Display ist es so, dass dieser Stromversorgungsblock, das Netzteil, da kommt der, der... Bei mir kommt ja kein Strom für meinen Rechner. Nee, aber irgendwie ist die...
Das ist auch die falsche Seite. Bei MacBook Air hast du nämlich Strom und Thunderbolt auf zwei verschiedenen Seiten. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das mit diesem Kabel machen soll.
Ja, das Kabel, da ist doch eh nur getrickst. Das muss man sich nochmal richtig angucken. Jedenfalls hoffe ich, dass du den Stromkasten, das Netzteil von dem Display, nicht da auch irgendwie ganz nah an dem Kabel mit dran haben, weil das nervt voll.
Warum nervt das voll?
Na, weil das Display hat ja nur ein einziges Kabel, was da rauskommt. Das heißt, um das Kabel, was wir jetzt hier gerade sehen, was am Rechner dran ist, da muss auch der Strom für das Display mit rein. Und bei mir ist es halt so, bei meinem letzten Karton-Display hier, also auch in Cinema, aber nicht das mit LED, sondern noch eins davor, dass da das Stromkabel von diesem riesen, dicken Netzteil direkt da rein geht. Und da das Kabel nur so kurz ist, muss es in der Nähe immer von meinem Laptop liegen, dieser Stromklopper. Und das nervt halt ein bisschen. Du bist doch nicht so frei und flexibel.
Welchen Stromklopper?
Ich kann ja gar nicht...
Das Cinema-Display hat doch auch noch ein Netzteil.
Ach so, das sei doch nicht hier.
Doch, das ist doch auch ein Netzteil.
Der ist doch eingebaut oder nicht?
Ne, glaub ich nicht.
Doch, bei anderen Displays ist es auch eingebaut.
Echt, bei meinem alten, ich hab da noch so extra...
Wo ist denn hier mal, wo kann man sich denn mal hier... Ich weiß es nicht, wo kann man sich denn mal dieses Scheiß hier mal angucken?
Vielleicht auch bei iFixit.
Das ist ja auch wieder zwei Kabel.
Verstehe.
Bei meinem Display ist da nur ein Kabel, was eigentlich auch nicht schlecht ist, aber das ist halt...
Das ist doch so ein...
Uralt-ADC oder was?
Nein, 2007, das sieht genau so aus, aber ist noch das letzte, was ohne LEDs ist. Aber auch schon hier mit USB und Firewire und so weiter. Wobei der Nachfolger mit dem Mini-Displayport hatte ja schon kein Firewire mehr, ne?
Na jedenfalls, das ist es jetzt wieder.
Firewire, alles da, dreimal USB, Mini-Displayport.
Was heißt denn das? Wenn ich jetzt ein Mac Mini an das Teil anschließe, dann hab ich zweimal Ethernet und ich hab noch mal Firewire 800 und noch mal dreimal...
Ob du zweimal Ethernet hast, weiß ich ja noch nicht, aber...
Ist auch ein CD noch weg drin.
Na warum sollte ich nicht zweimal Ethernet haben? Weil das Teil hat ja schon Ethernet drin. Und wenn ich über Thunderbolt das anschließe und die Treiber dabei sind, und warum sollten sie die da weglassen, dann hast du zweimal Ethernet.
Könnte sein.
Und du hast noch Firewire. 800. Und was ist da noch?
Eingebautes DVD-Laufwerk.
Thunderbolt und USB. Na gut, wie auch immer. Also ich hätte das ganz gerne ohne Display für meinen MacBook Air. Also ich hätte nur dieses Teil da links unten von diesem Display, wo die Stecker sind, einfach als einzelnes Device.
So als Docking-Station per Kabel.
Genau.
So ist das wie ich dachte, dass es kommen wird. Aber Apple ist natürlich schlauer, die wollen ja viel Geld verdienen. Also kleben sie noch ein Display mit dran, weil es kostet eh nix und wollen 1000 Dollar.
Ja, naja gut.
Sagen wir mal so, Apple wird sich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht sonderlich bemühen, wobei so richtig überrascht, wenn sie das doch machen, werde ich jetzt auch nicht, jeden Kleinscheiß anzubieten. Zumal ja solche Adapter auch schon angepriesen wurden, und zwar schon vor einiger Zeit. Und jetzt wäre es mal interessant zu sehen, ob es da jetzt irgendwelche Aktualisierungen gibt, nämlich von Sonnet Technologies. Die hatten schon vor einiger Zeit, nämlich als das mit Thunderbolt alles so losging, auf irgendeiner Messe mal groß losgekotzt, was sie doch alles rausbringen wollen. Jetzt gibt es hier auch eine Seite, sehe ich gerade. Okay, das heißt immer noch Upcoming Thunderbolt Products. Genau, die versprechen hier zum Beispiel das Echo Express PCIe 2.0 Expansion-Chassis.
Was dich interessiert damit, dass du deine PCI-Karte verbauen kannst, die du haben willst.
Das wäre zum Beispiel eine Option, dann bräuchte ich keinen Mac Pro, sondern würde auch ein Mac Mini reichen, mit so einem Chassis über Thunderbolt. Dann hätte ich auch, was ich brauche.
Ja, aber dann hast du aber auch so einen dicken Kasten gekauft, der kostet bestimmt ein paar hundert Dollar, könnte ich schwören.
Achso, na gut, Preise sind jetzt hier noch nicht dabei, aber ein paar hundert Dollar ist immer noch was anderes als ein paar tausend Dollar.
Ja, aber den Mac Mini musst du ja auch bezahlen, so ist ja nicht das...
Ja gut, aber den Mac Mini kostet 600 und Mac Pro geht wohlos, 2,3 oder so.
Ja, aber dafür hast du auch ein richtig geiles Ding.
Ich find den Mac Mini auch geil. Ich mein, ich will ein bisschen Audio hin und her machen, dafür brauch ich jetzt nicht so eine High-End 16-Core. Würde sicherlich nicht...
Als Verkäufer hätten wir dich jetzt.
Was mir jetzt fehlt, ist... Moment, haben sie es jetzt hier noch mal drin? Ah, das ist ja schön. Jetzt habt ihr wieder das eine Produkt, was ihr mir versprochen habt, ist jetzt nicht mehr auf eurer Seite. Scheiße! Wo ist mein Ethernet-Anschluss? Sie haben nämlich eigentlich einen Thunderbolt-to-Gigabit-Ethernet-Adapter versprochen. Davon ist jetzt hier nichts mehr zu sehen.
Wo brauchst du den für deinen R?
Dafür meinen R. Das ist für mich der Grund, warum ich das R mit Thunderbolt aktualisiert haben wollte. Damit ich da einfach einen Stecker reinstecken kann, so wie ich jetzt hier in meinem USB ein Ethernet dran habe. Da kommt halt Fast Ethernet raus. Hätte ich ganz gerne das Ganze mit Thunderbolt und Ethernet.
Ich muss erst mal erklären, was Fast Ethernet ist. Die denken, es ist noch schneller als das, was sie selber haben.
Da streicht er sich durch seinen grauen Bart.
Also damals im Klondike.
Hört mal zu, Kinders.
Da hieß es, Ethernet-Verkabelung hieß, dass wir dieses Coaxial-Kabel zusammenstecken. Wenn schon, dann muss man auch richtig anfangen. Auf jeden Fall, normales Ethernet ist halt 10 Megabit, fast Ethernet ist 100 Megabit. Und heutzutage hat man halt Gigabit Ethernet. Und demnächst kommt auch 10 Gigabit Ethernet und auch das ist mit Thunderbolt halt machbar.
Ja, und dann kommt Fiber to the desk.
Das glaub ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich glaub, dass diese ganzen Copper-Solutions, die werden auch einfach weiterhin.
Aber die gehen halt nicht unendlich weit, ne?
Das haben wir bisher von allen Steckern gesagt. Und irgendwie haben sie es, auch bei Gigabit Ethernet hieß es am Anfang, das geht ja nicht unendlich weit, da brauchen wir irgendwie noch FDDI und was nicht alles.
Du kannst so nur 1-2 Meter machen, so im Rack von einem Rechner zum anderen. Inzwischen geht es 20 Meter durch meine ganze Bude.
Ja eben.
Und hast mal getestet, dass du ein Gigabit kriegst? Aber da fällt mir auf, warum zur Hölle gibt es kein USB 3 an den Macs? Also ich hätte eigentlich ein bisschen mit gerechnet, dass jetzt mal langsam dieses stinkende, langsame, schnarchende, beknackte USB 3, 2 da noch immer verbaut werden. Das ist ja furchtbar. Na wieso wollen die kein USB 3? Also die sitzen mit Intel sowieso schon in einem...
Besser als Ethernet Thunderbolt Adapter.
Oh der ist ja schön.
Voll der dicke Klopper.
Hier kam gerade der Link. Also zur NAB 2011 haben sie das angekündigt. Das war die Messe. Das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. Und da haben sie auch die anderen, die jetzt auf der anderen Seite sind. Plus Allegro Firewire 800 Thunderbolt Adapter und Presto Gigabit Ethernet Thunderbolt Adapter. Das ist in der Tat hässlich, aber da würde ich auch noch leben können.
Das ist ja schlecht gerendert auch noch. Nur, was kriegen sie vielleicht am Ende auch kleiner hin, falls sie es überhaupt tun wollen?
Ja...
Ich will USB 3. Naja, weil halt irgendwie 90% der Peripherie da draußen so rumkeucht und fleucht, ja.
Behauptet, USB 3 zu haben.
Nee, macht halt schon sehr viel USB. Und dann so USB 3-Sticks oder externe Festplattenhäuser gibt es ja auch sehr viel. Also ich hätte jetzt nichts persönlich gegen USB 3.
Es gibt viel USB 3?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich sehe, dass so die PC-Leute da so irgendwie jetzt alle mit USB 3 am Start sind.
Ah, wie spannend.
Die Boards haben das schon, aber haben das auch schon Geräte und so?
Jaja, die Thinkpads kommen glaube ich mit USB 3 und so. Also ich glaube, das geht da jetzt so richtig in Roll-Out.
Na, das wird sicherlich genauso problemlos funktionieren wie USB 2.0 am Anfang, ne?
Kann ich mich nicht mehr daran erinnern. War das problemlos, frei, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Natürlich war das nicht problemlos.
Ja, ist mir egal. Ich depende ja nicht auf USB so in dem Sinne, wie die PC-Menschen, aber so eine schnelle USB-Schnelle.
Ich stehe einfach auf Synchrone Interfaces, muss ich sagen. Und dieses USB...
Ja, dass das irgendwie technologisch total minderwertiger Dreck ist, ist mir ja klar. Aber es gibt halt viel USB-Devices.
Ich wüsste jetzt überhaupt kein einziges Device.
Ich will auf USB-Stick mit mehr als 20 MB die Sekunde schreiben.
Lauter SATA-Adapter mit USB 3.
Schneller? USB-Sticks, hallo, 20 MB die Sekunde. Das ist ja nicht alles, was so geht mit Random Access Memory.
Na Thunderbolt-Sticks.
Ja, Firewire-Sticks gab's auch nie.
Das kann natürlich jetzt wieder passieren.
Aber das ist halt das Ding so. Also ich hätte gerne auch einfach USB 3-Sticks, die eben einfach schneller sind. Oder mal so eine externe Festplatte von irgendjemanden, wo man nicht nur mit 20 MB die Sekunde schreiben kann. Das ist 21. Jahrhundert.
Ich hab auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Apple mit diesen SD-Cards, wann sind die jetzt eingestiegen mit diesen SD-Cards? Also sie sind eingestiegen, also es ist mehr, da bin ich ja schon wieder fast vorbei.
Ich hab noch nie eine SD-Card in mein Mac gesteckt.
Doch, ich auch. Letztes Jahr so eine 16 MB hatte ich, glaube ich, oder so mit so einer alten Kamera noch. Hat funktioniert. Oder waren es 128 irgendwie auf jeden Fall? Minimal.
Ich benutze das auch nicht so richtig. Also wenn sie dann schon so superior Schnittstellen machen, dann sollen sie die halt auch für billig rauskloppen, dass jeder Arsch und sein Bruder, hätte ich beinahe gesagt, irgendwie halt auch devices dafür baut. Und wir nicht da wieder in dieser komischen teuren Mac-Ecke drin stecken und keine Devices dafür kriegen, die irgendwie einigermaßen sinnvoll zu bezahlen sind. Ich hab keinen Bock immer im Gravis oder sonstwo die Firewire-Pendalty zu bezahlen.
Tja, wird spannend. Ich ähm...
Du bist wieder abgelenkt, weil du schon auf der falschen Seite bist.
Nö, jetzt schickt mir gerade jemand was mit USB 3.0 hier in diesen Video-Capture-Karten von Blackmagic. Zum Beispiel gibt es USB 3.0.
Die bauen auch echt krasse Zeug dieses Magics.
Aber die haben auch schon genauso Thunderbolt angekündigt. Wobei das ein bisschen teurer ist. Ob das nun am Thunderbolt liegt, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber du weißt doch, hier externe Festplattengehäuse, die haben die ganze Zeit immer so ein Fofi oder so, haben die einfach mehr gekostet, nur weil Firewire drin war.
Ja, und ich weigere mich geradezu glauben, dass Sie jetzt diesen selben Firewire-Fehler noch mal machen wollen.
Momentan sieht es aber allerdings, ehrlich gesagt, danach aus. Also bis jetzt habe ich einen...
Naja, nicht ganz, weil der Chip, den Sie da verbauen, im neuen MacBook, er ist ja ein Intel-Chip, der da das Thunderbolt macht.
Das ist ja mal das Intel auf Ihrer Seite.
Ja, aber Intel hat da irgendwie auch noch ein eigenes Ding am Machen, oder? Da kommt doch demnächst auch noch ein neuer Standard raus.
Ja, und hier sagt auch gerade einer im Chat, dieses 50-Euro-Kabel da, also... Das ist halt, ist ja ganz schön.
Da hab ich aber auch geguckt, warum das voll ist, weil...
Ja, ja, ist ja auch alles gut und schön, aber ist... So für Casual Computing, ja, irgendwie immer mal so, ich brauch mal so ein Kabel, ja, ka-ching.
Wie lang ist denn das?
Das wüsste ich auch nicht.
Zwei Meter, glaub ich.
Ein zwei Meter Kabel, 50 Euro?
Das wüsste ich auch nicht, also...
Ja, aber da geht halt auch zehn Gigabyte drüber und du kannst da hinten halt dann wirklich deine PCI-Karte ranstecken. Also da geht schon ordentlich was rüber an Speed.
Zwei Meter, 50 Euro? Schon...
Ist schon sportlich, ja.
Ist sportlich, ja, würde ich auch sagen. Das geht schon so ein bisschen in diese Hi-Fi-Region mit so vergoldeten und geweihten Steckverbindungen und so.
Ich meine, da ist ja immerhin noch richtig auch was drin, was vielleicht diesen Preis rechtfertigt. Aber so als Casual Computing Connector Standard und so weiter, wenn das so die Antwort jetzt ist, da hätte ich schon nichts gegen USB 3 für mal so eben so ein Stick oder so eine komische Platte.
Das ist halt für Pros. Der normale User wird sich ein Thunderbolt-Display kaufen, da ist das Kabel ja mit dran. Und dann hat er da sein Internet und sein Zeug.
Und sein USB 2, super.
Ja, und aber Fireware 800, super.
Da gibt es auch keine Sticks für. In deinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn.
Hauptsache, ich kriege mal ein Gigabit-Internet.
Aber Gigabit ist auch zu langsam mit SSD, ist dir das schon mal aufgefallen? Also du sitzt so da und denkst dir, ja, was jetzt hier, 80, 90 Megabit die Sekunde, das ist alles so. Irgendwie die SSD schaukelt sich die 10. Also ich will jetzt 10 Gigabit jetzt auch.
Ich brauch das halt hier für mein Audionetz. Das ist halt einfach, da geht es gar nicht so sehr um die Geschwindigkeit, sondern vielmehr um das Verhalten von Gigabit, was bei Fars Internet nicht gegeben ist. Und dann kann ich mich halt hier in meinem Audionetzwerk auch mit meinem R draufklemmen. Das ist zwar jetzt nicht so das dringendste Problem, fände ich aber trotzdem cool. Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall hat mir das neue MacBook Air genug neue Features, als dass ich da sofort Kaufkreiz entwickelt hab.
Um mal die Erzählschleife wieder zu Ende zu bringen. Nach dem Bogen gekriegt.
Zu Mac Mini noch was sagen?
Na, gab's einen neuen Mac Mini auch noch?
Ja, ohne CD-Docs verkehrt.
Ah stimmt, da hab ich auch was gelesen. Ja, den hab ich nicht so verfolgt, das Gerät bisher.
600 Euro?
Nee, aber ich find's auch, ich find's sehr schön, dass jetzt auch mal diese CD-Laufwerke rauskanten. Oder diese DVD-Laufwerke.
Äh, sind bei dem Quadro hier aber auch nochmal machen sollen, oder?
Wir wollen ja nach wie vor MacBook Pro Air, ne? Der ist nicht gepaart, glaube ich, mit Steve, diese Kontrolle. Nee, ist alle.
Ja, Steve, erhöre uns, wir wollen hier das MacBook Pro Air plus Xtreme.
Ich wollte HAL um.
Ach so, HAL, ja, HAL müsste eigentlich gehen.
Aber es ist alle hier.
Wie immer.
Es blinkt nicht.
Ach so, es ist alle.
Wir könnten mal wieder eine Sendung über Batterien machen.
Ja, die halten nicht lang genug hier irgendwie.
Aber das ist nur in den V-Modes, oder?
Naja, kann schon sein.
Sie sehen diese Augen wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit.
Also Mac Mini finde ich an sich auf jeden Fall ein sehr schönes Gerät.
Ich auch, ich überlege auch immer wieder, ob ich das irgendwie gebrauchen könnte.
Das ist ein Grundeinfeld, dass man es kaufen kann, ja?
Ja, aber es ist bisher......ist äh......ist sie nicht so richtig. Es ist überhaupt so. Ein weiterer Computer ist immer... Ich meine, sie haben ja mittlerweile jetzt eine Menge nachgerüstet. So, was ich immer beklagt habe. Nö, jetzt so mit iCloud und tra-la-la. Und das Screensharing ist noch ein bisschen besser geworden. Aber du kannst einfach immer noch nicht einfach zwei Macs nebeneinander stellen und sagen, hier, SYNKE DICH! SYNKE DICH! Sei eins! Sei eins, ja, ohne die Wolke.
Mit deiner Private-Wolke.
Es muss halt jetzt wieder mit Wolke sein, ne?
So.
Ja, mit...
Jetzt kann ich dich hier stumm schalten, jetzt kann ich dir aber auch... sag mal was.
Jetzt mach ich ganz laut, nein, jetzt mach nicht wieder das Audio-Setup kaputt, jetzt geh ich weg.
Jetzt. Was, du bist weg?
Musstest du mit diesen scheiß V-Modes anfangen? Also ich hör mich nicht.
Ich hör den Huckel, der Huckel ist raus.
Doch, jetzt hör ich mich wieder. Aber leise. Sehr leise.
Du verschwindest jetzt auch. Na jetzt weiß ich zumindest, was der Auslöser ist.
Na wir reden einfach weiter, den Huckel brauche ich keiner.
Also die Chat-Hörer meinen ja, sie hören mich noch.
Ja, über mein Mikro ist doch klar.
Aber du bist leise geworden, stimmt's?
Ja, über mein Mikro. Wenn ich mein Mikro mal ein bisschen abschotte, dann hört man dich nämlich nicht mehr.
Richtig, sonst Huckel?
Ist ja interessant.
Also liebe Hörer, wir rebooten mal kurz die Sendung.
Warte mal, ich mach mal was ganz...
Ich halte mir mal die Kopfhörer vom Ohr weg. Tim tippt aufs Dein Spiel.
Du hast jetzt aber sehr gewagt, was ich mache.
Ja, voll spannend.
Soll ich mal?
Ist aber sehr laut.
Hallo.
Wir sind für alle wieder weg.
Ja, ich glaube, jetzt ist es wieder gut.
Gut, jetzt weiß ich zumindest, wo das Problem ist, oder dass da ein Problem ist. Wir lassen jetzt mal die V-Modes schön beiseite. Irgendwas ist da kaputt. Jetzt bin ich nur auf rechts recht gerade. Na, das werden wir mal beheben hier.
Mac Mini hat unseren Segen, aber wir wissen nicht, wofür wir ihn gebrauchen können. Also in der Firma ist er halt ganz gut, als kleiner Fileserver und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin jetzt auch lauter wieder.
Das war ja der Sinn der ganzen Sache.
Aber jetzt bin ich lauter, als ich vorher war.
Ja, ich finde als... Hier, so ein Mac ist ja eine Kiste, wo ich immer davor sitze. Und irgendwie zwei davon brauche ich eigentlich nicht.
Aber zum Beispiel, weißt du, so ein Club als...
Dann bräuchte ich wirklich so einen Sync-Scheiß.
Oder so im Club als Medienabspiel-Rechner und so, weißt schon. Screen Sharing Ruf, Klick, Peng.
Ist mir egal, ob die da mit ihrem Linux immer versagen. Eigentlich kriegen wir das ja hin jetzt da.
Ja, wenn es mal nicht Full HD ist.
Seitdem wir das mal da gemanagt haben, geht das eigentlich. Wir sind doch mal dahin, haben da irgendwie VLC und dann hier Gamma einstellen und plötzlich gignalet. Das geht schon. Und jetzt ist es auch erst wieder gemacht.
Jetzt, wo Linux 3.0 ist.
Rockt voll unsere Sendung hier, wa? Irgendwie kommen wir noch nicht so richtig in Wallung heute.
Machst du meine Kopfhörer noch ein bisschen leiser wieder?
Meiner auch.
Wenn sie müde sind, schmerzt sie.
Ich hab an deinen Kopfhörern überhaupt nichts verstellt.
Liebe Hörer, eine Zerreißprobe. Naja, das war's. Jetzt ist es wieder super.
Die machen ja ganz schön was mit, die Hörer, die werden hier gequält.
Ja, ja, das ist alles schwierig.
Das ist die Mobile-Max-Folterstunde heute.
Okay, also Mac Mini ist auch neu. Was haben wir denn, was gibt es denn noch neu?
Betriebssystem.
Ich glaube, bei der Hardware war es das erst mal, ne?
Also Thunderbolt Display hatten wir ja, dann Mac Mini, dann Macbook Air. Ja, mir fällt mir da auch nicht ein. Lion.
Und kannst du es noch lionen? Du tust dich schwer, ne?
Aber nur wegen Spaces?
Also das mit dem Scrollen, ich dachte auch erst mit der Richtung, aber das macht schon Sinn, weil mir ist das schon auch ab und zu passiert, dass ich irgendwie so wie auf dem iPhone halt, beim iPhone ist es glaube ich gar nicht so schlimm, sondern es ist schlimmer, wenn man halt ein iPad benutzt, weil man da irgendwie noch so viel mehr irgendwie das Gefühl hat, dass man es so benutzt wie ein Mac. Und dann hatte ich es auch schon gehabt, dass ich irgendwie den Inhalt auf so ein Fenster am liebsten auch drauf touchen will, auf meinen MacBook Pro, um etwas nach oben zu schieben. Deswegen mit dem Scrollen dachte ich, macht Sinn und habe mich auch versucht zu zwingen, diese umgedrehte Scroll-Richtung zu benutzen. Aber jetzt, seitdem ich das Line für ein paar Tage habe, also die Scrollbalken fehlen mir schon. Und das mit dem Scrollen, wenn dann wiederum auch die Scroll...
Kannst du einschalten, dass die Scrollbalken da sind.
Ja, habe ich ja auch gemacht. Seitdem ich das gemacht habe, stört es mich jetzt doch wieder, dass ich in die andere Richtung scrolle, als die Scrollbalken sich dann bewegen. Also ist das alles irgendwie so...
Also reine Gewöhnungssache. Ich hab jetzt vor ein paar Tagen umgestellt, ich hab auch erst auf Snow Lepard schon Scroll-Reverser eingeschaltet.
Damit du schon mal vorgewärmt bist.
Und ich bin schon fast da.
Ich bin auch da, aber ich bin noch...
Irgendwann wird dir die andere... Irgendwann wirst du vor so einem Windows-Rechner stehen und sagen, was denn das für ein Scheiß. Das scrollt ja alles falsch rum.
Also ich benutze den jetzt seit drei Wochen, den Lyone oder so, an dem Dreh, und ich merke das ja nicht mehr.
Also du schubst halt das Papier.
Ja, das ist schon klar. Aber dass diese Scrollbalken weg waren, das ging mal gar nicht, weil die braucht man wirklich. Also es gibt ja diesen Syracuse, dieses Buch da, was er veröffentlicht hat. Ich habe ja mehr oder weniger ein Buch. Und der schreibt ja auch, Scrollbalken ist eben nicht nur wie beim iPhone, dass man es weglässt, weil man irgendwie Platz sparen muss, sondern man hat wirklich genug Platz und ich brauche die Information. Ich will wissen, wo ich bin, wenn ich durch meterlange Source-Codes durchscrollen will, dann mache ich das auch nicht mit meinem Wheel oder mit dem Nippel auf meiner Magic-Mighty-Tralala-Maus, sondern dann will ich den Scroll-Balk nehmen, weil der ist einfach am schnellsten. Und dann brauche ich das, dass ich den direkt anklicken kann. Und das wäre zum Beispiel bei...
Warte mal, den gibt es doch noch, den Scroll-Balken. Ich weiß gar nicht, was dir fehlt.
Ja, ich hab ihn noch wieder eingeschaltet. Ich will nur darüber lästern, dass man den nicht einfach so weglassen kann.
Ich finde, den kann man weglassen.
Ich finde nicht, dass man den weglassen kann. Ich brauch den.
Das ist, glaube ich, eine sehr große Geschmacksfrage, auch in dem Fall.
Kann schon sein.
Die älteren Herren, so wie der Syracusa und du, die Traditionalisten?
Diese Information fehlt mir einfach.
Das ist das Problem.
Gegen die Optik, das ist mir alles Schnuppe. Wie gesagt, ich hab ihn jetzt eingeschaltet. Man kann ihn ja einschalten und auch nicht mit irgendeinem Default, sondern man kann ja irgendwo im General Preferences da, kann man ihn ja wieder einschalten und dann geht's eigentlich auch.
Wir können ja erstmal darüber reden, was uns gefällt.
Also was mir am deutlichsten aufgefallen ist bisher, was wirklich heraussticht an Positiven, ist, was aber nicht ein Line-Feature ist, sondern ist halt der Safari 5.1. Also der hab ich echt das Gefühl, das flutscht einfach wie Sau.
Den haben sie auch komplett. Ist das jetzt mit dem neuen Webkit?
Gibt es aber jetzt für Snow Leopard auch, ne? So was noch flutscht, muss ich dir wirklich sagen, weil... Also ich hab hier dieses...
Das sollte man mal sagen, warum das so ist.
Na, weil die bei dem Webkit 2 ist...
Es gibt jetzt einen separaten Prozess, der den Content hält, der auch in der Sandbox liegt. Der heißt dann auch Safari Web Content. Und der Safari, der Browser sozusagen, das Programm, das du benutzt, ist nur so ein Viewport quasi. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Link genau funktioniert.
Und davon hat man pro Winde oder pro Tab auch dann einen so einen Prozess, richtig?
Das weiß ich nicht genau, ist das so?
Na doch, wenn einer abkackt, dann kackt nur der ab und nicht die anderen mit.
Ah ja, wie bei Chrome.
Ne, eben nicht ganz, weil bei Chrome, wie bei Chrome, die starten sozusagen mehrere WebKit-1-Dinger selber. Und der WebKit 2, der kümmert sich aber selber um diese Verteilung. Das heißt, innerhalb von Safari gibt es einen WebKit 2, der dann mehrere Rendering-Ports oder wie auch immer aufmacht. Also die haben es direkt in das WebKit integriert. Und da es aber Chrome schon ein bisschen länger macht und damals noch kein WebKit 2 gab, haben die das außendrum rumgeklebt.
Aber wie viele Prozesse entstehen jetzt tatsächlich? Also wenn ich jetzt einen neuen Tab mache, wer erzeugt einen neuen Prozess? Erzeugt der Safari einen neuen Prozess? Oder erzeugt der Safari Web Content nochmal mehrere Prozesse? Weil die sehe ich hier nicht.
Ich glaube, man kann ja auch nicht nur gucken, dass du ein neues Tab aufmachst und da kommt ein neuer Prozess. So wird es nicht sein. Ich denke, da feuern sogar mehrere.
Ich sehe jetzt hier nur zwei. Die irgendwie Safari heißen irgendwie. Du wirst jetzt nicht, was hier sonst noch dazugehören könnte.
Ja.
Das andere ist mir wohl vertraut.
Das stand aber glaube ich auch in dem Syracusa auch als Beispiel drin im Post.
Als Beispiel für was?
Na, wie dieser Delegation-Prozess und wie die da alle heißen.
Naja, ich bin einfach noch nicht durchgekommen. Das ist wirklich zum Heulen. Ich meine, wer noch nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, wir reden natürlich von diesem mittlerweile schon legendären Mac OS X-Review von John Syracusa, was der schon seit den ersten Versionen, ersten Developer-Versionen von Mac OS X macht. Und der da einfach einen technischen Level anlegt, den man eigentlich relativ selten sieht. Also für meinen Geschmack könnt ihr noch weiter ausholen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ganz gute Quelle, um das zu verstehen.
Ja, auch gerade wenn es um die Änderungen am Filesystem und Security-Features oder irgendwie Cocoa-C-Geschichten geht, da holt er dann eben auch mal die Pfeile raus und schabt am Metall. Das macht eigentlich wirklich sonst niemand.
Na, wir werden uns das nochmal genauer anschauen. Ihr habt es komplett gelesen irgendwie?
Wollt ihr da nochmal ein bisschen berichten?
Also bestimmte Sachen habe ich so ein bisschen überflogen, aber...
Filesystem?
Nee, das ist halt nicht überflogen.
Ja, das hast du wahrscheinlich im Detail gelesen.
Schon?
Ja, dann her mit dem...
Na, Filesystem selbst, gibt es nichts Neues? Nada Null?
Also On Disk.
Wie On Disk?
Also das HFS Plus ist unverändert.
Das ist unverändert, aber sie haben da so eine Art, naja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das schon Volume-Manager nennen kann, aber so eine Unterschicht drunter gebastelt, die Core Storage heißt. Und das ist die Sache, die sich ums Encrypten kümmert gerade. Da kann man auch mit DiskUtil in einer Command-Line, also es war ja auch in diesem Artikel drin, genau, DiskUtil CS-List machen, das heißt Core Storage List, und dann kriegt man so ein bisschen eine andere Ansicht auf seine Volumes.
Ja, das war doch auch, dass man mit diesem Core Storage halt mehrere Platten zu einem Volumen und so theoretisch zusammenfassen könnte und so eine Geschichten.
CS-List.
DiskInfo-Lehrzeichen, CS-Lehrzeichen-List.
Und dann die Core Storage-List. Ja, muss man aber nicht austippen.
Ja, also ich denke mal, das ist irgendwie der Anfang von was auch immer die da so groß vorhaben. Aber am HFS Plus hat sich erstmal nichts geändert. Aber die machen da das Krypto, während das da drüber das HFS Plus kriegt gar nichts mit und darunter wird sozusagen alles kryptomäßig umgewandelt.
Das finde ich wirklich klasse.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch schon Industriestandard. Da sind sie ein bisschen spät dran sowieso, aber...
Was ist es so on the fly geht?
Ist bei Ubuntu und so ist das schon so. Sehr, also in Informationszeitalter, jahre gemessen doch sehr lange. Haben wir das schon. Also da war 5Volt wirklich stinkender Scheiß dagegen. Naja, also das, was ich ja ganz spannend fand, was aber angeblich auch schon in iOS so war, ist ja, dass sie so mit Prozessen jetzt so ein bisschen anders umgehen. Das heißt, wenn du, wenn das OS der Meinung ist, dass ein Prozess nicht benutzt wird mehr von dir, dass wir den halt auch einfach killen von sich aus. Und wenn du ein Programm beendest, dann lassen sie es aber gegebenenfalls noch ein bisschen länger laufen. Und falls du es gleich wieder startest, ist es halt eigentlich auch noch da und du hast es snap sofort wieder auf dem Screen. Also so, da so die User-Bevormundung, ja, ok, du hast zwar jetzt quittgesagt, aber ich halte das mal noch ein bisschen im Speicher, falls du gleich nochmal klickst oder ja, komm, das Programm hast du jetzt drei Stunden nicht mehr angefasst, das kill ich mal weg. Lassen die da auch die Programme, ja ok, lassen natürlich die Programme noch so im...
Ja, die sind halt einfach suspended und wenn sie nicht mehr gebraucht werden, werden sie erst aus dem RAM rausgeperched und wenn sie gebraucht werden, dann sind sie quasi schon da und müssen nicht erst wieder komplett aufgebaut werden aus den Files.
Genau, und das gibt es da jetzt auch. Und dann dieses Sandboxing-Feature ist halt genauso wie beim Safari, eben auch bei Preview, wo zum Beispiel der PDF-Renderer in so einem Sandbox-Extraprozess läuft. Oder bei QuickTime, was ja auch immer so ein Einfalls... Also eigentlich Preview als PDF-Viewer und QuickTime als Media Player, so sind ja die Einfallstore für die ganzen Exploiter. Und da sind jetzt zum Beispiel der Decoder und so weiter, laufen alle in Sandboxen. Das heißt, du startest ein Preview, lädst ein PDF und das wird aber eigentlich von so einem Sandbox-Prozess gerendert, damit falls da Exploited-Food drin ist, dann der da schön in der Sandbox sich aus-exploiten kann und dein PDF da trotzdem sicher gerendert werden kann.
Fragt man sich warum... Also vielleicht erinnert sich das mit iOS 5 dann auch, dass wir das da auch machen, aber dass jetzt auch das letzte iOS wieder mal so locker vom Hocker weggehauen werden konnte, von so einem bekloppten PDF-Exploit. Das finde ich ja schon bedenklich.
Und es gibt jetzt eben die AP dafür, dass das halt alle Leute im Prinzip tun können. Und irgendwann wird ja das auch Pflicht, dass diese Apps im App-Store alles Sandbox sind. Und dann haben wir letztens gemunkelt, dass es dann so ist, dass der User mit seinen Intents sozusagen festlegt, was sie abdann darf in ihrer Sandbox und was nicht. Das heißt, wenn du dann sagst, du klickst jetzt auf Recent Documents, dann in dem Moment, da fällt die App ab, da auch immer aus der Sandbox raus oder was auch immer. Und Recent Documents anzeigen und so eine Geschichten. Das heißt, da gibt es nicht die nervigen Windows-Dialoge. Sind sie sicher?
Wollen sie das?
Ja, wollen sie das? Das könnte jetzt...
Wenn sie das nicht wollen, wird es nicht funktionieren. Wenn sie es wollen, wird alles ganz unsicher.
Genau. Und ich finde das einen spannenden Ansatz. Ich frage mich schon auch so ein bisschen, ob das nicht dann unsicherer ist. Wenn man so einen kleinen Apple-Script-Virus schreibt, der dann auf die Menü-Items klickt und dann... Na ja, weiß man nicht. Na ja, auf jeden Fall schon ganz spannend, dass sie jetzt so die Sachen da mal ein bisschen durchgezogen haben. Dann hier Address Randomization war ja eh schon klar. Das sind so erstmal so ein paar Sachen, die ich da aus diesem Artikel ganz spannend fand. Ich guck grad nochmal ins Inhaltsverzeichnis, was ich schon noch vergessen hab. Privilege Separation, ja, das kommt ja mit diesem Sandboxing. Dann irgendwie ist ja angeblich auch Resolution Independence wieder nochmal ein Stück vorangekrochen. Ja, es geht ja auch so wirklich in Zentimeterschritten voran, aber da gab es auch einen Abschnitt in dem Review dazu, dass da jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen mehr geht. Aber es ist alles nur so, es ist immer noch nicht vollständig, ja. Und, naja, Autosafe und so hatten wir ja alles letztes Mal auch schon durchgekaut und es ist ja auch genauso, wie sie es gezeigt haben. Und das Einzige, was halt der Seracusa dann noch berechtigterweise sagt, ist zwar alles gut und schön und eigentlich ist es auch super, dass Apple da die Abstraktion immer noch weiter treibt und die User ja wirklich eigentlich vieles gar nicht verstehen müssen, um so einen Computer zu benutzen. Aber dass halt im Gegensatz zu iOS es jetzt erstmal noch eine ganze Zeit lang sogenannten Hodgepodge gibt, nämlich die Apps, die sich an alles halten und alles schick machen und die Apps, die halt nichts von dem machen. Weder Sandboxing noch Autosafe noch Versioning noch irgendwas. Und dass es jetzt halt nicht für neue User eine komplett gestreamgliente Experience ist, wie beim iOS, sondern eben Hodgepodge.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine grundsätzliche Schwierigkeit, die Entwickler da mitzukriegen, wobei ich den Eindruck habe, dass sie noch nie so gut aufgestellt waren, so viele Änderungen auch wirklich durchdrücken zu können. Vieles ist ja auch gestorben mit diesem Mangel in Support. Ich denke mal an Power-Talk, damals noch System 7 und so eine Sache, wo viele Ideen schon realisiert waren, die jetzt gerade auch erst wieder dazukommen. Was weiß ich, so Inboxing und Files sind wie AirDrop. Und so haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber geredet. Aber das hat dann einfach überhaupt, das haben sie auch vom Marketing her total verkackt, das war auch technisch alles wahrscheinlich nicht da, wo es sein muss, aber dieses Problem, dass man eine Technologie immer so händereimäßig durchdrücken muss. Und dass man es dann auch mal mit solchen Boliden wie Adobe und Microsoft zu tun hat, die überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran haben, sowas einzubauen, weil ihnen das eigentlich nicht hilft.
Ich glaube aber, Microsoft wird auf jeden Fall im App Store releasen, wenn sie es nicht sogar schon teilweise haben. Und hier gab es jetzt Photoshop Elements im Mac App Store. Das heißt, sie werden sich da auch zumindest so ein bisschen, also ok, Autosafe haben sie vielleicht jetzt alle noch nicht, aber zumindest so, wenn sie jetzt da releasen, dann werden sie sich ja schon generell darauf einlassen, auch dieses Sandboxing-Thema da mitzumachen. Und dann haben sie auf jeden Fall mit diesem App Store schon einen relativ großen Hebel, da erstmal alle zu mitzunehmen. Das ist schon ganz gut für Apple auf jeden Fall. Und dann sind halt super viele Kleinigkeiten, die mir jetzt schon aufgefallen sind, aber die ich mir natürlich nicht alle gemerkt habe. Zum Beispiel eine Sache, also eine Kleinigkeit weiß ich noch, und zwar im Terminal, wo ja sowieso viel verbessert wurde. Es gibt ja jetzt Ansi-Colors zu kustomisieren. Ah, gesegnet sei der Herr. Früher brauchte man dafür Symbol-Plugins. Und jetzt ist es so, wenn du ein Verzeichnis wechselst, also ganz oft beim Programmieren wechselt man halt so in sein Projektverzeichnis, macht einen Editor auf, was auch immer, und dann macht man Apple-T und dann ist das Tab wieder in deinem Home. Und du musst dann wieder CD, hast du nicht gesehen, XY. Ich wollte mir ja schon mal einen Skript dafür schreiben, dass ich sag, hier, wenn ich in dieses Ordner-Line wechsle, dann mach mir gleich 23 Tabs da auf. Und jetzt, wenn du im selben Fenster sozusagen ein neues Tab öffnest, dann ist das im selben Fahrt gleich automatisch. Das sind so Kleinigkeiten, wo man dann so da ist und denkt, Daumen hoch!
Ja, dann macht das auch mal total Sinn mit dem Tab.
Und dieses Window Resize on all Corners ist auch, dass man da so lange drauf warten musste wieder.
Ja, das versteh ich auch nicht. Setz mal wieder dein Mikrofon auf.
Ja, die Linux-Jungs können das doch auch, oder? Bestimmt.
Bestimmt, die kommen bestimmt in zwei Richtungen gleichzeitig vergrößert.
Terminal-Technologie ist wirklich sehr ausgereift unter Unix.
Aber da gibt es ja jetzt hier dieses eine Terminal, was einen Blur macht. Also nicht nur transparenten Hintergrund, sondern auch noch Blur. Das sieht auch sehr fancy aus.
Sieht auch aus wie Windows 7.
Was meinst du, das eine Terminal ist so ein Preset oder was?
Ja, es gibt ein Preset, wo du so einen Blur-Hintergrund hast. Geht gar nicht. Und wenn du den Fokus wegklickst, dann wird es durchsichtig.
Ach, der ist dahinter.
Ah, oh. Also ich könnte darauf nichts Sinnvolles tun. Das würde mich total... Finde ich aber ganz geil. Also früher, wenn man jung gewesen wäre, dann hätte man bestimmt seinen ganzen Desktop mit diesen Terminals gepflastert.
Das ist so eine Milchglas-Scheibe.
Gibt es immer noch ganz viele, die durchsichtige Terminals benutzen. Aber war ich irgendwie nie Fan von.
Noch mal kurz zu diesen Standard-Features. Also was ich ja schon vorher, bevor irgendwas über LINE gesagt wurde, hier schon häufiger mal beklagt habe, dass das irgendwie nicht da ist. Dieses alles speichert sich selbst. Das scheint ja jetzt langsam zu kommen. Und da sind wir natürlich auch genau bei diesen typischen Henne-Eye-Problemen. Also wie viele Programme wird es wohl bald geben, die das auch wirklich unterstützen, außer denen, die jetzt so standardmäßig dabei sind. Ich denke, daran wird sich eine Menge ablesen lassen. Eine meiner Lieblings-Macintosh-Buden war ganz fix. Und mein Lieblingsprogramm, mein Omni-Outliner, hat das schon. Ja, das ist einfach so praktisch. Und das finde ich mal wieder echt super. Weil was andere Leute mit Text-Edit machen, das ist halt mein Omni-Outliner. Da schreibe ich halt meine Ideen rein. Und jetzt kann ich das auch mal so lose reinschreiben, irgendwas sammeln, so wie Stickies eigentlich. Die Stickies haben ja schon immer so funktioniert. Nur dass die Stickies halt... Das braucht ja nix. Jetzt kann ich sogar meinen Rechner booten. Kommt dann mein Outliner auch wieder hoch?
Damit du ihn nicht ausgemacht hast, ja.
Wenn man Versionen unterstützt, unterstützt man damit auch automatisch Resume?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Das probier ich jetzt mal aus.
Oh Gott, jetzt Achtung, Stream festhalten.
Der Rechner hier ist ja separat, ne?
Ja, und wir sind jetzt schon so einige Kleinigkeiten aufgefallen, die da so ähnlich wie dieses Terminal und so, wo es schon schick ist. Und das ist insgesamt auch snappy, habe ich den Eindruck. Also ich habe ja drüber installiert, also der Excuse jetzt so von wegen, ja Clean Install ist ja immer schneller, zählt ja jetzt da in dem Fall nicht. Und irgendwie, gut, mit SSD merkt man eh nicht mehr so den Unterschied, aber irgendwie so der Finder, alles irgendwie, alles noch ein bisschen snappiger.
Das stimmt.
Aber ist ja drüber installiert.
Ja, aber bestimmte Files sind vielleicht auch einmal wieder sauber neu gespeichert worden. Ich weiß auch immer nicht, woran es liegt, aber es geht auch wieder schnell weg.
Aber sie haben halt auch so überall so ganz leichte, dezente Animationen, die auch noch so dieses Flüssigkeitsgefühl noch unterstützen. Also auch dieses Fenster, wuuh und fluff und wuff und...
Also das, wovon es überhaupt kein Freund ist.
Und hier im Safari die History so mit zwei Fingern hin und her schnacken, das macht alles so schnack, schnack und... Schön. Das klickt sich geil. Jetzt kriegen sie es immer wieder hin. Find ich schon.
Macht auf mich auch den Eindruck, ich hab jetzt einfach noch nicht so viel Hands-On-Erfahrung, deswegen kann ich jetzt hier auch nicht so richtig posen.
Damit, ne?
Und was man dann auch noch sagen muss, also als ich hier dieses Upgrade geklickt hab, das ging ja so super smooth. Also runterladen, installen, los geht's. Aber dann hab ich heute mal bei einem Kollegen zugeguckt, als der das so installiert hat.
Dat hat gedauert.
Er hatte eine Festplatte. Oh man, sind das arme Leute. Die armen Menschen. Mit diesem drehenden Metall in den Rechner. Das geht ja wirklich überhaupt gar nicht. Das hat eine Stunde oder so gedauert, bis der da fertig geroutet hat.
Also ich hab das einmal gemacht. Ich musste noch einmal booten, weil ich dieses File Vault, glaube ich, aufgegeben hab. Aber ausloggen musste ich mich. Booten musste ich gar nicht.
Du musstest ja noch den Trim Enabler, und dafür musstest du rebooten.
Ja, genau. Okay, aber den haben wir ja auch gleich gemacht. Und seitdem nicht mehr gebootet. Also der Install und das bestehende Gefahrverhältnis, irgendwie super. Wobei ich sagen muss, auch bei dem Snow Leopard kann ich mich jetzt schon an den letzten Colonel Panic nicht erinnern. Also, obwohl doch. Ich hab einmal hier Bitcoin-Mining probiert, und das ist ja so ein OpenCL-Tool, der da so ein bisschen Grafik irgendwie mit dem OpenCL-Halter irgendwie auf die Grafikkarte hämmert. Und da ist es mir einmal weggecrashed irgendwo drin. Aber sonst, also, ist das ganz schön stabil geworden, dieses OS, muss man ja schon sagen.
Also man kriegt schon echt das Gefühl, dass die doch wirklich sehr viel Arbeit da reinstecken, dass das halt nicht so zu bloated wie das eine oder andere, ne?
Naja, bloated finde ich es aber schon doch langsam. Also nicht, dass es dadurch langsam ist, das ist eigentlich alles noch okay. Also auch durch die SSD jetzt schon, merkt man es ja auch erstmal nicht. Aber so vom Umfang her ist es schon ganz schön bloated, was es alles so kann und macht und tut.
Na können darf es sehr viel, aber es soll halt nicht langsam dadurch werden. Und irgendwie behebe ich und irgendwie crashen und dependency-Höllen eröffnen und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt muss es noch den Text selektieren und gucken, ob die Selektion auch nach dem Boot noch da ist.
Aber auch, dass man zum Beispiel mal ein Terminal-Fenster, wenn man irgendwie runterfährt und man startet wieder, dass noch der alte Inhalt vom Terminal kommt. Selbst, also in Grau zwar nur, und man kann es glaube ich noch selecten und copy und paste machen. Also man sieht den halt noch, das ist schon cool.
Also es fühlt sich echt so ein bisschen mehr nach Zukunft wieder an.
Und jetzt ist ja das Terminal, auch wenn es im Dock ist, weiterhin live, so wie wir es vor 10 Jahren schon mal hatten. Das war ja ganz früher schon mal so. Dann haben sie es aber irgendwann abgeschaltet, mit 10.3 oder so, weiß nicht genau.
So, dann können wir eigentlich schon in die Glaskugel gucken, was dann jetzt als nächstes kommt. Was fehlt denn noch?
Sag mal, als diese erste Beta rauskam, da war doch alles voll mit diesen Text-to-Speech-Stimmen in tausend Sprachen.
Ja, gibt's jetzt auch. Kannst du klicken, aber das ist fett. Ich hab mir mal alle deutschen Stimmen angeklickt.
Die muss man sich runterladen.
Na, du klickst dir in Text-to-Speech, wähl mal die Stimme aus, und dann kannst du auch noch mehr auswählen, dann kommen diese Auswahl-Dialog. Und wenn du dann alle deutschen Stimmen anklickst, kommen da 3,4 Gigabyte Files runter, und dann hab ich erst mal abbrechen geklickt, weil mir das gerade doch zu viel war, aber... oder? Was war Universal Access?
Nee, es war bei...
bei Sound. Nee, was war bei Sound? Ja, genau, Speech. Und da kannst du dann Customize klicken, bei System Voices, und da kannst du dir dann alle möglichen Sprachen klicken. Hindi, Griechisch, also wirklich hier.
Wo sind die Deutschen?
Bei German. Anna, Steffi und Yannick. Wobei Yannick jetzt nicht unbedingt so der deutscheste Name ist, aber 3,4 GB für alle deutschen Stimmen.
This voice will be automatically downloaded. Ah, das ist ja interessant.
Okay, so machen sie das jetzt.
Cross? Die shopp ich mir mal.
Die gibt's kostenlos? 1,2 GB.
Echt, bei mir waren es 3,4.
Für drei Stimmen.
Ich hatte noch italienisch mit dabei.
Nee, ich hab wirklich nur die drei deutschen angeklickt. Vielleicht schon komprimiert mittlerweile.
Ja, das kann sein. Okay, dann hab ich das erledigt. Wo wir immer so auf File Vault den alten so rumhacken. Einen Vorteil hatte ja das alte File Vault.
Ja, kann ich dir genau sagen. Ich glaube, wenn du das meinst, und zwar, dass ich genau nur mein Home verschlüsselt hab, das heißt, wenn du nur noch einen zweiten User hatte, dann konnte der... Dann schalten die nämlich alle den gesamten frei, richtig?
Und dann bist du eigentlich nur noch auf die Permissions und so. Aber so konnte ich mir auch, sagen wir mal, auf irgendeinem anderen Rechner von irgendjemand mal so ein temporäres Home anlegen, mit 5 Volt verschlüsseln, da auch ruhig ein paar Keys und ein paar Passwörter fallen lassen. Und ich wusste, selbst wenn ich da nie wieder rankomme, und wenn der da irgendwie alle Fails auspackt, er kriegt nicht mehr als diesen einen Kryptoblob.
Wie falsch?
Na, der Master-Admin hat immer den Hauptzugang. Der kann den immer freischalten.
Stimmt.
Voll verloren.
Doch.
Wenn er sich das notiert hat.
Na klar, du musst ja nicht notieren, aber da musstest du aber dem 5 Volt erstmal das Master-Passwort eingeben für alle. Und dann hat jeder User noch sein eigenes gehabt. Das heißt, du hättest immer den Hauptadmin des Rechners fragen können. Du, mach mir mal meinen Pfeil Volt wieder auf. Ich hab's vergessen. Richtig.
Na, das ist recht. Nee, in dem Fall, bei mir war das nicht das Problem, weil ich derjenige war, der das da überhaupt eingeschaltet hat. Nee, stimmt. Aber trotz alledem, so dieses Shielding zwischen den Usern an sich, wär ganz cool. Weil jetzt kannst du halt für jeden User sagen, ob der auch die ganze Platte entschlüsseln darf. Aber du kannst halt nicht sagen, mit meinem Passwort meine Dateien, weil das halt so auf dem Level sicher überhaupt nicht realisieren ließe.
Da musstest du jetzt wieder dein eigenes Krypto-Image...
Ja, da musst du dein eigenes Krypto-Image, aber das geht halt dann wiederum nicht für die ganzen Systemdateien und so. Das ist halt schon was anderes.
Das ist schon was anderes.
Du hast auch recht, das ist auch nur eine Sicherheitssimulation, wenn man dieses Masterpasswort damit einberechnet.
Mensch, denn das hast du ja wieder voll ins Schwarze getroffen.
Ja, denn ist das ein Fuchs.
Ich bin auch gleich sofort aufgefallen.
Macht doch mal euren Safari auf. Euren tollen neuen. Und gebt mal nur apple.com ein. Nur apple.com.
Ja.
Und Enter drücken auch. So, und welche URL steht da jetzt da oben? www.apple.com Und was steht vor dem www?
Doppel.Doppelslash.
Bei dir steht HTTP.
Bei dir nicht?
Nee, bei mir steht immer HTTPS. Und ich wundere mich, woran das liegt.
Vielleicht bist du eingeloggt und hast eine sehr schön im Store.
apple.com eingeloggt?
Im Store oder Developer oder so?
Nee, Safari oder Quatsch, Firefox nutzt ihr nicht. Die haben ja auch so ein Auto SSL 2, oder? Oder gibt es das als Extension für Safari?
Ich kann dir das nicht beantworten. Ich weiß nur, ich tippe hier das ein. Okay, das ist vielleicht einfach bei mir in den Top-Hits einfach so. Ich dachte eine Weile, sie leiten einen automatisch auf HTTPS um. Das tun sie aber offensichtlich nicht.
Nee, nee.
Aber immerhin kann man da...
Das hätte im Syracusa drin gestanden, aber den hast du ja nicht gelesen.
Nee, das habe ich nicht gelesen. Deswegen, das ist bei mir nicht an. Wie kommt das in meine Top-Hits rein?
Außen Top-Hits, innen Geschmack.
Haben sie diese Top-Hit? Vielleicht haben sie die URL schon mit HTTPS hier drin? Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich habe keine wirklich guten Beobachtungen zu machen.
Dann... können wir es ja auch...
und so weiter. Hier...
Die anderen Podcasts haben alle ganz spannende Entdeckungen.
Echt?
Ja, was man so machen kann und so. Achso, können wir jetzt eigentlich AirDrop ausprobieren?
Theoretisch, klar.
Wir haben doch jetzt moderne Computer, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, dann los, AirDropen wir uns mal ein.
Ich mach mal AirDrop.
Ah, da ist er auch schon.
Ich sehe Ten.
Das ging sehr schnell.
Wer ist denn Ten?
Ichke.
Ich schick dir mal ein lustiges Foto.
Und Goldfinger.
Wieso sehe ich da jetzt nur eine Rose und einen Löwen? Du schickst mir eine Datei.
Ich schick dir so ein Bild.
Save and Open.
Und bei Dennis kommt aber nichts. Das ist dieser Affe, der sich selbst fotografiert hat.
Was machen diese Computer jetzt genau? Warum geht es nur mit neuen Rechnern? Ist das vielleicht tatsächlich so, wie ich letztlich mal Gemutmaß habe?
Der hat mich gerade ausgelockt, als ich aufs Bild geklickt habe.
Jetzt kommen die echten Entdeckungen hier zu.
Und man kann auch wieder Normal-Dock-In mit ohne bunte Bildchen einschalten. Das habe ich noch gar nicht entdeckt. Der Affe hat gerade meinen Window-Manager gekillt.
Was ist das denn?
GFX-Card-Status-Update.
Was ist das denn? Hast du das installiert? Ich habe dir auch ein anderes Bild geschickt als Tim, glaube ich.
Aber der Affe kam ja.
So, aber was passiert da jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich bei diesem AirDrop?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Bei mir sah es eher wie ein Bomb-Drop aus.
Also gucken wir uns doch mal die Computer an, die da unterstützt sind. Das steht doch hier in den Tisch-Specs.
Vor allem das ist was, worüber der Herr Siracusa sehr wenig bis gar nichts geschrieben hat.
Macbook Pro Late 2008. Macbook Air Late 2010. Macbook Late 2008.
Ok, warte, warte, warte, ich öffne mal den Mac-Tracker und klick Macbook Pro und du sagst Late 2008. Das hat dann, steht da bei Connections und Expansions, steht da drin, welchen Wifi-Chip sie drin haben?
Ich mach mal mein Wifi aus, mal gucken, ob das dann auch noch geht. Seid ihr über Kabel drin?
Ich bin über Kabel drin.
Aber habt ihr auch noch WLAN an?
Ja. Ok.
Aber mein WLAN ist gerade hier.
Ich muss WLAN anmachen, damit Airdrop funktioniert.
Ja, das haben wir doch schon auch irgendwo gelesen.
Na gut, lesen ist das eine, sehen ist das andere. Aber, noch bevor er sich hier in das WLAN einbucht, tauchst du auf. Das bestätigt meinen Verdacht.
Wenn ich WLAN ausmache, ist Airdrop auch sofort weg und er sagt mir, ich soll es einschalten.
Genau. Also meine Vermutung ist, dass das Airdrop so funktioniert, dass es erstens nur auf Computern funktioniert, wo er gleichzeitig so ein Ad-hoc-Netz aufmachen kann.
Wo er zwei Antennen hat.
Und auch noch parallel ganz normal mit einem WLAN verbunden sein kann. Ja, der Multiplex einfach so, ich meine so wie eine Airport, auch mehrere SS-IDs bedienen kann und rausschicken kann. So kann das wahrscheinlich, wenn das jetzt auch diese MacBooks seit 2008, bestimmte Modelle und dann andere erst ab 2009 und erst ab 2010, die erst, die haben einfach einen Stein drin, mit dem das geht. Und dieses Airdrop, wenn du da draufklickst, erzeugt vermutlich irgendwas, das müssten wir mal scannen eigentlich.
Ich hab hier irgendwie einen WLAN-Scanner drauf.
Ich kriege auch schon Kopfschmerzen.
Wovon?
Von dem Airdrop? Ja, sobald, als kaum hat mir das eingeschaltet, hab ich auch so ein Pfeifen im Hinterkopf. Nee, hier läuft auch so die ganze Zeit, guck mal, hier in diesem Icon so ein Radar ringsrum. Das macht bestimmt ganz furchtbare Strahlen.
LaRose meint, das geht auch ohne WLAN. Warum sagt er mir dann, ich soll WLAN einschalten?
Ja, genau, er hat mir gesagt, ohne WLAN geht's nicht hier.
Du Pfeifer.
Ja, das ist unklar, aber...
Aber hatten wir das nicht letztes Mal sogar schon gelesen, irgendwo wo das stand, wie das funktioniert? Mir war so.
Wir haben es gerätselt.
Ich glaub, wir haben es nur gerätselt. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein merkwürdiges Feature. Und es ist mal wieder so total...
Und der Siracusa hat nichts drüber geschrieben.
Ja, man hielt das nicht für wichtig.
Aber das ist mal echt was, wo ich gerne wissen würde, wie es funktioniert.
Eine Journalism-Opportunity an der Stelle.
Ja, vor allen Dingen im Mac-Tracker steht ja erstaunlicherweise gar nicht drin, welchen Wifi-Chips sie so verwenden. Und irgendwann hat ja Apple mal angefangen, so Atheros zu verbauen. Und dann hatten sie aber auch noch mal ein bisschen was anderes. Und wahrscheinlich liegt es dann einfach da dran, welche Macs so einen bestimmten Chip drin haben und welche nicht.
Ja, also ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher. Das ist halt einfach ein Stein nötig, der gleichzeitig Atomnetzwerk aufmachen kann. Und parallel aber noch, der dadurch aber nicht seine normale WLAN-Connectivity verliert.
Was wir hier gerade nicht getestet haben, weil wir beide haben ja Ethernet an hier.
Ja, aber du kannst ja jetzt mit Wireshark zum Beispiel kannst du ja auch in diesem Promiscuous-Mode zum Mitsniffen und kannst trotzdem noch WLAN benutzen.
Ist das das Gleiche denn?
Das ging ja.
Der Promiscuous-Mode bedeutet ja nur, dass du wirklich auf den Link-Level runterkommst und alle Pakete siehst. Und nicht nur die, die du für dich tun hast.
Aber früher konnte man das auch nicht gleichzeitig machen.
Ja, was ein Problem war, dass die Tools halt dann für die jeweiligen Steine, die in den Mix verwendet wurden, nicht die richtigen Treiber hatten. Und dass das OS X von sich aus ebenso nicht erlaubt. Weil du hast da ja nichts zu suchen auf dem Level. Weil, wo kommen wir denn da schon hin? Du kannst ja andere Leute Kies abschnüffeln. Was man ja damit eigentlich auch tun wollte. Na gut, fühlen wir unsere unglaublich langweilige Sendung voran.
Eingeschlafene Füße heißt die. Oder?
Genau.
Alte Socken.
Wir können ja mal die Sache vielleicht ein bisschen... Ich weiß nicht, haben wir zu Laien noch irgendwas? Also wir haben bestimmt noch eine Menge zu erzählen.
Wir haben diese... Nein, haben wir nicht. Wir haben diese eine Sendung gemacht, wo wir diese ganzen Features durchgenudelt haben. Dann in der nächsten Sendung haben wir ein Review von diesen Features normal gemacht. Nee, haben wir nicht gemacht. Ja, war so halb schon. Und jetzt haben wir nochmal die erste Woche benutzen. Oder die ersten drei Wochen benutzen. Jetzt reicht es mir auch mit Leinen. Können wir das einfach jetzt erstmal benutzen und uns wieder um andere Marken machen? iPad 2, äh, 3, äh, nee. Ja, ich war ja irgendwie letztes Mal ganz angeregt. Hiervon bin ich ja rausgegangen aus diesem Podcast, als du mir hier diese Aspire Easy Store vorgestellt hast. Und habe auch voller Andacht die Kommentarentwicklung zu diesem Post, also zu dieser Sendung, verfolgt. Weil da wurden noch ein paar andere Geräte dann erwähnt, die da für so ein Home-NAS-Storage-Dingsbumms in Frage kämen.
Insbesondere dieses HP-Teil, ne?
Genau, das HP ProLiant war eigentlich da, das Attraktivste von allen, da es erlaubte, auch noch mehr RAM reinzustecken.
Und billiger war es meins.
Und billiger war es auch noch. Und ein schnellerer CPU hat es auch noch, ne? Also besser, besser, besser.
Fragt man sich, warum ich überhaupt auf dieses Teil gekommen bin, ne? AP ProLiant N36L Microserver.
Richtig.
Nee, aber der wurde halt so erwähnt, ne?
Genau, das war so erstmal, genau.
Kann ja sein, dass der irgendwie viel, viel größer ist als mein Teil.
Der ist auch ein bisschen hässlicher auf jeden Fall.
Ja, noch hässlicher, ne?
Ist echt erstaunlich.
Also es geht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall keine Augenweide. Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich mich ja so auch nochmal mit diesem Thema beschäftigt, weil wie gesagt, ich habe, oder weiß nicht, ob ich das letzte Mal schon erwähnt hatte, ich habe ja zu Hause so einen fetten Festplattenstapel, den ich auch in meinem Blog kürzlich mal abgebildet habe.
Tolle, einfach tolle, okay. Kauft ihr zwei Mal zwei TB, drei oder so gibt es inzwischen schon, weil die alten Festplatten kosten ja nur Strom.
Die liegen ja so ohne Gehäuse einfach so im Regal und sind gelabelt. Und wenn ich mal Backup von sonst woanders brauche, nehme ich die Platte, hole meinen USB-Sata-Adapter und stecke die halt ran. So, jetzt ist es halt so, jetzt sind auf diesen Platten Medien-Dateien. Filme, Musik, Fotos, dann sind dann so meine Home-Verzeichnisse, Projekt-Dateien und so weiter. Die sind halt auch quer über diese Platten verteilt. Und zum einen hätte ich halt gerne Medien-Files irgendwie auf so einem Fileserver, zum anderen halt Backups. Und ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf diese Platten und dieses rumgefuselte. Darum dachte ich mir, alles klar, holst du dir mal jetzt auch so ein NAS-Ding und baust das mit Freenas selber. Vier Platten-Slots sind mir zwar eigentlich zu wenig gewesen, aber hätte ich jetzt auch noch so einen Kauf genommen, dann habe ich so geguckt. Dann war so das nächste Problem, wo tue ich die Kiste hin? Weil ich will die nicht auf dem Schreibtisch haben, wo die dann hier irgendwie so vor sich hin säuselt und rattert, weil da sind ja Platten drin. Da hab ich mir okay, packst du ein anderes Zimmer, dann hätte ich da erstmal wieder Ethernet hinlegen müssen und Strom. Dann hab ich ja so infrastrukturelle Maßnahmen. Dann dachte ich mir, ist doch jetzt Cloud-Zeit-Alter? Gibt es da nicht schon irgendwie fertige Lösungen, um Online-Backup zu machen? Dann hab ich mir ja mal so einige Recherchen gegeben und tatsächlich gibt es da auch schon echt vieles.
Das heißt, du willst nicht nur dein Home von deinem Rechner online irgendwie hochschieben, sondern deine ganzen Movies, Filme, Zeug von mehreren Platten. Das kannst du doch voll vergessen.
Nein, nein, nein. Also Movies und Musik. Außer Sachen, die ich selber erstellt habe, weil andere Movies in digital, die kriegt man jederzeit wieder.
Aber deine eigenen Movies sind ja wahrscheinlich auch schon größer, oder deine Bildersammlung?
Genau. Naja, also ich hab mir erst mal angeguckt, was es überhaupt so gibt. Weil man muss ja sowieso ein paar Grundvoraussetzungen für so einen Nerd erfüllen, damit man überhaupt seine Daten irgendwo in eine Wolke schiebt. Genau. Krypto, genau. Schon mal als erstes so und...
Ich hab nur gehen gehen, weil ich müde bin, nicht weil langweilig ist.
Ich freu mich, dass du auch mal früh auf den Strand bist, dass man nachvollziehen kann.
Naja, da gibt es auf jeden Fall so zwei, drei Backup-Services, die daherkommen und behaupten entweder, es gibt zwei mit Unlimited Storage und einer, der ein bisschen teurer ist mit seinem Storage. Aber sie bieten alle an, dass es gekryptet ist und doppelt und dreifach sozusagen. Sie machen das auch schon auf deinem Rechner. Du schiebst es nicht in Plain Text hin und sie inkrypten es da. Du inkryptest die Dateien, es wird in Blöcke gesplittet und die schieben es einfach so auf ihre File Server. Dann versprechen sie natürlich auch hoch und heilig, sich um die Data Integrity und so weiter zu kümmern und dir auch Mails zu schreiben, wenn mal ein Bit gekippt ist.
Die haben ja keine Mails zu schreiben, die heißt einfach, da hat kein Bit zu kippen. Da sieht man ja von aus, dass sie da jetzt nicht gerade einen Mörer am Start haben, aber irgendwie von 20 Festplatten dann noch vielleicht eine mal für Parity zuständig ist.
Genau. Also es gibt halt welche, da klingt das in den Beschreibungen nicht so knusper alles, aber bei dreien, die ich rausgefunden hab, war das eigentlich...
Was kosten die dann?
Erstaunlich wenig. der eine, das ist auch gerade eigentlich so mein Favorit, der heißt Crashplan, der Anbieter. Ja, das sind zwei davon, haben Java-Client tatsächlich, aber die sind so von den sonstigen Features halt irgendwie so ein bisschen weiter vorne noch. Und Crashplan kostet für Unlimited Storage pro Computer 3 Dollar im Monat. Und dafür, dass du dann so ein echtes Offside-Backup hast, also so ein richtig echtes, gekryptet, irgendwo da draußen, wo du aus dem Internet auch jederzeit wieder rankommst, ist jetzt echt kein schlechter Preis.
Drei Dollar im Monat für was?
Für Unlimited, Kryptet, Storage, von was auch immer du da hinschieben willst.
Was ist Unlimited?
Unlimited ist angeblich tatsächlich Unlimited. Also ich hab auch gegoogelt so, weil es gab schon mal einen so einen Anbieter, und der hat dann so mittendrin gesagt, Unlimited ist doch noch nicht so richtig Unlimited. Und wir müssen da mal ein bisschen die Schraube anziehen. Die sind jetzt glaube ich auch mittlerweile pleite oder so. Also von denen hat man nicht mehr viel gehört.
Die haben dann auch von heute auf morgen so klick gemacht, und man ist an seine Sachen nicht mehr rangekommen?
Nee, das nicht, aber sie haben dann ihren Service so langsam, also das, was du da hochschieben konntest, wurde dann halt gedrosselt. Also angeblich, so was ich bisher gelesen habe, ist zum Beispiel bei Crashplan Unlimited Storage tatsächlich Unlimited Storage. Da gibt es Berichte, wo sie hunderte Gigabytes schon reingeschoben haben und alles gut ist soweit. Vielleicht ist ihr Datenmodell oder ihr Preismodell einfach so, dass sie denken, die meisten Leute, die bei uns bezahlen, schieben halt nur ihre Dokumente aus dem Office oder was auch immer da rein und das ist schon alles okay. Und die Leute, die dann wirklich Terabyte-weise reinpumpen, das ist dann eher die Ausnahme. Weiß man aber nicht so genau. Und was back-uptet der? Alles, was du ihm sagst, dass er back-upen soll. Also du kannst, glaube ich, die Checkbox aussetzen, alles. Und, also genau, da gibt es, das ist auch ein sehr guter Punkt, was er überhaupt back-upt. Weil bei Mac-Filesystemen und so weiter, da gibt es ja die Resource, Forks und Metadaten und Extended Attributes. Und ein Backup-Service, der heißt Arc, der basiert im Prinzip auf einer GUI, die du dir kaufst. Und dann schiebt er das auf Amazon S3. Und du kannst dann halt auch aussuchen, ob in Europa oder auf welchem, so ein bisschen mehr Selbstkontrolle sozusagen, die du dann ausüben kannst. Und der hat auf seiner Webseite einen Test gemacht. Da gibt es auch ein Tool für, um das zu testen. Und zwar schieb, kannst du mit so einem Command Line Utility dir so ein Test-Zett an Daten machen, mit allen möglichen Features, die so in HalfS Plus gehen, mit Metadaten und so weiter. Schieb das halt einmal irgendwo raus, holt es sich wieder rein und guckt, was davon noch übrig geblieben ist. Und damit hat er sozusagen alle großen Backup-Dienste getestet. Seiner hat natürlich alle Tests gepasst. Crash Plan und der andere, die passen alle bis auf einen, der aber auch tatsächlich relativ relevant ist. Genau, wenn du da bei ARK klickst... ARQ, genau. Das wird Dennis auf jeden Fall total gefallen, dieser Test. Wenn du da so ein bisschen runter scrollst.
Aber S3 ist auch scheiße teuer, wenn du da...
Genau, also ARK ist ein bisschen teurer. Also das ist wirklich, wenn du viel Daten rausschieben willst, dann wird das sehr viel teurer als Crash Plan. Wenn du halt so im Bereich 50 GB bleibst, dann bezahlt es halt auch nur deine 5 Dollar im Monat letztendlich. Aber dafür kannst du dir halt aussuchen, wo auf dem Kontinent deine Daten liegen sollen. Und du kannst halt bei Amazon auch den Super Redundant Storage anklicken, wo es dann sowieso nochmal bei Amazon doppelt und dreifachig liegt für super secure Sicherheit. Genau, also ARK ist der sozusagen selbstbestimmte Backup Service. Da ist es aber auch so, dass die Daten auf deinem Rechner gekryptet werden und dann blöckeweise auf S3 geschoben werden. Und bei den anderen, die haben halt ihre eigenen Rechenzentren, gibt es auch auf den Seiten. Also das fand ich auch positiv überraschend. Eigentlich immer sehr coole Tour durchs Rechenzentrum, welche Security-Measurements und wie das so aufgebaut ist und wie ausfallsicher und was es für Maßnahmen gibt. Die lassen schon ein bisschen die Hose runter, um dir möglichst wirklich so ein gutes Gefühl dazu zu geben. Und die haben auch FAQs, wo eigentlich fast jede Frage, die ich so hatte, eigentlich erklärt wurde.
Jetzt Crashplans oder alle?
Also die, die ich da aufgelistet hab, waren da eigentlich alle sehr gut dabei.
Da kannst du ja noch mal kurz hier Backblaze, Crashplans, Spider Oak, Jungle Disk, Arc.
Also Spider Oak waren die, die so mit dem Thema Daten-Integrity und Krypto am meisten die Hose runtergelassen haben. Auf der Seite war so richtig viel. Bei Backblaze, das benutzen eigentlich die meisten, weil es da eine Mac-GUI für gibt, also eine native GUI. Das ist so ein System-Preference-Pain letztendlich, glaube ich sogar.
Auf sowas stehe ich ja.
Crash Plan und Spider Oak, das sind die mit den Java-GUIs. ARK ist auch eine native OS X-GUI. Jungle Disk habe ich mir allerdings am wenigsten angeguckt. Bei Spider Oak zahlst du 10 Dollar pro Monat pro 100 GB. Wenn man diese Sachen kennt, was Unlimited wirklich heißt, kennt man ja von den Internet-Providern, wo deine Flatrate auch nur heißt, 3 GB und dann gedrosselt. Wenn man von vornherein schon skeptisch ist, dann muss man vielleicht zu Spider Oak oder zu ARK gehen, wo man dann weiß, das kostet halt so viel wie es kostet und ist nicht einfach so Unlimited.
Hättest du ja noch so ein paar schöne Matrix-Vergleichstabellen machen können, das wäre.
Ja, ja, na ich, hm, ja. Ja, das hat mich schon abgebrochen, das überhaupt so zusammen zu dingeln.
Aber schon soweit ist es, dass da dann meistens noch der...
Was halt auch, ja genau, okay, das ist ein guter Punkt, das mach ich vielleicht noch. Auf jeden Fall, was halt auch schick ist, dass diese Sachen, die da aufgelistet sind, die erlauben dir dann halt natürlich so Zero-Configuration und so. Einfach klicken und wir machen für dich. Aber der Nerd will ja nicht einfach von so einem Tool sich irgendwelche Keys generieren lassen und wer weiß, wo die hinkommen und wo die herkommen. Und bei denen kannst du halt auch, wenn du es richtig wissen willst, auch auf der Command Line deine Keys selber generieren und die dann benutzen zum Krypten. Also dass du dann auch wirklich sicher bist, dass da keiner irgendwie deinen Key parallel hoch lädt und so. Bei Backblaze, bei diesem, wie heißt es denn? Crashplan und dem Spider-Oak. Könntest du das glaube ich machen.
Ja, aber irgendwo musst du doch diesen Key dieser Software sagen, ich meine, sonst kann es ja nicht.
Ja klar. Nee, aber du hast glaube ich bei allen auch dieses Zero-Set, da legst du halt einmal ein Passwort an und wo die Keys herkommen, siehst du da halt nicht. Aber du kannst halt auch bei denen halt auch sagen, nee, ich will jetzt hier aber meinen 4096-Bit-Key verwenden mit meiner Passphrase und kannst das auch full manual steuern, wenn du halt wirklich...
Ja, aber du musst ja trotzdem noch diese eingeben und...
Klar, ja. Aber wie gesagt, das ist halt so...
Sicherheitsimulation.
Genau, ich war halt schon positiv davon angetan, dass sie zumindest so auch so die nerdigen Features noch am Start haben, wenn man sie denn... Das ist so die Frage. Hatte ich jetzt nicht so erwartet, weil die Seiten sehen natürlich so, oh, Family, ja, komm, Backup, war nie so einfach. Wir können alle Backupen, Embrace the Cloud, weißt schon und so. Aber wenn man dann halt so ein bisschen hinter die Fassade guckt, dann bricht's, also bricht's auch nicht so schön.
Hast du mal irgendwie selber mal irgendwas gebackupt damit mit den Dingern oder hast du jetzt nur Specs verglichen?
Nee, ich hab Spider Oak, Crash Plan und Backblaze hab ich mal so ein bisschen gebackupt. Vor allen Dingen, weil ich wissen wollte, wie scheiße die Java Client sind im Vergleich zu der Native App.
Wie scheiße sind sie?
Sie sind schon natürlich Java-Guys, das können sie nicht verstecken. Aber sie geben sich zumindest sehr große Mühe. Und das Ding, was ich auch so... Also im Twitter hab ich auch ganz viel rumgefragt, da meinen halt auch einige Leute, ja, ist eine Java-Guys, aber du hast halt die meiste Zeit diese Gui auch gar nicht vor der Nase, weil du stellst halt einmal ein, welche Ordner und so weiter. Und dann siehst du oben nur noch das Icon, was dann halt sagt, ja, hier, so und so viel gebackupt und so.
Aber gibt's denn nicht auch so ein bisschen wie mir? Ich hab immer das Gefühl, also wenn sie noch nicht mal schaffen, einen nativen Client zu bauen, they don't care about my OS. Und was motiviert sie dann, sozusagen die anderen Spezifika meines Betriebssystems zu berücksichtigen?
Andererseits könnte man auch sagen, mir ist es vor allen Dingen wichtig, dass sie sich um ein gottverdammtes Backup kümmern. Und dass die Seite korrekt und sicher und alles gut ist. Und wenn jetzt die GUI da zum Konfigurieren in Java ist, drücke ich da nochmal ein Auge zu. Aber klar, natürlich eine Native-Up wäre wünschenswert. Aber bei Backblaze gab es halt so ein paar Sachen, wo die Leute schon, also da gab es so am meisten noch so ein negatives Feedback oder Leute, die irgendwie mal eine schlechte Erfahrung gemacht haben. Deswegen hatte ich so Backblaze erstmal noch so an die Seite geschoben.
Negative Erfahrung in welcher Hälfte?
Na, es gab so zwei Leute, die meinten, dass zum Beispiel ihr Restore nicht geklappt hätte. Also es waren jetzt auch so Reports wieder ein Jahr alt und so, aber da sagten wir noch gleich, na... Und bei Crashplan zum Beispiel hatte ich jetzt keine einzigen. Ich hab ja auch, wie gesagt, nochmal auf Twitter gefragt, auf das Blog gelinkt und so. Und mit Crashplan waren sie erstmal alle zufrieden. Und ARK war eigentlich der zweite Gewinner. Da gab es auch einige Nerds, die das benutzen und da voll zufrieden waren.
Also dein Tipp wäre sozusagen, wenn man jetzt so Choose One irgendwie ohne viel selber nachdenken, würdest du sagen, als erstes sollte man Crashplan ausprobieren?
Also ich glaube, Crashplan ist schon dann so der Contender Number One.
Also geh doch mal die 5 durch und sag doch mal, was für die jeweiligen am ehesten spricht Pro und Contra.
Na, Backblaze ist sehr verbreitet bei den Mac-Usern, weil es eben eine Native Integration hat, also System Preference Pain. Bietet auch im Wesentlichen eigentlich alle Features, die die anderen bieten. Also ein, zwei Abstriche gab es hier und da. Plus, dass ein, zwei Leute halt so auf Blogpost von einem Jauda2 gelinkt haben, wo sie halt irgendein Problem mit Backblaze hatten und das auch nicht so richtig zufriedenstellend gelöst wurde. Aber das ist halt so Internetberichte, da weiß man halt auch nicht so genau. Aber sie haben auch ein Windows-Klein, wie man sieht, oder was? Naja, also zumindest gab es da auch, ach das ist ja sogar hier in Deutsch, alles guck an. Na ja, siehst du mal.
Jetzt kaufen.
5 Dollar pro Monat unbegrenzt.
Genau, war auch ein bisschen teurer als Crash Plan.
Na gut, aber um 3 oder 5 Dollar kostet es mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal.
Das macht den Kohl nicht fett definitiv.
Du kannst auch gleich ein Jahr kaufen für 50 Dollar.
Genau, das haben sie aber im Prinzip auch alle. Genau, also das wäre dann natürlich das, was für Backplays spricht oder eben auch nicht. Bei Crash Plan, die Crash Plan-Jungs sind eigentlich so die Feature-Completesten. Also die haben so in Security und... Achso, und die Crash Plan GUI, die erlaubt halt nicht nur Cloud-Backupen, sondern du kannst halt auch lokale Backups machen. Wenn jetzt z.B. Dennis und Tim auch Crash Plan installiert haben, dann könntest du jetzt auf deinem Rechner mir einen Bereich geben, wo ich meine Backups auch mit hinschieben kann. Das heißt, wenn wir hier immer zusammensitzen, würde ich dann auch so ein paar Backups in den von dir für mich freigegebenen Bereich reinschieben. Also das erlaubt auch lokale Backups, Backups auf Disks und was auch immer. Mit dieser Crash Plan GUI kannst du auch gleich noch lokal und auf Festplatten und auf DVDs...
Ohne, dass es an irgendwelche Kosten nach sich zieht. Also man kann einfach die Software nehmen und kann sagen, okay, weiß ich, so Familienmitglieder untereinander speichern sich gegenseitig ihre Backups, wenn sie genug Platten Platz frei haben.
Genau, und das ist dann kostenlos und der Online-Teil kostet dann halt Geld für vor allen Dingen den Storage und den Servers und so weiter. Aber wie gesagt, bei Crash Plan ist wirklich, da hab ich jetzt erstmal überhaupt kein Haar gefunden und die bieten halt wirklich verdammt viele Features und auch in Sachen Security sind sie da relativ vorne mit dabei. Es gibt sogar Version Retention, also sie behalten halt auch Versionen von Files, falls sie sich geändert haben. Also eine kleine Cloud-Time-Machine auch noch. Bis zu welchem Level das geht, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, aber zumindest bieten sie das an. Und natürlich was auch, aber glaube ich, alle machen. Du kannst ja dann halt auch sagen, ja irgendwie alles gecrashed. Ich hab auch nicht mal mehr einen Rechner, könnt ihr mir einfach eine Festplatte schicken mit meinem Backup und dann schicken sie dir mit FedEx Express innerhalb von 24 Stunden eine Platte mit deinem Krypto-Backup und wenn du deinen Crash-Plan installierst. Also ok, du brauchst natürlich die Keys.
Also du kaufst von denen dann eine Platte sozusagen.
Ja, mit deinem... Also falls ihr als Downloads... Ok, die Keys musst du natürlich echt behalten. Na du brauchst deinen Key natürlich auch. Also den lädst du ja nicht hoch. Und der sollte ja auch nicht in dem Backup irgendwo enthalten sein. Also Key sollte man glaube ich so oder so immer behalten. Naja, anyway, auf jeden Fall schicken sie dir halt auch die Festplatte dann einfach zu mit FedExpress oder was auch immer in 24 Schritten.
Kaufst du da sozusagen eine Festplatte, wo zufällig schon Daten drauf sind?
Naja sag mal, du bist jetzt gerade im Banger, der ist dein Rechner, wurde geklaut oder so. Du musst deine Daten nochmal kurz ran oder so. Obwohl es gibt ja auch ein Web-Interface. Du kannst auch über Web-Interface an einen Backup ran.
Das können sie ja im Prinzip auch jedem anderen, der das kaufen will, schicken. Da brauchen sie gar nicht große Authentifizierungen, weil ohne Key kann er eh nichts damit anfangen.
Und per Web-Interface ist dann auch noch verschlüsselt?
Das weiß ich nicht. Web-Restore.
Es gibt ein Web-Interface, um auf die Daten vergrafen zu können.
By backing up your personal files to Crash-Plane Central, you get the ability to restore them to any other computer using your internet browser and an internet connection. Das hab ich jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert, zugegebenerweise.
Okay, bleiben wir noch mal im Vergleich.
Genau. Spider Oak, die haben im Prinzip, also da fand ich die FAQ besonders cool. Die haben halt wirklich sehr viel ausführlich erklärt. Und auch jede Nachfrage, die in meinem Kopf immer kam, gab es auch eine FAQ-Antwort. Und die wirkten so von den Marketing-Texten so am nerd-kompatibelsten. Also so ein bisschen, nicht so ganz viel Buzzword-Bingo, sondern schon irgendwie relativ mit Bodenhaftung und relativ ausführlich erklärt. Da sind zwei Nachteile, auch wieder der Java kleint und zum anderen kostet der Speicher da halt mehr. Also für uns Nerds vielleicht sinnvoll mehr, also oder realistisch mehr. Das heißt, da hätte man am ersten vielleicht das Gefühl, dass sie nicht irgendwie sagen, ja plötzlich unlimited geht aber nicht mehr, sondern dass es vielleicht eher noch billiger wird, aber dass man schon pro 100 GB da bezahlt. Ja, also es ist schon im Vergleich zu unlimited für 3-5 Dollar ist das schon mal um einiges teurer. Aber sie haben halt hier gerade diese Two-Factor Authentication und Comprehensive Zero Knowledge Data Encryption, also sie erklären halt aus diesem ganzen Kram relativ leicht verständlich. Ja, also die Vorteile da, ein bisschen nerd-kompatibler, ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen. Sie haben eine iOS-App und eine Android-App auch dafür. Auch glaube ich, Webrestore schicken ja auch eine Platte. Also ansonsten das gleiche. Also wie gesagt, Nachteil hier, Jahre klein und teurer. So, und dann hier gehen wir gleich nochmal aufs nächste, damit wir uns hier nicht allzu lange aufhalten.
Du brauchst zwei Schlüssel.
Der eine verfällt in zwölf Stunden, oder was?
Ja, so was hier wie dein World of Warcraft RSA One-Time-Token, oder was?
Und bleibt noch Jungle Disk?
Ja, wie gesagt, das haben wir am allerwenigsten angeguckt, aber da gab es sehr viele, die das auch immer wieder erwähnt haben. Das gibt es auch schon sehr lange und hat halt auch relativ, ich sage sehr viel relativ, ich sage relativ oft relativ, das hat auch ziemlich günstige Preise. Aber da hat auch eine iPhone und ein iPad ab, aber sonst kann ich da jetzt gerade gar nicht so viel zu sagen, außer dass das sehr viele Leute bei meiner Recherche auch immer wieder hochgehalten haben als gute Alternative. Und das Jungle Disk, also genau, alle, die ich da erwähnt habe, sind auch in diesem Metadata-Test, den dieser Typ von ARK gemacht hat, haben halt so gut wie alle Tests gepasst. Also ich hab da keinen aufgelistet, der schlecht abgeschnitten hat. Und ARK, wie gesagt, final ist, da bezahlt man einmal 29 Dollar für das Programm. Und dann dockt man das halt an sein Amazon S3 Storage an. Wie gesagt, der Vorteil da ist, man kann sich aussuchen, wo der ist. Bei den anderen Providern ist das Rechenzentrum halt in Amerika meistens. Hier könntest du halt sagen, ja, mein Backup ist in Europa. Die GUI ist jetzt nicht so der Weisheit letzter Schluss. Also auch eine Native ab kann manchmal ein bisschen hässlich sein. Angeblich kommt da bald die Version 2.0 raus, mit der nochmal alles viel besser wird. Aber zumindest die Leute, die es benutzen, hatten damit keine Probleme. Da freuen sich die Leute, dass sie bei Amazon den Kram haben. Da kriegt man natürlich dann seine Festplatte nicht zugeschickt. Oder? Kriegt man das von Amazon? Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und, ja, Trustworthy Online-Backup. Also wie gesagt, das passt alle Metadatentests, hat eine Mac-Up. Man kann kontrollieren, wo der Storage ist, aber es ist halt auch ein bisschen teurer dadurch.
Das ist so der...
Der Überblick.... der Overview. Und ich werde mich jetzt in Kürze mal für einen entscheiden und werde dann mal ein initiales Fullback-Up da reinschieben. Das wird halt, wie gesagt, zuerst mal Crashplan werden, wahrscheinlich. Und dann werde ich da nochmal drüber berichten. Na schon im 100 Gigabyte-Bereich. Also mit einem Megabyte pro Sekunde schafft man in der Nacht so mit acht Stunden oder so schafft man schon so 28 Gigabyte. Ich habe ja ein bisschen mehr zu Hause. Das heißt, ich schaffe dann auch 50 bis 60 Gigabyte pro Nacht. Und mein Initialbackup werde ich irgendwo machen, wo es ein bisschen schneller geht. Aber da gab es halt auch schon ein paar Nachfragen. Natürlich werde ich auch noch eine Festplatte für zu Hause mit lokaler Time Machine haben, damit da mal direkt anschließen kann für den Restore und so weiter. Aber dann eben nur eine und die wird dann auch immer wieder überschrieben. Ich wollte halt vor allen Dingen auch noch ein echtes Offside-Backup. Das ist halt auch so ein Bedarf, den ich damit relativ gut abdecken kann. Ja, werde ich mal ausprobieren und dann nochmal berichten. Und wie gesagt, Blog-Post ist bestimmt in den Links. Und wenn einer von den Hörern, also wenn alle von den Hörern, da noch Erfahrungsberichte haben, nur her damit. Also das hilft allen, wenn man da mal zusammenträgt, weil so einen richtig guten Überblick über diese ganzen Online-Backup-Dienste gibt es noch nicht. Und dann könnte dieser Blog-Post und die Kommentare und so weiter und die Folgepost dazu beitragen.
Es ist ein richtiges Hammer-Thema geworden.
Ja, dann können wir auch gleich nahtlos weitergehen zu dem aktuellen Nass-Storage-Problem. Obwohl Nass-Storage ist auch schon doppelt gemoppelt. Aber da gibt es ja mit dem Line so eine kleine Änderung, wie Apple mit AFPs-Farbern spricht. Und es ist wohl so, dass diese Geräte, die so einen fertigen Nass irgendwie drauf haben, also die auch irgendwie Free Nass oder was auch immer, die so als Grundlage benutzen, die da dieses Neta-Talk benutzen, damit sie native Apple-Talk sprechen müssen, können und nicht Summer nehmen müssen. Die haben wohl ein Feature nicht eingeschaltet, was es bei Neta-Talk aber schon seit einer Weile gibt. Nämlich dieses, ich glaube, was? DHX2? Dieses DHX, ich glaube, ja. Double Handshake Exchange? Nee, irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Weiß nicht, was das jetzt genau heißt. Aber das haben die nicht eingeschaltet oder nicht eingebaut, wie auch immer. Das ist jetzt aber bei LINE erstmal Voraussetzung, dass es funktioniert und deswegen geht es nicht. Dafür gibt es aber ein oder zwei Defaults, die man da irgendwie setzen kann, damit es dann doch geht. Kann man zum Beispiel bei Heise, bei den LINE-Tipps und Tricks irgendwie finden. Dann ist aber noch das Problem, also das kann man sozusagen lösen, dann ist aber noch das Problem, dass wenn die Leute, so wie ich, die ihr Time Machine-Backup über so einen Netatalk Storage machen, nicht einschlafen, Dennis. Ja, ich muss überlegen, du musst ja überlegen, was man erzählt. Dass das nicht mehr funktioniert, weil die bei Apple auch hier jetzt die neueste Version von dem Apple-File-Protokoll, oder wie es heißt, irgendwie voraussetzen. Und das gibt es noch nicht im Netatalk. Also es gibt es schon, da gab es ja diese 2.2.beta.4. Und dann hat dieser Frank Lahm gesagt, ja, nee, hier die OEMs, die hier irgendwie meine Software auf ihren Boxen irgendwie da vertreiben, die zahlen ja irgendwie nichts. Und er hat die ganze Arbeit und hat nichts davon, und die ziehen da die Kohle ein. Und dann hat er den Source nicht veröffentlicht und diesen Brief da rausgegeben, über den wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon mal gesprochen haben. Und jetzt haben wohl irgendwie aber ein paar Hersteller von diesen Geräten da mit ihm irgendwie was zusammen an Deals irgendwie gemacht. Und heute Morgen, wie ich hier in unserem Local Chat hier erfahren habe, hat er den Source wohl dann doch rausgegeben. Die finale Version wird dann demnächst schnell nachgeschoben. Also der Source, der ist jetzt doch irgendwie verfügbar. Und ich hoffe dann, bei meinem Time Machine Backup zu Hause geht nämlich auch gerade nicht. Dass dann in den nächsten Tagen irgendwie, auch, weiß nicht, auf FreeBSD wieder einen Port gibt oder was auch immer, dass ich mir das neu bauen kann und dass ich mir meinen Time Machine wieder über meinen Server fahren kann. Oder über meinen Router da, wo meine Platten drin sind. Weil ich hab jetzt als Ersatz erstmal eine Festplatte an mein Display angeschlossen, so mit USB. Ich dachte das ist eigentlich auch mal ganz cool so. Aber es ist überhaupt irgendwie gar nicht cool, weil keine Ahnung. Also ich hab da auch gleich die Krypto eingeschaltet natürlich, damit mein Backup gekryptet ist mit diesem Core Storage. Aber irgendwie mit meinem Router, so bei WLAN, wird das Auto gemountet, wird das Backup aufs Time Machine gemacht und der unmountet das auch wieder. Jetzt mit dieser Platte, mit diesem Krypto Core Storage, ich muss die immer von Hand mounten, weil von selber will er irgendwie nicht. Wenn ich sie von Hand mounte, dann unmountet er die nicht von allein. Das heißt, ich muss immer das selber ab und an melden, das nervt alles immer noch so ein bisschen. Das ist nicht so schick wie vorher.
Also jetzt Time Machine Backup auf Krypto Platte.
Ja, wobei man bei Time Machine, da komme ich auch ein bisschen durcheinander, bei Time Machine kann man ja klicken, dass man einen Krypto Backup haben will. Was heißt das nun, dass er die Daten nochmal selber irgendwie kryptet? Weil ich hatte ja die Platte schon per Core-Storage gesagt, dass die gekryptet werden soll. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, warum es bei Time Machine dafür auch nochmal ein Häkchen gibt. Vielleicht macht der das dann irgendwie automatisch für mich.
Das ist ja nichts Neues, das Häkchen.
Ist es was extra? Na doch, eigentlich schon, weil das war früher in irgendwelchen Betas bei 10, 5 oder 10, 6 Mal drin. Aber es war im Release nicht drin, genau.
Ja, was sind dieses Häkchen?
Na, da wo man sein Backup einstellt.
Also damals in der Beta war das meines Wissens ein Krypto-Bundle. Also er macht dann alles in ein Disk-Image und nicht direkt auf die Platte. Das ist quasi der Unterschied. Und wenn jetzt aber die Platte gekryptet ist, wie ist denn das, wenn du eine externe Platte, die jetzt mit dem neuen 5V gekryptet ist, anstöpselst? Was kommt da für ein GUI hoch? Muss man da ein Passwort eingeben oder nicht?
Ja, außer du hast es in deiner Keychain drin, da nicht mehr.
Ah, Keychain.
Wie macht man denn das eigentlich mit den externen Platten?
Also ich meine...
Na angeblich hat der Zyra...
Siracusa.
Siracusa. Das ist auch geschrieben, dass es noch nicht so richtig Support gibt für Krypto bei externen Platten, weil der ja auch dann noch so ein extra Partition erschreibt, damit dann irgendwie das ein Notfallsystem ist, damit man auch rankommt und so weiter und so fort. Alles ein bisschen komplex. Aber irgendwie in Disk Utility, wenn man doch das Volume nochmal neu formatiert und dann dort auf Encrypten geht, dann funktioniert das. Genau, diese Live-Encryption, dass die so nebenher läuft, das ging irgendwie nicht. Das geht nur, wenn man es hier auf dem Betriebssystem selbst macht. Da geht das wohl. Also mit Disk Utility kann man das unten drunter, per Command-Line, wo alles machen, aber im GUI geht es erstmal nur auf das System selbst, für fremde Platten nicht. Aber ich hatte die Platte, die sollte eh platt gemacht, die Platte. Und da habe ich gesagt, einmal mit Krypto bitte. Aber dann habe ich später gesehen, dass bei Time Machine dieses Häkchen auch noch setzen kann mit Krypto. Ich denke mal nicht, dass es jetzt doppelt gekryptet ist, aber es könnte glatt sein. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Man müsste das halt einfach nochmal probieren. Wollte ich sogar machen. Aber ich konnte halt dieses Core Storage Krypto-Teil von der Platte nicht runterkriegen, weil es im GUI erstmal nicht ging, dass ich das alles da irgendwie wieder zerstöre. Weil es ist ganz schön resistent gegen zerstören. Man kriegt es dann irgendwie nicht wieder runter. Ja, indem du einfach dahin gehst und bei... Du musst in Disk Utility gehen und dann bei der Partition sagen hier Erase.
Nee, Erase, Erase, Erase.
Da oben Erase, genau. Und dann hier bei Format sagst du genau.
Sagst du immer mit Krypto bitte.
Aber bitte mit Krypto. Aber bitte mit Krypto.
Jean-Helde, komm mal, encryptet. Jean-Helde.
Jean-Helde. Arnold. Übrigens hab ich ja noch voll vergessen, dass diese Online-Backup-Dienste auch D-Duplication haben.
Ja, wenn sie D-Duplication haben, dann können sie den Zeug aber nicht.
Doch, die machen da halt irgendwie, also das hab ich auch, ich hab denen geschrieben.
Ja, den Trick müsstest du mir mal erklären.
Naja, sie krypten ja auf deinem Rechner und splitten das in Blöcke und gucken dann halt irgendwie, wenn der Key immer der gleiche ist, dass immer das gleiche rauskommt. Sie machen halt auch Checks, also die Files oder die Blöcke, oder was sie da auch immer hoch haben, die haben halt auch noch irgendwie Checks sammeln. Also sie machen halt irgendwie eine Checksamme auf das, was sie da blocken oder krypten oder wie auch immer. Und dann laden sie das hoch und wenn sozusagen du noch mal dieses File hast und sie das noch mal hochladen wollen, dann hätte das die gleiche Checksamme, also der gekryptete Block hätte die gleiche Checksamme als Name oder was auch immer und dann wüssten sie, dass es das gleiche ist, ohne zu wissen, was drin ist.
Naja, aber sie könnten es schon irgendwie wissen, wenn halt irgendwer sagt, was drin ist, dann wissen sie auch, was bei dir drin ist. Also ein bisschen...
Naja, also das ist auf jeden Fall auch so eine Sache, wo ich erstmal so ein bisschen nachdenklich gestimmt war, aber sie machen das halt auch tatsächlich alle und...
Ja, ich denke mal schon auch, dass sie das deduplicativ machen, weil es bestimmt eine Menge Platz spart, weil schon eine Menge Leute den gleichen Scheiß schicken, wobei es halt voll gekloppt ist, das zu tun, weil man sollte wirklich nur die Sachen hochschicken, die man selber erstellt hat und die gibt es dann wirklich nicht nochmal.
Ja, aber man weiß schon, was jetzt wirklich alle haben und was nicht und so.
Naja, wenn alle natürlich irgendwie dann ihre... Also den gleichen gerippten Mo wieder hochladen, warum auch immer, was so ein bisschen blöd ist eigentlich, aber dann klar, dann sparen die sich halt irgendwie von tausenden Leuten, einmal her, der Ringe Extended Version da liegen zu haben, sondern haben die dann nur noch einmal da liegen.
Ja, der Ringe Extended Version, Full HD Blu-Ray Raw Ripper, 100 Gigabyte, zack. Back-ish-up muss ich haben, noch in 10 Jahren. Naja, würde ich auch noch mal erwähnt haben. Aber da hab ich auch erst mal so überlegt, Häh, Soldatien, aber der Support-Typie.
Naja, was spricht, naja doch, da spricht eine Menge dagegen. Also wenn ich jetzt, ich hab schon voll überlegt, wenn du sagst, du zahlst da irgendwie 3 Dollar, 10 Dollar irgendwie so in dem Durchschnitt, ja. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mir einen Rechner kaufe, sagen wir mal so eine 2 HE-Kiste, ich stell die zu irgendeinem LG-Provider, der so ein bisschen Netz hat und hab da, pack da vier Mal 3 Terabyte Platten rein oder so und mach dann ein Rate 5. Das heißt, ich hab irgendwie noch 3 Mal 3 Terabyte durch, also 12 Terra, da kann man schon so ein paar Leute mit versorgen. Wenn ich dir dann anbiete, okay, ja hier kannst du bei mir irgendwie, kannst du so ein paar 100 Gig irgendwie Speicher, kannst du da haben und das mach ich mit 20 Leuten, wo ich dann im Monat auf meine 200, 300 Dollar komme, was irgendwie die Provider-Kosten entdeckt, plus ein bisschen Hardware-Kosten vielleicht, dann wär das doch was. Und dann könntest du da sogar, naja, ne, mit dem De-Duplication, das geht halt nicht. Also entweder du machst Krypto oder du machst De-Duplication, aber beides geht nicht. Also ich hätte ja immer noch gerne so ein ZFS per Eiskasi zu meinem Rechner hin exportiert, das wär's. Dass wirklich das gekryptet dort ankommt, aber ich trotzdem lokal bestimme, was de-duplicated ist und was nicht oder wie auch immer. Und Compression natürlich auch gleich auf volle Pulle stellen, weil die Leitung ist so lahm, da kannst du auch gleich Full-Compression machen.
Buzzwords den Hörern um die Ohren hauen, ja, aber dann ist das...
Ja, aber dann hast du dein eigenes, dann hast du auch ein ZFS Netatalk, was weiß ich nicht. Dann hast du dein komplett eigenes...
Da können wir uns gerne auch nochmal demnächst nochmal drüber unterhalten ins Bastelprojekt.
Der Frank Lahm soll jetzt erstmal seinen Source da finalisieren von seinem Netatalk, damit ich das alles an den Start krieg, damit Time Machine wieder läuft und dann...
Kannst du das nochmal ein bisschen verdeutlichen? Also er hatte ursprünglich den Source dicht gemacht, weil er wollte jetzt Geld verdienen.
Na, er meint, er hat da voll die Arbeit. Diese Freak-Nas-Hersteller, die packen halt das Netatalk immer mit in ihre Distributionen, verhökern da das irgendwie dick als Gesamtsystem oder wie auch immer. Und er sieht irgendwie keinen Fett, und das fand er irgendwie blöd, weil er muss irgendwie auch, weil open source, es war open source, aber er will halt auch irgendwie mal Kohle sehen. Irgendwie so indirekt. Und dann hat so ein anderer Typ... Dann hat so ein anderer Typ auch geschrieben, ja ist zwar schade für dich, dass dein Businessplan nicht läuft, aber dann musst du dir was anderes einverlassen, das ist open source, kannst du nicht machen. Du bist da auch erst seit irgendwie ein paar Jahren dabei und du stehst auf den Schultern von vielen anderen, die da schon vorher dran gekodet haben und so weiter und so fort. Und dann meinte der Typ aber, dieser Frank Lahm hat auch gleich in dem gleichen Blog-Post geantwortet und meinte, naja, er weiß, dass er auf den Schultern anderer steht und er würde da auch gerne weiter stehen bleiben, aber er schafft es halt nicht, wenn ihm keiner hilft. Und ihm blieb nichts anderes übrig, als jetzt irgendwie halt das Ultimatum zu stellen und jetzt abzuwarten, dass jetzt, wo Lion halt rauskommt, weil es ist ja schon Absicht, dass er es genau jetzt macht, weil er wusste, dass es mit Lion nicht mehr gehen wird, dass er sozusagen diese Freenance-Hersteller so ein bisschen zwingt, dass sie jetzt endlich mal auch was tun, weil die halt in Bedrängnis sind, weil die natürlich ihre Produkte irgendwie für Lion fertig haben wollten. Und das hat halt aber nur einer gemacht. Das ist wohl Netgear, wenn ich es mir richtig gemerkt habe, nicht wenn es noch einen gibt, der so ähnlich heißt, aber ich glaube, Netgear war es. Und jetzt haben wohl auch noch ein paar andere irgendwie mit ihm da sich koordiniert. Und jetzt hat er wohl heute Morgen den Source freigegeben und...
Also auf der Net-Art-Talks seh ich aber da jetzt nichts.
Ja, ich hab da auch nichts gesehen, aber ja, vorhin hat einer was verlinkt und da konnte man so einen Text sehen, so ein, so ein, dieses Sourceforge. Also ich meine, Frank Lahm, wenn du hier zuhörst, wenn du überhaupt deutscher bist, ich denk mal schon, ja. Aber mal ehrlich, wie, was hast du vorhin gesagt?
Friedhof der Open-Source-Projekte.
Ja, allerdings dieses Sourceforge, also ich meine, da macht's nicht mal Spaß, Forumseinträge zu lesen, ja, weil es geht einfach nicht weiter. Das ist alles so langsam schnarchend, man muss da hin und her klicken, man weiß nicht mehr, wo man ist, ey, das ist, äh... Ich hab noch nichts schlechteres gesehen. Vielleicht hab ich wirklich noch nicht viel gesehen, aber ich hab auf jeden Fall noch nichts schlechteres gesehen.
Ja, es ist...
Also Sourceforge war früher bestimmt mal toll, weil es waren auch die ersten und so, aber inzwischen ist es wirklich Friedhof von Sachen, die keiner mehr will. Und dann ist es kein Wunder, wenn dir keiner hilft. Also geh da bloß weg. Es macht echt keinen Spaß.
Deswegen finde ich mal, dass du auch wieder dein Toast nicht wieder...
Ja, aber mal ehrlich, ich meine, daran liegt es nicht. Sondern ich meine, du musst ja wirklich Plan haben, um... also so Protokoll und Networking, das ist jetzt mal nicht...
Ey, das gibt es doch so viele kleine Bugs, die jeder fixen kann, ja. Das muss nicht immer irgendwie das voll schwierige Zeug sein. Manchmal ist das so ein leichtes Print-F, wo einfach das Format nicht stimmt. Ja, aber dann können ihm halt Leute helfen. Dann muss er nicht alles alleine machen. So muss er halt wirklich. Oder dann kann man auch mal entspannt eine Mail schreiben, wo man auch weiß, dass in diesem Forum da ankommt.
Das liegt auch an South Fortune-Lab.
Ja, das macht einfach keinen Spaß.
Bei GitHub so dieser Workflow mit vorklicken, irgendwie Pull-Request schicken, du siehst gleich, ob es irgendwie der Merch durchgeht.
Also ich sehe das ein, dass es damit einfacher ist. Das steht ja vollkommen außer Frage.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Community-Feeling als dann dieser.
Ob es wirklich genug Developer gibt, das ist jetzt zunächst einmal von uns eine Vermutung. Und ich würde mal sagen, so sexy ist das jetzt nicht.
Was?
Ja, an dieser AFP-Software mit rumzududeln.
Manchmal formuliert man sich da so rein und dann so schwer ist es manchmal gar nicht. Besonders, wenn ein Projekt ja schon mehr oder weniger fertig ist. Das Schlimmste ist noch irgendwie, was von vorne aufzusetzen.
Ich kann mir das alles selber zusammenreimen, warum jemand interessiert sein sollte. Aber ob jetzt wirklich so viele da sind, weiß ich nicht. Die Frage ist, was böte sich denn für ihn denn überhaupt an als Monetarisierung?
Eine Commercial License zum Beispiel.
Ist ja witzig, einer der Bitcoin-Programmierer ist auch, hier hat Netatalk Fork gemacht.
Auf GitHub.
Da, wo alle Forks...
Weil ich doch gerade meine, dieses...
Wie heißt das hier?
Junior, nee, JRM, Miss Dobbs, fehlt da nicht ein S, war doch immer. Jedenfalls, den kenn ich doch von Bitcoin und hat Sache, der ist auch bei Bitcoin. Naja, also wie gesagt, Sourceforge, es trägt bestimmt seinen Teil dazu bei.
Definitiv.
netafp.com gibt's jetzt auch schon.
Ja, ist aber eine gute Frage, was ist Netafp?
Vielleicht legen sie jetzt gerade alle los mit ihren...
Ja, jetzt fangen sie alle an, jetzt sind sie alle aufgeschreckt.
Briefly Unavailable for Scheduled Maintenance. Check back in a minute. Na, vielleicht hat der Frank Lahn deswegen heute Morgen gepublished, weil die Forks ein bisschen zu viel wurden.
Auf GitHub schießt schon das Kraut.
Ja, das lässt sich die Open Source-Gemeinde nicht lange gefallen, wenn einer sagt, er rückt es nicht mehr raus. Also ich kann sein Ärger schon auch verstehen, so ist es nicht, aber ich glaube auch, dass es die falsche Methode ist.
Ich habe auch die Frage, was wäre denn die richtige Methode?
Eine Commercial License.
Er kann ja nicht die Lizenz ändern, das geht ja nicht.
Na, das ist ja alles GPL, oder?
GPL oder ist es BSD? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Okay, wenn es BSD ist, ist es schwierig.
Also vor allem ist es halt eben nicht komplett sein Code. Das heißt, er kann auch kein Dual-Licensing mehr machen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie haben andere es auch geschafft im Nachhinein. Also es scheint nicht komplett unmöglich zu sein.
GPL ist es.
Also MySQL war ja auch eine Zeit lang GPL. Und die haben ja auch dann irgendwie so eine Commercial-License.
Commercial Support for Net Our Talk is available from Netafp.
Also Netafp ist von dem Typen selbst, von dem Frank Lahm oder wie?
Weiß ich nicht.
Schreibt da grad wer.
Der alte Kram von Netatalk, 1, wohl teilweise.
Ja, Franz Lahm, das ist von dem. Ja, und der ist aus Frankfurt.
Okay, das heißt, er versucht das zu tun, aber funktioniert nicht. Könnte auch daran liegen, dass die Seite nicht erreichbar ist.
Scheduled Maintenance for 4 years. Naja, also er ist auf jeden Fall so... Da gibt's noch einiges an Verbesserungspotenzial.
Ja, aber wenn's GPL ist, dann kann er da auch nix machen, richtig? Naja, wenn's komplett seins ist, dann kann er natürlich alles erstellen, was er bock hat. Ist aber nicht der Fall.
Ist ja nicht alles sein Copyright.
Genau, deswegen muss doch Harald Welte, auch von allen Leuten, die irgendwie IP-Tables irgendwie was mal irgendwie reingepupst haben, muss er sich irgendwie die Rechte übertragen lassen, dass der dann sozusagen klageberechtigt ist für die. Jedenfalls, da die Sonne kommt langsam wieder vor, also in Berlin jetzt nicht, hier regnet es weiterhin, aber im Netatalk-Bereich sieht es so aus, als wenn da noch was passieren könnte. Und ich würde mir auch glatt wünschen, wenn da mal noch ein paar mehr Leute mit dran rumfuschen oder mitkoden, wie auch immer. Wie zum Beispiel dieser Bitcoin-Typ. Ich weiß nicht, ich hoffe nicht, der hat nur ein Falk gemacht, weil er wollte, sondern weil er vielleicht auch, weil da was dran drehen will. Ich kann den ja mal im Bitcoin-Channel irgendwie ausquatschen.
Tja, vielleicht geht es jetzt auf einmal voran.
Das würde diesen Netatop-Wake wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut tun.
Ja, und dann könnte man vielleicht auch irgendjemand mal eine Hardware rausbringen, auf der man diesen ganzen Mumpets hier mit, jetzt hab ich schon wieder vergessen, wie es heißt.
Asus S-Bayer.
Was hab ich da installiert?
Freenas, ach so.
Ja, ich hatte so wenig Zeit mich darum zu kümmern. Und das nächste was passiert ist, ich hab's eingeschaltet und es bootet nicht. Und der PC zeigt jetzt auch nichts mehr auf den Bildschirm an. Nicht, dass ich irgendwas berührt hätte, ich hab's nur ausgeschaltet.
Und falsch, im Moment wahrscheinlich.
Ja, und jetzt kommt da kein Bild hoch und...
gleich in die Tonne.
Es ist total PC, ja? weiß nicht.
Ja, weil, also das ist wirklich bei diesen Gehäusen...
Man kann es nicht einfach zwei-, fünfmal, zehnmal, zumindest mal booten, so wie vorher. Ich bin vielleicht auch einfach zu doof.
Du bist eine Bugonschleuter.
Ja, ich bin eine Bugonschleuter.
Wenn was schief gehen kann, geht es bei mir schief.
Ich weiß.
Ja, also wir sagen es ja auch immer wieder, wenn ihr irgendwas gebaut habt oder ein Software gecoded habt und ihr wollt die mal so richtig getestet haben auf Herz und Nieren, ja, dann schickt die mal Tim. Und der benutzt das dann vielleicht eine Woche und wenn es dann zerbröselt auf dem Boden liegt, dann...
Der verhökert hier wirklich voll den Service und dann auch noch wieder muss man pro CPU bezahlen. Core 1 bis 8, 75 Dollar pro Core pro Jahr. Core 9 bis 16, 50 Dollar pro Core pro Jahr.
Für Netatalk?
Für...
Support Incidence Unlimited.
Und wenn er davon nicht leben kann, das heißt, es kauft niemand oder was? Also er hat nicht einen Kunden, weil wenn er einen Kunden hätte, dann hätte er schon zumindest so ein bisschen Cashflow.
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, aber...
Na, es ist Support für laufende Systeme, nicht Support für verkaufte Produkte. Ist ja nicht Lizenz.
Ja, aber so oder so, scheint er da nicht viel von zu haben.
Können wir ja mal anrufen. Vielleicht können wir das ja mal erklären. Warum das nicht geht.
Da werd ich ja gespannt.
Das geht nicht.
Ja, Backup, Backup, Backup.
Das Thema. Aber man muss schon sagen, mit Time-Machine und so ist das schon alles viel schicker geworden. Und hier so die ganzen Windows- und Linux-Leute, die müssen das ja alles ja noch mal manuell machen. Da gibt es ja nichts so. Nicht so was wie Time-Machine vom US. Gleich hier Platte ranstöpseln, automatisch Backup und so.
Was ist denn hier eigentlich aus diesen lokalen Time-Machine geworden jetzt in Line?
Tja, ist da.
Wer irgendwie Backups macht, während man gar keine Platte dran hat und die dann später rüber schiebt.
Wie, weißt du auch nicht? Hast du aus Syracusa gelesen?
Ja, aber dieses Konto geht immer noch nicht mit Time-Capsule. Und es geht auch irgendwie, weiß nicht, wo schaltet man diesen lokalen Backup-Kram denn ein? Den schaltet man gar nicht mehr ein.
Der ist einfach an, der findet einfach statt. Also bei mir war es so, erst habe ich davon gar nichts mitbekommen und in dem Moment, wo ich eine externe Platte dran hatte und dann Time-Machine angeschaltet hatte, dann ging es auch los. Und dann macht sich das so bemerkbar, dass da irgendwie alle paar Nase lang, also vielleicht so alle paar Stunden oder so, tickt so dieser Backup-D und unser Metadata, also MDS-Prozess, den wir ja auch schon lieben und schätzen gelernt haben, die ticken dann mal kurz so auf 80% CPU und rödeln da für eine Minute und dann ist es auch erstmal wieder gut. Und ansonsten habe ich davon jetzt noch nicht viel weiter mitbekommen. Und dann steckst du die Platte an und dann sügt es sich wieder.
So ist das.
Und der Siracusa meinte, dass das alles auch sehr unspektakulär implementiert ist letztendlich. Das ist das gleiche wieder mit diesen Hardlinks.
Er macht einfach lokal in einem Hidden Volume in diesen Mobile-Backups.
Genau.
Macht er einfach die Hardlinks quasi auf der eigenen Platte. Das ist eigentlich alles.
Sozusagen, genau. Der Siracusa heult auch ein Lied.
Es gibt keine Snapshots.
Genau, es gibt keine Snapshots. Also er beklagt das auch sehr, dass dieses Fallsystem schon seit mehreren Reviews einer der Hauptkritikpunkte ist. Und ja, das da immer noch nicht landen sich. Aber er meinte ja, dass dieser Volume oder das Core Storage schon ein erster Schritt sein könnte, wo sie dann früher oder später einfach das Fallsystem an sich dann auch nochmal austauschen können. Aber jetzt schon so ein bisschen infrastrukturregens rum. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube gelesen zu haben, dass du auch mit diesem Core Storage prinzipiell mehrere Platten zu einem Volume schon zusammenfassen könntest.
Klingt so. Ich meine, es scheint mir ein Logical Volume Manager zu sein. Zum Beispiel, so liest sich das ja hier sogar auf der Disk Utility Core Storage.
Wahrscheinlich sind die erstmal noch ziemlich beschränkt auch. Und ich denke mal, die werden jetzt also beschränkt in dem Sinne, dass sie halt erstmal hauptsächlich für ihr Encryption das fertig und getestet und stabil haben. Und die werden jetzt demnächst das, was auf ihrem Zettel steht, was sie machen wollten, nach und nach irgendwie mit reinschieben. Und so ein Volume Manager, wenn man einen schreibt, der modern ist und der kommt ja nun jetzt gerade raus, müsste ja schon irgendwie alle Features und noch mehr haben, die andere Volume Manager auch schon so haben.
Also, ja, denk ich mal.
Ja, alles sind jetzt Logical Volumes hier. Logical Volumes Family, Physical Volumes, Logical Volumes Group.
Group!
Da waren wir aber auch schon vor langer Zeit. Logical Volumes, wo war das das erste Mal? Ich glaube, das hat IBM mit AEX seiner Zeit eingeführt. Das waren, glaube ich, die ersten, die mit Logical Volumes gearbeitet haben unter Unix. Das ist schon sehr lange her. Sehr lange her. Seitdem hat sich natürlich eine Menge getan. Nur bei Apple nicht. Aber jetzt haben wir sowas hier auch ein bisschen.
Wie hieß diese Kreuzung aus Tiger und Löwe? In Mac OS Liga. Da werden wir dann bestimmt auch das neue Fallsystem sehen.
Ist das jetzt die letzte Katze?
Also danach werde ich sie nicht bringen.
Nee, glaube ich auch nicht.
Nee, aber was bleibt denn jetzt noch?
Neon-Cat fand ich ja sehr schön vorstellen. Oder wie auch immer das auffällt. Ja, was sag mal Tim hier du als alter Feature-Prediger, was fehlt denn jetzt eigentlich noch in so Mac OS?
Na, also bleiben wir gleich da, wo wir sowieso hängen. Also es fehlt einfach richtige Snapshots, keine Ahnung.
Also Filesystem auf jeden Fall noch.
Ich finde Filesystem, da kann man einfach noch eine ganze Menge bringen.
Ja, finde ich auch. Also ZFS fehlt einfach. Ganz easy und simpel. Oder was ein Filesystem, was so viel kann wie ZFS. Nee, nee, muss gar nicht ganz so viel sein, aber also Check Summing. Ich will halt Check Summing haben.
Ja, Krypto haben sie jetzt.
Ja, aber halt wieder auch so unten drunter.
Ja, aber unten drunter ist eigentlich besser als oben drüber.
Wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Wie unten drunter, ich meine...
Wir müssen jetzt eigentlich auch Sachen encrypten. Wie soll man sagen, also wo jetzt auch gerade nichts da liegt oder ist die so schlau, dass nur das encryptet wird, wo auch die Blöcke gerade in Benutzung sind? Weil das ist halt der Unterschied zwischen einem Fallsystem, was irgendwie weiß, was belegt ist und nur das kryptet oder auch wirklich einfach jeder Block, egal ob da was drin ist, was spannend ist oder nicht, gekryptet wird. Was ja zum Beispiel bei dem Trim auch wieder so eine Arge wäre, wie das dann da läuft.
Hätte ich derzeit überhaupt nicht beantworten. Dazu muss sie mir das alles mal ein bisschen genauer anschauen.
Naja, so, und dann Pilesystem haben wir. Und was fehlt uns noch?
Was ich gerne hätte, und ich glaube es gab es schon mal bei Next Step, ist, ich will nicht VNC haben, sondern ich will einen Tool haben, womit ich einen Rechnerfernbediener und die mir aber ihre Drawing-Commandos zu meinem Rechner schicken. Also so gesehen das, was jetzt gerade mit der Grafikkarte passiert, dass halt nur noch die Drawing-Commands zur Karte geschickt werden und dann dort ausgeführt werden. So hätte ich es gerne mit so einer Art VNC, dass ich mich irgendwo einlogge und wenn da ein Font ist, dann schickt er mir einmal den Font und der Font wird dann bei mir ins Fenster gerendert und nicht irgendwie die Bitmaps von der Stelle, wo da der Font ist, wird irgendwie zu mir rüber gerendert, sondern die Commands zum Zeichnen kommen, zum Beispiel, weil es dann wieder ultra schnell wird. Oder, dass wenn ich ein Fenster verschiebe, dann schickt der halt das Kommando zu mir, dieses Fenster wandert jetzt nach da. Und dann sind das halt ein paar Bytes, die übertragen werden müssen und sonst gar nichts. Und sowas hätte ich gerne. Und das gab es wohl schon mal.
Für einen Clienten mäßig dann auch fast schon wieder.
RDC-X11.
Was ist denn jetzt hier mit diesem Feature? Remote einloggen und man kriegt einen zweiten Desktop.
Haben wir schon mal getestet, glaube ich. Mach mal an, ich log mich mal bei dir ein. Komm, mach mir einen Account auf deiner Krypto-Platte. Ich mach auch nichts.
Ihr beide könnt es ja machen.
Ich kann ja gerne mal hier in den Account klicken. Ich mach dir Account.
Crossland.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hab mich schon ewig nicht mehr auf einem anderen Rechner eingeloggt. So wichtig ist es eigentlich auch nicht. Was brauch ich eigentlich noch?
Ja, irgendwie so langsam dünnt es sich dann auch aus an Features, die man so haben will.
Ja, ein bisschen schon.
Also sie können halt jetzt das Ganze, was sie gemacht haben mit ihrem Sandboxing und den Eingekapselten installs und so, das können sie dann alles noch ein bisschen feiner machen und durchziehen und so, aber...
Ja, mit dem Sandboxing, das ist schon eigentlich wenn, also da passiert ja wohl noch ein bisschen was.
Trim für alle, ja, auch das.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, was jetzt eigentlich fehlt. Ich meine, ich muss mal erstmal ein bisschen darüber im Klaren sein, was jetzt überhaupt da ist.
Ja, auch diese Syncing-Geschichte mit der iCloud, ich glaube, die wird uns auch noch nicht so 100%ig, wie du schon sagtest, so zwei Rechner mal einander stecken und so eine Geschichten, das sind noch so Sachen. So, hier hast du gemacht bei Antares.
Moment, ich hab hier gerade noch Verwirrung.
Peter Fnord.
Passwort hättest du gerne?
Ist dein Rechner jetzt per IPv6 von überall erreichbar?
Hier ist dein Passwort.
Hier ist mein Passwort? Ja, steht das da drauf. Alles klein.
New Account, Standard, Manage with Parental Controls. Sharing only, ach Group, ach nee, man kann jetzt Gruppen anlegen im normalen, ah. Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen. Man kann jetzt auch im normalen Account-Panel auch Gruppen machen. Na guck an.
Na guck mal einer Show.
Na guck mal einer Notbook.
So und worüber soll das jetzt funktionieren? Aber nicht über Screensharing, oder?
Du kannst jetzt in dem Finder.
Doch, über Screensharing.
Im Finder klickst du jetzt Share Screen. Und dann fragt er mich jetzt hoffentlich gleich nach Username, Passwort.
Hab ich Screensharing an.
Ja, Huckel fragt da her und dann tippst du jetzt ein hier, Banane. So, Ask to Share the Display.
Nee, willst ja nicht.
See your Desktop and Files.
So, Huckel kriegt jetzt seinen eigenen. Und bei dir müsst ihr jetzt weiterhin...
Du kriegst jetzt den Login-Screen.
Ja, aber er kann sich jetzt auch halt einloggen. Und deiner geht nicht weg, das ist ja das Ding. Also er geht nicht über deinen drüber.
Das heißt, man kann nicht mal eben jemanden auf den Desktop gehen, wenn der eingeloggt ist.
Doch, stand ja gerade. Dann hätten wir jetzt auf Tin klicken müssen. Haben wir ja nicht.
Nee, Ask hätte man dann.
Dann musst du immer noch fragen, wenn schon einer ist. Das ist sehr elegant.
Das war doch aber vorher auch schon so.
Nee, nee, nee.
Dann sollte man anwählen, dass man informiert werden will, bevor einem einer über die Session reinkommt.
Hatte das nicht nur angezeigt im Menü?
Ja, oder so.
Man konnte es einstellen, dass du auch ohne Login einfach anklopfen kannst. Zeig mir mal den Screen.
Aber geht hier nix, ne? Schon mal direkt weggekrascht.
Aber du kannst nix anklicksonen.
Auch ich starte gar nicht. Nein, ich mach mal nochmal. Das geht ja hier nicht so.
Remote-Login ist hier für All-Users eingeschaltet. Screensharing ist auch All-Users.
Ich kann einmal klicken, aber dann passiert nichts.
Also funktioniert nicht.
Nee, da hat uns Onkel Steve wieder das Blower vom Himmel versprochen. Jetzt klicke ich mal bei dir und ask mal to share your display. Ja, das funktioniert wohl. Da kann ich jetzt hier dich fernsteuern. Aber meinen eigenen Screen, das geht irgendwie nicht.
Hm, also vielleicht noch ein Bug, aber man... Also das geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung.
Es geht in die richtige Richtung, das ist richtig, ja.
Pfiffig. Na, ich meine, das lag ja irgendwie auch nah, weil dieses Multi-User, mit mehreren Eingelogged-Signen, hat ja eigentlich eh schon denselben Zustand gemacht. Was ich mich halt frage ist, also wenn das jetzt funktioniert, ob man nicht dann sozusagen auch so Mac Mini auch ohne Bildschirm nutzen ziehen kann. Du stellst ja halt so ein Mac Mini hin und das ist sozusagen so der Ort, wo jeder auch drauf arbeiten kann, aber du benutzt halt normalerweise so deinen Laptop als Bildschirm. Aber du kannst auf dem Teil Programme fahren, Daten haben und so, ohne die jetzt übers Netz sharen zu müssen und so weiter. Also es ist mehr so ein Login-Server. Und das könnten dann eben theoretisch auch mehrere Leute gleichzeitig machen.
Und vor allem das Screensharing geht ja dann wieder als Fullscreen-App so, dass du irgendwie deinen Remote-Desktop sozusagen auch so voll auf dein Display pusten kannst und dann bist du auch drauf. Und wenn du dann mit dem Resolution Independent Interface noch auf die Zielauflösung deines Clients irgendwie alles hoch oder runter skalieren kannst, dann bist du ein bisschen verrückt. Also wir stellen schon fest, thin clients sind also die Zukunft.
Ja, da bin ich mir immer noch nicht so richtig so sicher, ob das eigentlich, was eigentlich für dich so genau die Zukunft ist. Aber ich fand jetzt deine Frage, was wir uns jetzt eigentlich noch wünschen, war ja eigentlich eine verdammt gute Frage. Ich bin mir bloß gerade nicht so sicher. Also ich weiß, was ich mir jetzt gerade so generell wünsche. Das hat aber gerade gar nicht so viel mit Betriebssystemen zu tun.
Und das wäre?
Ähm, mal gucken, ob hier überhaupt noch alle...
alle Fans auf Halbmast sind?
alle Streams laufen. Ach nee, es ist hier schon wieder...
Streams sind ja schon wieder alle abgekackt hier. Das ist ja wirklich alles eine Scheiße.
Bestimmt euch das Remote-Test aus dem anderen Rechner? Ich hab hier so Skripte, die es eigentlich automatisch wieder starten sollen, aber das scheint nicht geklappt zu haben.
Das hab ich hier nicht so im Blick.
Ach ja, dass uns überhaupt noch einer zuhört, ist ein Wunder. Ähm, ja, ich kann ja auch mal ein bisschen meinen Ärger rauslassen, oder? Dafür sind wir ja hier, wa?
Genau, alle warten darauf.
Worüber haben wir jetzt überhaupt gerade geredet? Wir haben über Remote-Login genäht.
Ich muss mir das ja auch mal alles mal merken.
OS, Features, worüber haben wir denn davor noch geredet? Ja, nee.
In verschiedensten Variationen.
Ach, NetArtalk hier, jetzt vor diesem Kram hier, wo wir gerade hingeblieben. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Kannst du dir das ja alles nochmal anhören, dann?
Jaja, klar, ich hör mir das alles nochmal an. Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab so ein bisschen was zu meckern. Ich glaub, ich hab teilweise hab ich das schon mal gemeckert, aber ich glaub, ich muss mir auch nochmal wiederholen. Hab ich schon mal hier darüber, über Audio-Programme gemeckert?
Kommt mir nicht unbekannt vor, aber ja, so, das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen unspezifisch, ne?
Also, es gibt auf dem Mac kein einziges Programm mit Einschränkungen, sag ich das jetzt. Dazu komm ich auch gleich. Also es gibt zumindest keins, was mir gefällt. Bei dem man was Audio abspielt, entweder so lokale Dateien, also so Player, oder so Streams. Bei Streams sieht es besonders scheiße aus.
So Radio-Hören-Ding.
Also sowas wie iTunes oder so. Bei dem man sagen kann, über welches Audiodevice man das hören möchte. Was ich völlig absurd finde. Also dass man mit einem Audioprogramm, wo es um Hören geht, nicht sagen kann, wo man das hören will. Jetzt kommt die Einschränkung. Ja, bei VLC kann man das einstellen.
Das wollte ich doch gerade sagen.
Aber er vergisst dieses Setting auch wieder, wenn du das Programm beendest und wieder neu startest. Abgesehen davon, dass das UI dafür grauselig ist. Dann gibt es irgendwie M-Player Extended. Der kann es auch, der merkt sich das auch. Eigentlich nur katastrophale Ergebnisse, was so das Abspielen von Streams betrifft mit diesem Programm. Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich 1000 Leute kommen, die sagen, ich habe noch nie ein Problem damit gehabt. Und wie kannst du das überhaupt sagen? War bei mir einfach so. Sind jetzt auch nicht so ganz die Programme, die mir besonders gut gefallen? Würden sie das tun, was ich brauche? Würde ich sie auch fröhlich und happy benutzen? Ich verstehe bloß überhaupt nicht, warum die ganzen anderen Programme das nicht können. Vielleicht gibt es ja etwas, aber ich habe nichts gefunden. Ich habe dann auch mal hier, wie heißt dieses schicke Ding, was so Audios, Radiostreams auch abspielt. Hab ich den Namen schon wieder vergessen. Den habe ich dann irgendwie auch noch in eine Mail geschrieben und gleich mal so im Support. Ja, hier, wie wär's denn mal mit diesen Features? Und ich würde ja ganz gern mal den Audiokanal auswählen und so. Ja, ein paar von den Features werden vielleicht auch mal kommen und so. Und dann habe ich auch gleich so alles reingeschrieben, was ich so wollte und unter anderem halt, dass man überhaupt mal einen Audioport auswählen kann. Das traue ich mich gar nicht als Feature-Request zu anzuerkennen, bei einem Audioprogramm. Ich meine, what's the fucking problem? Ja, ein Audiokanal, einfach so ein Pop-Up in Präferenz zu haben, wo man sagt, darüber abspielen. Oder? Also ich meine, da fehlt mir die Luft. Und abgesehen davon ist es halt einfach so, dass jedes Audio-Device mehrere Kanäle hat.
So ist das.
Aber glaubst du, es gibt auch nur ein Programm, und das vollzählen soweit alle in der selben Kiste jetzt wieder, wo du auch mal die Kanäle auswählen könntest. Und das ist einfach, wenn du hier so ein Audio-Interface kaufst, so ein USB-Teil und so weiter, das ist ein Device in Kanäle. So, und wenn du mal über irgendeins was ausgeben willst, dann musst du gleich so ein Tool wie Logic oder Live oder Cubase starten, die irgendwie die einzigen Programme sind, die schon mal davon gehört haben, dass Audio-Devices auch mehr als nur einen Stereokanal haben können. Nur sind solche Programme halt für diesen Zweck vollkommen ungeeignet, geschweige denn zu teuer und bekloppt und sehen scheiße aus. Und ich will natürlich nicht jedes Mal eine Audio-Suit starten, nur um einen Radiostream abzuspielen. Oder überhaupt mal irgendwas abzuspielen.
Aber M-Player und VLC können es prinzipiell?
Dieser M-Player Extended zumindest.
Also der kann auch die Kanäle auswählen oder nur das Device?
Nein, das können sie alle nicht. Sondern das können sie das Device auswählen. Und wie gesagt bei VLC ist es auch unbrauchbar, weil er dieses Setting nur temporär macht. Also zumindest das OS X VLC und so weiter. Klar, jetzt kann man einen Skript machen, guck mal, eine Zeile geht mir vom Leib. Ich rede jetzt hier von normaler, freundlicher Consumer Software, die einfach mal das tut. Stattdessen gehen sie alle auf den Default. Schöne Ausnahme ist zum Beispiel hier mein kleines Programm Soundboard. Da kann man das Audio Device tatsächlich auswählen.
Dafür gehen dann die Headsets nicht mehr?
Dafür kannst du nicht das Default Device auswählen. Also wenn du es mal wirklich auf das Default Device haben willst, geht es da wiederum nicht. Das fand ich auch geil. Und Kanäle auswählen? Das war nämlich die, den ich in den Mail geschrieben hab. Und die meinten dann, nee, Kanäle auswählen und so weiter. Da gibt es doch hier unser anderes 150-Euro-Produkt, was was ganz anderes macht. Hier dieses Wiretap Anywhere. Und damit kannst du das ja von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge vielleicht auch irgendwie machen. Hilft mir überhaupt nicht weiter. Da hab ich sie echt nur noch für bekloppt erklärt. Geht's doch. Also das ist wirklich...
Aber es kann ja eigentlich nicht so schwer sein, ne?
Nein, das kann alles nicht so schwer sein. Martin meint ja immer, mit Chor-Audio zu prämieren, das wäre ja eine Strafe. Und dafür müsste man ja von Apple bezahlt werden, um das irgendwie zu benutzen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, Audio-Kanal auswählen, also...
Schnell mal so einen Kanal auswählen.
Kann doch nicht das Problem sein, oder?
Dennis, mach das doch mal kurz Xcode auf und steck mal im Interface-Bilder...
Hast du das mal gemacht, Dennis? Hast du mal ein Programm geschrieben, was ein Audio-Kanal aufmacht?
Also...
Ich hab noch nie wirklich irgendwas mit Sound gemacht, glaube ich. Zum Not lässt du mal irgendwie so ein Dingling abspielen, aber da wählst du ja keine Kanäle auseinander. Das kommt dann heraus, worauf sie...
Also, liebe Hörer, wenn ihr schon mal mit Xcode, also Objective-C, also Coco, herumgespielt habt mit Audio, ist es schwer, ein Dropdown-Menü, eine Auswahlbox zu machen, wo man das Audio-Device und die Kanäle vielleicht auswählen kann, um damit auszuwählen, wo ein etwaiger Sound abgespielt werden soll? Wenn ja, wenn nein, schreibt das doch mal in unsere Kommentare, damit wir wissen, ob es vielleicht wirklich ein Mammut-mäßiger Aufwand ist, der einem normalen Sterblichen nicht aufzuerlegen ist, oder ob es vielleicht doch ganz einfach ist.
Es geht. Ich hab hier ein Soundboard-Programm und das tut genau das. Soundboard von Ambrosia hat hier so ein kleines Pop-Up und das sagt mir, auf welchen Kanal es rausgehen soll und fertig. Ich meine, das Sound-Control-Panel von Mac OS X hat dieses Interf... Das gibt es schon immer. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Und das prangere ich an.
Audacity kennt das auch nicht.
Und dann kommen wir gleich auf das Feature, was dem OS X einfach fehlt. Es geht nicht. Es ist vollkommen schwierig. Man könnte das ganze Problem dadurch lösen, in dem OS X, ich hab noch gar nicht geguckt, ob sich im Audi-Bereich irgendwas geändert hat, aber ich befürchte mal nichts. Bevor ich jetzt hier Scheiße erzähle, guck ich noch kurz rein. Aber mit diesen Aggregate Devices ist es wahrscheinlich immer noch dasselbe Spiel.
Haben sie jetzt ganz gestrichen?
Wie, es gibt keine Aggregate Devices mehr?
Hallo?
Ah, doch hier ist ein Plus.
Create Multi-Output Device.
Wieder die spannenden Momente im Mobile Max.
Was ist denn ein?
Wird erst hinkriegen.
Will Output Audio Simultaneously?
Sie erfahren es in der nächsten Sendung. Cliffhanger, zack.
Mal eine Runde Angry Birds spielen. Das ist ja hier auch krass, dieses Lotzi-Ding.
Guck mal, wenn man in einem Fullscreen ist und man macht Ctrl-Cursor-Down, dann verlässt er den Fullscreen-Modus. Also ein Xcode hat er den gerade verlassen, den Fullscreen-Modus. Wenn ich hier Fullscreen mache, ein Xcode und mache jetzt Ctrl-Cursor-Down, jetzt geht es ja auch nicht mehr.
Das ist eine Scheiße. Aber, heißen die Lotzis diese Patentrolle?
Ja.
Da hat ja einer getwittert irgendwie Angry Birds Lotzis Edition, wo es statt Schwein dann Patentrolle gibt. Das wär's eigentlich mal, ja. Das ist auch echt eine witzige, also nicht eine witzige, ist eigentlich eine komische, also da bin ich auch mal sehr gespannt, wie die Entwicklung jetzt weitergeht, wenn sie jetzt wirklich da hergehen und die Patentrolle, die Indie-Developer irgendwie alle an den Karren fahren, ja. Da gibt's ja jetzt, da wird dir so ein bisschen Panik geschoben gerade. Aber ihr seid total vertieft in eurer eigenen...
Ich versuch dir zuzulernen, weil ich ja gerade bevor ich jetzt hier anfange, Scheiße zu erzählen.
Ich bin durch.
Dennis, geht nicht. Wir machen so selten Mobile-Max. Die Leute wollen alles von dir. Wobei sonst wenn irgendwie noch...
Ich hab in der letzten Sendung über meinen Pool berichtet. Und wir sind jetzt bei 25 Giga-Hash irgendwie pro Sekunde. Und es läuft eigentlich ganz gut. Und ich hab dann eine feste Mannschaft, die irgendwie auch dabei bleibt und nicht immer nur mal gucken kommen und dann nach zwei, drei Tagen wieder weg sind. Weil wir hatten die ersten beiden Blöcke ziemlich. Unser Glück war uns nicht heult. Und dafür aber die nächsten drei Blöcke, die kamen so schnell. Also wir sind jetzt immer noch voll überdurchschnittlich in Auszahlung. Also Jungs, die, die abgehauen sind, weil sie dachten, die ersten beiden Blöcke sind so schlecht, waren besonders zwei Leute, die echt gleich knapp unter mir waren in den Giga-Schiss. Also richtig fette Jungs und die sind einfach weggegangen. Ihr hättet so viel Bitcoins verdient, aber ihr seid ja vorher abgehauen, selber schuld. Also nach Regen kommt Sonne, Jungs, müsst ihr euch mal merken.
Wie viel Bitcoins habt ihr denn jetzt verdient?
300.
300 Bitcoins? Mit der Rechnerei? Und das verteilt sich über wie viele Leute?
Viele.
Das heißt?
Da muss sich alles auszeigen.
Ja, aber wie viel bleibt da denn für dich?
Na, das hab ich noch gar nicht so richtig geguckt, aber in dem Speed, wo wir gerade Blöcke finden, also das kannst du, das brauch ich gar nicht nachgucken, das lohnt einfach gar nicht. Wenn wir jetzt gerade so einen Durchschnitt alle drei Tage einen Blog finden und die Leute da 1% anklicken, und das sind nur manche, die meisten klicken ja 0% an, das heißt von diesen 50 Bitcoins kriege ich vielleicht, was ist, 1% wäre 0,5, ne? So, das machen aber nicht alle, das heißt, ich kriege eher so ein zehntel Bitcoin pro Blog, den wir finden. Und bei sechs Blöcken macht das 0,6 Bitcoins. Da kriege ich nicht mal nicht nur die Provider-Rechnung nicht mit rein, dass wenn ich den Strom bezahlen müsste, würde ich den nicht mal reinkriegen. Für die Kiste, die noch nicht viel macht. Das ist noch nicht mal Bitcoin-Main, was viel Strom kostet.
Aber sein Business-Modell funktioniert nicht, da würde ich den Sozco einfach nicht rausgeben.
Doch, der funktioniert schon, wenn, die Kiste ist ja nicht ausgelastet, also wir könnten ja viel mehr Leute mit Get-Works, also heißen diese Request, die man macht, damit man Arbeit für seinen Mainer kriegt, versorgen. Und wenn wir dann irgendwann mal vielleicht 10 Blöcke am Tag finden, was schon ganz schön viel wäre, aber jedenfalls ein paar mehr Blöcke am Tag, dann würde man schon so langsam in den grünen Bereich kommen. Aber noch ist einfach viel zu wenig.
Aber es sind insgesamt 300 Bitcoins quasi für das Erarbeiten eingenommen worden durch alle, die mitgerechnet haben.
Genau, wir haben 6 Blöcke gefunden. Das muss ich kurz gucken. Aber es sind so Active, also die heißen halt Worker immer. Und Active Worker haben wir gerade 136. Das sind aber auch nicht einzelne Leute, weil es ist eigentlich so Usus, dass man sich pro GPU einen Worker anlegt, damit man genau sehen kann, auf welche Karte jetzt gerade noch was macht, wie schnell die ist. Und für die nächste Karte macht man sich einen weiteren Worker. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es alle so machen, aber man könnte sagen, dass wir 136 Grafikkarten oder einzelne GPUs irgendwie am Start haben. Aber ich denke, ein paar Leute machen es auch nicht. Also wie viele es wirklich sind, einzeln kann ich nicht so sagen. Aber was ich sagen kann, ist, dass wir ca. 300 Auszahlungen haben. Aber es sagt über die Anzahl der Leute eigentlich auch nicht direkt was aus. Da müsste ich nochmal tiefer forschen, weiß ich gar nicht. Aber es werden schon so 100 sein.
Also Business läuft noch nicht so richtig.
Aber du bist auch nicht unzufrieden mit dem Zustand.
Na ja, doch. Ich hätte es schon noch ein bisschen mehr. Weil sonst habe ich wirklich nur Kosten. Das wäre ein bisschen blöd. Aber auf jeden Fall macht es voll Spaß. Ich sehe das ein bisschen anders als dieser Netatalk-Typ. Ich mache das ja noch mit drei Kumpels zusammen. Wir machen Python, wir machen Engines als Proxy davor. Wir machen Postgres, dass es flutscht und optimiert. Und mit Index und tralala. Dann machen wir alles auf ZFS. Dann muss ich wieder mit Platten rumbasteln. Ich musste mit dem Server rumbasteln. Ich musste mit IPMI rumbasteln. Ich muss mit Jails rumbasteln. Jetzt machen wir einen Mail-Server. Da muss ich mich demnächst mit SSL beschäftigen. Also einmal den ganzen Kram, den man machen muss. Den müssen wir jetzt einmal machen. Und wenn man so auf die 60 zugeht, ist das gar nicht so weit. Aber wenn man schon ein bisschen älter ist, und dann ist man ja auch, ich weiß nicht, ich hab jetzt eine Weile lang dieses iOS-Programmierung gemacht. Und dann war ich voll aus dem FreeBSD-Kram. Ich war echt so ein bisschen raus. Also meine Kiste zu Hause lief so gut. Und ab und zu einen neuen Körnel gebaut und so weiter. Und eine neue Welt installiert und fertig. Aber hab sonst da nicht mehr so viel gemacht. Und dann vergisst man schon Sachen. Dann weiß man gar nicht mehr, wie die so gingen. Und jetzt bin ich wieder so richtig voll drin. Und das ist schon auch ganz cool. Man kriegt einmal so den kompletten Refresh. Und sieht mal wieder, was so der neueste Scheiß ist. Und lernt dann, dass halt SQL nicht alles ist. Sondern dann gibt es halt hier diese schnelleren Memcached-D und Redes und was weiß ich nicht. Alles, die man so davor schalten kann. Find ich ganz gut.
Nach dem kurzen Einwurf kann ich mal kurz...
Nichts interessiert den Tim immer gar nicht, wenn wir über uns persönlich Sachen erzählen.
Ja, ich hab mir auch ein neues Shampoo letztens gekauft.
Klar interessiert mich das, das hätte ich ja nicht gefragt. Aber es war doch jetzt abgeschlossen, oder nicht?
Ich habe dazu nichts mehr zu sagen.
Ich habe fertig.
Nächstes Leinen Netzwerk noch gleich, Bitcoin was?
So, was hast du jetzt rausgefunden?
Also es gibt tatsächlich ein neues Feature, von dem ich bisher noch nichts wusste. Ich habe allerdings keine Ahnung, wozu man das braucht. Aber wenn du jetzt mehrere Stereo... Du kannst halt jetzt in diesem Audio-Midi-Setup...
Das, was irgendwo ganz tief unten versteckt ist, dieses Tool, richtig?
Ganz tief unten, na das liegt halt so in den Ups rum. Oder in Utilities, glaube ich.
Das ist nicht mit Xcode irgendwie noch...
Applications, Utilities, na nein, das ist Standard. Das ist an sich ein sehr wertvolles Tool, wenn man mit Audio und vor allem mit Midi arbeitet. Darüber kann man so allerlei lustige Sachen machen. Aber mir ist einfach die Motivation bei diesem Feature-Set ist mir vollkommen unklar. Also was es zum Beispiel schon immer, oder schon längere Zeit, ich glaube seit 10, 3 oder 4, seitdem sie irgendwann mal Core Audio eingeführt haben, was war das, 10, 2, gibt es diese Aggregate-Devices. Da kannst du halt mehrere zu einem logischen Device zusammenfassen. So, und dann gibst du dem halt einen Namen und dann kannst du das auswählen, als wärst du ein eigenes Device. Und was er aber macht, ist er legt die Kanäle der anderen Devices hintereinander, und zwar alle. Das heißt, das ist dann ganz praktisch, wenn du eben, wie vorhin schon erzählt, eben mit so Programmarbeit ist, wo du sowieso den Kanal auswählen kannst. Dann hast du halt drei solche Geräte, machst den in ein Aggregate Device und kannst dann immer noch deinem Logic oder Live oder Cubase sagen, hier, das ist das Device, mit dem du arbeiten sollst. Und dann kannst du auf alle Kanäle von allen Devices zugreifen und Core Audio kümmert sich um diesen Audio-Drift und den ganzen Kram.
Ich lache auch jedes Mal drüber, wenn ich über dieses Programm stolpe. Der muss alles so drüber, das ist echt unglaublich.
Der Dist hat gerade die Affenwelt nochmal ausgewacht. Aber Michael trostet das tatsächlich auch, wie deine Geschichte mit den Kanälen weitergeht.
Spannend.
Hier Timme, einmal drauf gucken bitte.
Der Killer-Joke hat einen würdigen Nachfolger gefunden.
Aber apropos Killer-Joke, nochmal kurz unterbrechen, weil wir wollen ja nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Segelsteine sind.
Es gibt heute eine Seite mit den schlimmsten Auto-Corrects im IOS. Könnt ihr auch noch zuhören? Und da sind die 15 besten Auto-Corrects, die voll in die Hose gegangen sind, aufgelistet. Ich hab da auch Tränen gelacht. Ich poste die mal hier in den Chat. Ihr könnt die ja auch noch mal verlinken. Die sind nicht komplett jugendfrei. Aber bei manchen Sachen sind echt... Ich würde mich auch in Grund und Boden verliegen, wenn ich meiner Mama aus Versehen so was SMSen würde. Oder sie mir irgendwie.
IOS Auto-Corrects.
Und das Schlimme ist, auf dem Lyon geht es ja auch schon los mit dem Verschreiben. Besonders wenn man Englisch und Deutsch chattet, kriegt das ja auch immer nicht so mit. Also es kann ja irgendwie nicht merken, dass man auch mal in einer anderen Sprache chattet. Du kannst den Affen ja auch mal in den Dings posten.
Mach das mal in die Show-Notes, damit passen zum Lachfleisch.
Wie heißt das Teil?
Der macht auch noch die Fotos von sich selber. Der schnappt sich halt die Kamera und knips da irgendwie fröhlich seine eigene Visage.
Und lacht sich auch noch eins dabei.
Ja, hier meinte auch jemand, wir sollten vielleicht mal das Fenster aufmachen. So was ist jetzt mit diesen Kanälen hier.
Okay, also ich versuch's noch mal zusammenzupassen. Es gibt Devices, die haben Kanäle. Die meisten haben zwei, manche haben mehr. Mit so was wie Soundflower kannst du dir auch virtuelle anlegen etc. Aggregate-Devices sind halt ein System-Level-Feature, dass du eben mehrere Devices zu einem zusammenfassen kannst. Dann nimmst du aber alle Kanäle von allen Devices rein. Und in der Reihenfolge, in der du das packst, du hast auch die Reihenfolge der Kanäle. Hast du also ersten 16-Kanal-Devices, dann die ersten 16, dann 8-Kanal-Devices, dann die nächsten 8 etc. Das hilft mir jetzt allerdings bei einem speziellen Problem überhaupt nicht weiter. Ich meine, es ist gut, dass es das gibt. Und es ist auch nötig, dass das Betriebssystem das für dich macht, weil du hast halt immer dieses Problem mit Clock-Deviation, dass deine Zeit auseinanderläuft und du willst halt über mehrere Devices das mit dieser Zeit-Synchronisation irgendwie hinhauen. Ich habe aber jetzt das Problem, ich habe jetzt hier ein Device mit vielen Kanälen, möchte da aber mehrere Programme separat unterschiedliche Kanäle ansprechen. Ich würde zum Beispiel gerne Skype zwei Kanäle davon geben. Und eine andere Telefonie-Applikation, damit das auf meinem Mischpult hier landet.
Unter Windows geht sowas alles, ne? Kann man das da nicht so grafisch, wie die Connections da so ziehen?
Ja, bei Windows 7 gibt es auf jeden Fall so eine Art Mischpult-Dings zum Abgreifen der Programme. Wie das genau funktioniert, kann ich nicht sagen.
Diese DVD-Ripper, da gab es schon diesen Virtual-Dub. Da konnte man auch schon seine Inputs und Outputs und so alle so durch die Gegend ziehen, wie man es so haben wollte. Und dann, wenn man noch einen Filter hatte, hat man den da reingesetzt und in den Filter reiht, aus dem Filter wieder raus. Und so ein bisschen wie Quarz. Composer. Genau, sowas. Nur halt für Audio- und Videogeschichte.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt nochmal die Verknüpfung von Kanälen und Audio-Flow. Ich rede ja erstmal gar nicht von Audio-Flow, sondern ich rede einfach nur davon, dass wenn Skype, in Skype kann ich ja zum Beispiel, in Skype kann man ja ein Audiodevice auswählen. Skype kann das ja zumindest.
Sogar Skype kann das.
Du weißt ja, wenn du jetzt mit Alt oben reinklickst, dass du dann auch dein Device jetzt auswählen kannst, ne?
Das ging schon vorher. Ja, aber bei Skype kann ich auswählen, womit ich Audio rein und raus haben will. Das ja auch ganz sinnvoll ist, weil du hast da so ein Bluetooth-Headset dran und das willst du nur für Skype benutzen und ansonsten benutze deine Lautsprecher, damit sie nicht mit Standard in, Standard out arbeiten. So, wenn ich aber jetzt ein Device habe mit mehr als zwei Kanälen, dann kann ich Skype nicht sagen, ich benutze auf diesem Device Kanal 7 und 8. Könnte ich jetzt aber in Mac OS X, zum Beispiel in diesem Audio-Midi-Setup, ein virtuelles Device anlegen und sagen, nur Kanal 7 und 8 von diesem einen Device sollen da drin sein, dann würde es ja völlig ausreichen. Es wäre nur, dass Kanal 7 und 8 in diesem virtuellen Device Kanal 0 und 1 ist, also der normale Stereo-Kanal. Rein wie raus. Und das heißt, während Skype denkt, er schreibt bei diesem Device auf das normale Stereo in-out, ist es tatsächlich Kanal 7 und 8 von einem anderen. Aber es kann nicht mehr egal sein, wie das Scheißteil heißt, es kann nicht mehr egal sein, dass es da theoretisch auch noch andere Kanäle gibt. Ich hätte halt einfach nur gerne nur das. Diese Möglichkeit gibt es einfach nicht. Und deswegen gibt es auch generell keine Möglichkeit, einem Programm, was mir nicht die Möglichkeit bietet, Kanal auszuwählen oder überhaupt Audio-Device auszuwählen, irgendwo hinzuschicken, wo es hin soll.
Also auch nicht Wiretap oder Audio Hijack Pro oder was auch immer, diese ganzen komischen Audio-Juggler.
Auf einen Hack bin ich jetzt hingewiesen worden. Das ist der, den ich jetzt auch hier derzeit zum Beispiel benutze. iTunes ist ja auch so ein Problem. Bei iTunes kannst du auch kein Audio-Device angeben. iTunes kann nur das Standard-Audio-Device oder halt sein Airplay-Kram benutzen.
Ja, sonst könnte man ja auch digital Musik abgreifen, die man schon selber besitzt.
Nein, das ist totaler Blödsinn, weil ich kann natürlich alles als Default-Device einstellen, aber iTunes nimmt halt nur das Default-Device und ich kann nicht sagen, iTunes spielt da und alles andere spielt da. Was ist, wenn ich jetzt mit iTunes Radio hören will und es soll halt nur auf irgendeinen externen Lautsprecher oder auf irgendeinen Kopfhörer gehen, aber auf was anderes nicht? Das ist nicht vorgesehen. Verstehe ich auch überhaupt nicht. Um das jetzt zum Beispiel, ich möchte zum Beispiel hier im Vorfeld der Sendung spiele ich also einen Stream ab. Da läuft immer diese Musik. Das ist mein News-Case. Jetzt möchte ich gerne, dass der hier bei meinem Mischpult aufschlägt. Und damit ich das überhaupt machen kann, habe ich mir schon ein extra USB-Audio-Interface daran gemacht, damit ich das überhaupt separat auswählen kann. Damit ich also nicht diese Problematik mit Kanal 7, 8 usw. habe. Das hat halt nur zwei. Und da kann iTunes dann drauf schreiben. Wenn ich aber dann während dieser ganzen Stream läuft, auf diesem Computer noch andere Sachen vorhören möchte, dann möchte ich vielleicht mein Default-Device aber auf was anderes eingestellt haben. Das heißt, ich hätte gerne iTunes soll dahin spielen, aber mein Default-Device soll woanders hin zeigen. Einziger Hack, den ich gefunden habe, ist mit Audio Hijack Pro, so ein völlig krudes Setup, wo du dann Filter einstellst und einer dieser Filter, der dabei ist, heißt dann Auxiliary Device. Wer ist das Tool? Audio Hijack Pro.
Ach so, na doch.
Und das hat halt so Effect-Settings und einer dieser Effects, darauf hat mich einer hingewiesen auf Twitter, ich weiß nicht mehr wer, aber vielen Dank, was tatsächlich so eine Kopie auf ein anderes Audio-Device machen kann. Und dann mutee ich das eigentliche Ding, das heißt mit Audio Hijack Pro hijacke ich iTunes, mutee es und in den Effekten erstelle ich aber von dem Sound noch eine Kopie, sodass es dann eben auf einem anderen Device rauskommt. Ja, holy shit, wo lebe ich? Also das bedrückt mich. Das macht mich wirklich fertig.
Das hilft nur der Affe.
Ja, da reden wir von diesen ganzen Advanced-OS und so weiter und du kannst auch nicht mal so ein Scheiß-Audio-Routing machen. Das wird dich zum Kotzen.
Ja, nee, also ich sehe schon auf jeden Fall einen, das ist so die Möglichkeit, mal Devices zumindest auszuwählen und so. Das wäre schon mal nicht schlecht, ob es jetzt wirklich für... Nee, okay, wenn man das hat, hat man den Rest auch.
Also wenn jemand in der Lage wäre, jetzt kommen wir wieder zu Development Opportunities, ein Tool zu schreiben, wo ich sage, leg mal ein neues Audio-Interface an.
Ich kann mich da nicht konzentrieren. Also ich muss dazu sagen, Tim hat hier so einen Beamer und der prangt jetzt hier die ganze Zeit. Mach den Affen weg!
Also angenommen, jemand würde ein Tool schreiben. Ich weiß nicht, wie kompliziert das ist, und ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob es überhaupt geht. Ich hab mal mit Martin gesprochen und er meinte, schwierig heißt ja nicht unmöglich. Und dass es generell irgendwie schon geht, zeigt ja dieses Audio-Haijack Pro. Die Frage ist, ob man dieses Hailjacking irgendwie braucht oder ob es nicht doch irgendwie einen Weg gibt, das zu machen. Also ein Tool, was einfach sagt, ich lege hier ein Virtual-Audio-Device an und alles, was da drauf geschrieben wird, schiebe ich auf ein anderes, auf einen zu konfigurierenden Kanal.
Ich würde mir auf jeden Fall unter Core-Audio dann genau so eine Funktionalität vorstellen. Kann man das nicht mit, wie heißt der Quartz-Composer, da kann man doch auch so Audio-Stöpseln, oder? Ich dachte, aber weiß nicht genau. Gibt es ihn überhaupt noch? Sagst du so, hast du ihn schon gestartet? Oh, es gibt den Quartz-Composer-Visualizer und den Quartz-Composer, na dann gucken wir doch mal. Gibt es hier nicht irgendwas mit, es gibt Music-Visualizer?
Das sind halt schon neue Dinge, oder?
Ja, aber es ist schon immer sehr visuell natürlich. So, Audio-Inputs, ach Gott, ne, das ist jetzt auch wieder ein, naja.
Ja, aber dieses Routing...
Aber so wär's ja eigentlich auch noch mal ganz, so ein Audio-Router, so wie Graf...
Ja, da stellen sich immer gleich... Ich brauch das auf System-Ebene, und das muss vor allem so latenzfrei wie irgendwie möglich sein. Deswegen wär's halt optimal, eigentlich wenn das im OS ist, weil es ist ja eigentlich nur ein Mapping von einem anderen Namen auf eine andere Kanal-Nummer, sonst ist es gar nichts, sonst ändert sich nichts. Es ist so einfach, das sprengt mir das Hirn, dass das überhaupt nicht drin ist. Jetzt kommt der Chat wieder mit Vorschlägen, hier Soundflower, nein, Soundflower macht das alles nicht. Soundflower macht was ganz anderes. Soundflower greift, da schreibt man was rein und man kann mit einem anderen Programm auf der anderen Seite das auslesen. Aber ich kann nicht konfigurieren, geh auf dieses andere existierende Audiodevice und schreibe da auf Kanal sowieso. Es sei denn, ich hätte ein Programm, was das tut. Aber das ist dann auch die Frage, wie das dann eben mit Clock-Deviation funktioniert etc.
Vielleicht geht das halt einfach gar nicht, weil da müsst ihr auch dann zwischen Formatenevente umrechnen, 48 Kilohertz und 44 und noch live und tralala und bei Audios ist mit der Latenz immer so eine Sache.
Bei Audios ist das mit der Latenz immer so eine Sache. Ja, das bringt mich auch gleich noch zu einem anderen Thema. Entschuldigung, dann ist das Audiothema aber auch durch. Das ist jetzt auch weniger ein Thema als ein Hilfegesuch meinerseits, weil ich hier eigentlich davon träume, auf Logic Pro umzusteigen. Und ich glaube zwar, dass es keine Lösung gibt, aber vielleicht gibt es eine Lösung. Also falls irgendjemand von euch ein Logic Pro Wiz ist und damit viel arbeitet und irgendeine Ahnung hat oder irgendeinen Weg kennt, wie man diese Marker exportiert bekommt, sodass man da irgendwie im Idealfall einen Textfall hat mit Zeit-Einheiten. Ey, ich würde euch flattern, bis der Arzt kommt. Also ich habe keinen Weg gefunden und es sieht auch schwer danach aus, dass es keinen gibt, aber vielleicht habe ich ja irgendwas Dramatisches übersehen. Logic Pro 9. Und es gibt da ein großartiges Marker-Feature, was diese ganze Kapitelmarken-Problematik, die wir hier haben, hervorragend automatisieren könnte. Wenn dich eine Menge drin ist, du kannst das mit OSC automatisieren, mit MIDI automatisieren, alles, du kriegst es bloß nicht exportiert. Und diese Apple-Tools sind ja auch nicht in der Lage, ihre eigenen Standards zu unterstützen. Also mit Kompressor zum Beispiel. Ich hab festgestellt, kann man tatsächlich auch Kapitelmarken schreiben. Mit Bildern und Links und all das, was man haben will. Gesehen davon, dass das User-Interface zum Reihern ist. Aber warum kann ausgerechnet das Kompressortool, also das Tool von Apple, was man für 40 Euro kauft, damit es einem Formate konvertiert, warum ist es nicht in der Lage, HE-AAC zu erzeugen? Also warum kann ausgerechnet das Apple-Tool nicht das im Betriebssystem vorliegende HE-AAC, was sogar iTunes erzeugen kann? Warum geht das nicht? Ich verstehe es nicht. Aber Logic Pro. Also wenn irgendjemand eine Methode kennt, Marker in Logic Pro zu exportieren, ich liebe euch. Das war es jetzt mit dem Thema Audio von mir.
Das war ja auch schon mal nicht schlecht.
Danke.
Das war doch mal ein fundierter Vortrag zu einem Verbesserungs...
Ich habe mir Software gekauft. Ich habe neulich über Flink hier erzählt, über diese Mitfahrgelegenheitsnummer. Oder war das bei Nortel Vorwerk?
Hier war das nicht.
Genau, erzähle ich jetzt hier auch noch mal davon. Damals war das nämlich noch Beta, jetzt ist das auch live. Das ist so eine, wie nennen die sich, Mitfahrzentrale für den Alltag, die in Real-Time funktioniert.
Aber war das nicht so, das Flinkster war dieses Carsharing?
Flinkster ist das Carsharing von der Bahn.
Genau, der Holgi hatte da schon mal was verlinkt, kann es sein. Der hat das getwittert oder so. Oder du ihn retweetet.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr.
Irgendwas habe ich da auf jeden Fall mit live schon mal, entweder hast du es schon mal erzählt oder irgendwo hatten wir es schon mal.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall mal mit den Jungs ein bisschen gesprochen. was ich noch nicht wusste ist, wie Realtime das Ganze ist. Also es ist quasi so eine Art mini-social-Network. Du trickst dich da ein mit Foto und so weiter, weil es geht ja hier um Mitfahrvermittlung. Also sozusagen um Leute, die dann in deinem Auto sitzen, während du irgendwo hinfährst. Da will man ja schon so ein gewisses Vertrauen aufgebaut bekommen. Und du kannst halt, wenn du eine Fahrt machst, die da anwählen. Und wenn jemand anderes eine Fahrt braucht, die in deinen Reiseplan passt, dann wird ihm das halt vorgeschlagen und du wirst an ihn vermittelt und du kannst vorher sagen, wie viel Geld du dafür haben willst und so weiter. Also gibst du Kilometerpreise an und so weiter und dann wird das alles auch automatisch ausgerechnet. So weit, so gut, so weit auch, sagen wir mal, nicht anders als andere Mitfahrtzentralen. Was mir bloß nicht bekannt war, ist, wie Realtime das ist. Das Ganze geht sozusagen auch noch während der Fahrt und das Ganze ist in diese Navigon-Software eingebaut. Das heißt, wenn du auf deinem iPhone diese Navigon-Software hast und du hast das Schling gleichzeitig installiert, dann erkennt er, dass das installiert ist. Und wenn du in Navigon sagst, ich fahre jetzt nach Hamburg und du fährst los, dann kannst du das so konfigurieren, dass du live dem Flink sagst, wo du gerade bist. Und wenn während du fährst, irgendjemand auf Flink sagt, ich müsste aber jetzt mal hier von, was ist da auf der Strecke?
Penneberg, was weiß ich irgendwas.
Keine Ahnung, ich müsste von Schwerin nach Hamburg. Und du bist dann noch irgendwie auf der Autobahn.
Und dann siehst du, der bietet 50 Euro, wenn ich ihn jetzt mitkomme.
Dann kommt das in deinem Navigon hoch. In deiner Navigation-Software sagt er, hier, da würde jemand irgendwie von Schwerin mitgenommen werden. Der Umweg wäre für dich so und so viel. Zeit und so und so viele Kilometer. Willst du den trotzdem mitnehmen? Weil du würdest auch so und so viel Geld dafür bekommen. Außer Schwerin, kein Problem, ich hab eh Zeit. Sagst du ja. Dann wird das live dem dann auch zurückvermittelt. Und dann kriegst du die Information, wo du hin musst. Beziehungsweise kriegst du es direkt in dein Navigon. Das heißt dein Navigon nimmt das gleich als Zwischenziel mit auf. Und du wirst dann sofort dahin, wo du ihn abholen musst, hingeleitet. Pfiffisch, fand ich auch.
Und vor allem live.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie gut es funktioniert. Ich hab halt so eine Demo gesehen, die hat funktioniert.
Sind die Aktien der Bahn schon gesunken?
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaub ja nicht, dass es der Bahn groß schadet, diese ganzen intelligenten Reisevermittlungen. Ich glaub eher, dass es diesen Markt des Reisens einfach vergrößert. Die zicken zwar rum, die haben sich da auch mit diesen Busunternehmen, die da so dünne Vermittlung machen, da gekalt, aber ich glaub, das war auch sehendos. Stattdessen sollen sie lieber nachdenken, selber sowas anzubieten. Ich mein, sie sind ja jetzt mit dem Carsharing und mit dem Fahrrad und so weiter eigentlich auch in dem selben Business. Also lieber nur bessere Angebiete machen. Na ja, also kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal angucken. Gibt es auch gerade brandneue Versionen auf iPhone und so. Und das erscheint mir irgendwie alles ganz sinnvoll zu sein. Mal gucken. Ja?
Hab ich mir irgendwelche Software gekauft in der Zwischenzeit eigentlich?
Na, ich dachte ja, ich musste irgendwie hier den Xcode updaten. Und weil da hatte ich ja mal vier Euro bezahlt, weil ich noch keinen Lust hatte auf Developer-Account. Aber den gibt es jetzt wieder für free, den Xcode.
Zumindest für leihen, ja.
Ja, was nur jetzt irgendwie nicht ging. Ich konnte mir die Core-Doku für 10.7, die will er irgendwie bei mir nicht runterladen. Das weiß ich auch noch nicht, woran das liegt.
Core-Doku?
Ja, der lädt doch die Doku mal noch nachträglich runter. Und das macht er, für 10.6 hat das gemacht, für 10.7, da beschwert er sich, man meinte, ich hätte irgendwie nicht die richtigen Rechte.
Dann hab ich mal ein Programm gesucht, weil ich so frustriert war und ich keinen Bock mehr habe, Adobe Software zu installieren und irgendwie mir Illustrator zu kaufen, nur um alle Nase lang mal ein PDF zu öffnen. Hab ich mal geforscht, ob es irgendwie ein Tool gibt, was halbwegs brauchbar in der Lage ist, PDFs zu öffnen, sodass ich sie danach bearbeiten kann. Und da ist mir ein kleines Tool ins Auge gefallen, das heißt Vector Designer, gibt's im Upstore. Und das kann das. Und es kostet gar nicht so viel. Es ist jetzt auch nicht vollkommen flawless, aber es hat zumindest eine ordentliche Mac OS X Appearance. Ach so, wenn man es gekauft hat, dann darf man noch nicht mal sehen, was es kosten würde.
Ja, das ist auch...
Ach doch, hier 24 Euro. Und es ist für so ein kleiner Up irgendwie nett und bietet also ordentliche Vektor-Bearbeitung. Das, was man so standardmäßig erwarten würde, das ist so drin. Da kann man auf jeden Fall schöne kleine Logospiele reinmachen und vielleicht auch vollwertige Ergebnisse erzielen. Gefühlt mir so auf den ersten Blick ganz gut. Da tut sich so ein bisschen was. Alle sind noch nicht so der große Illustrator-Konkurrent, aber auf jeden Fall ist das ordentliche Software.
Ich will mein Freehand wieder haben.
Ich auch.
One Fine Day.
Haben wir eigentlich mal über diese Mobile-Max-Statistiken geredet?
Ja, da gab es schon wieder neue.
Das weiß ich nicht. Stehen sehe ich jetzt gerade. Das ist hier noch vom 28.
Juni.
Ich glaube, es gab nichts Neues hier auch.
Das waren nur die Vorhersagen. Nee, Sendungslänge stimmt.
Nee, das war danach. Also der selbe Mensch, der diese WWDC-Predictions-Kram ausgewertet hat. Oder? Nee, das war nicht der selbe.
Doch, ich dachte.
Nee, das war glaube ich nochmal ein anderer. Nee, das war der selbe. Okay, alles klar. Kugelblitz heißt das Block. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Mann hieß. So, und dann gibt es dann hier schöne Statistiken. Der durchschnittlichen Sendungslänge von Mobile Max mit logarithmischer Trendline. Genau, also wer schon immer mal interessiert hat, wie lang Sendungen in zehn Folgen sind, hier lässt sich das wahrscheinlich heute schon ablesen. Unglaublich. Guck mal, hier gibt es die Zeitrechnung Before-Huckel und Since-Huckel. Die Sendungslänge hat aktiv zugenommen.
Da möchte ja auch sein, ne?
Liegt das an dir?
Sicher, sicher. Also, mehr, mehr...
Ich verlink das mal, dann könnt ihr da mal klicken. Verlink das mal, ich hab... Dann hab ich das endlich mal raus aus meiner Liste.
Ich hab keine neue Software seit dem letzten Mal, das kam's doch gar nicht. Ist ja unglaublich, außer allein...
Ich hab mir auch dieses Navigon dann übrigens gekauft.
Ja, und das hab ich mir schon gedacht.
Das taugt, durchaus.
Das kann man echt gebrauchen.
Ach so, nee, du hast ja mit LINE noch nicht viel rumgemacht. Hätte mich ja noch interessiert, wie denn so dir das Quicktime jetzt ohne Quicktime 7... Du hast ja letztes Mal gesagt, dass ohne Quicktime 7 geht ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich hab ja noch Quicktime 7.
Hat er dir doch noch...
Zumindest bei meinem Upgrade hat er es jetzt nicht weggeschmissen.
Und es läuft auch noch.
Macht den Eindruck. Also funktioniert genauso scheiße wie vorher. Sagen wir's mal so. Also was heißt scheiße? Ich mein, es ist überhaupt noch in der Lage, wichtige Sachen zu konvertieren. Deswegen haben sie es jetzt nicht komplett rausgenommen. Aber was ich erstaunlich finde, ist, dass ich eigentlich... Bei Snow Leopard haben sie dieses Quicktime X gepriesen. Und es macht so den Eindruck, als ob unter Leinen sich genau nichts geändert hat.
Oder? Mal sehen, nichts Weltbewegendes. Brauchst du Strom? Nee.
So ein Dingskabel hier, so ein iPhone-Dingskabel. Ja, ich hab eins in meinem Rucksack. Redet einfach weiter, ich hab schon.
Nämlich bei armen Leuten. Wir hätten ja hier auch noch Kabel gehabt.
Was hätt man?
Hätt auch noch Kabel gehabt.
Na, ich hab auch Kabel. Na gut. Ich nehm lieber mein eigenes. Wer weiß, dass du da für Sniffer mit drin hast. So, ich hab euch unterbrochen, ihr wart gerade dabei, ich hab zugehört, also jetzt musst du weiter erzählen.
Ja, wir haben eigentlich nur festgestellt, dass sich nichts geändert hat bei QuickTime. Wobei, bei QuickTime muss ich halt auch sagen, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich mich da jetzt darüber freuen soll oder nicht. Also ob ich darüber traurig sein soll, dass sich nichts geändert hat oder ob ich mich nicht lieber freuen sollte darüber, dass sich nichts geändert hat.
Ehrlich gesagt, seitdem es M-Player Extended gibt und VLC und so, ich hab den irgendwie nie wieder gebraucht. Irgendwie hab ich's aufgegeben. Doch schön Hardware beschleunigt, mit QuickTime meine Movies zu gucken.
Du redest von QuickTime Player? Ja, ich red ja von QuickTime dem Subsystem. Ja, und was hat das mit VLC zu tun?
Na, ich brauch keinen QuickTime Player mehr. Ja, inzwischen. Also entweder VLC oder ein Player. Einer von beiden kann's dann immer.
Also das ist eigentlich auch echt schade, dass das mit diesem QuickTime immer wieder doch aufs neue mal wieder ein Schmerz ist und man doch immer dann wieder auf sowas zurückgreifen muss.
Was mich, also eigentlich hat sich ja was geändert, weil es gibt ja jetzt, ich blicke das halt noch nicht so ganz durch. Ich habe auch diese ganzen Developer-Videos von der Konferenz noch nicht durch. Hat sich das eigentlich von euch jemanden mal schon gegeben? So ein bisschen?
Ich hab meinem Kumpel, der auch hier Kabel in der Zeit, hab ich gesagt, klick mal alles. Und dann hat's irgendwie ordentlich stundenlang gesaugt. Ich glaube, das hat auch mal abgebrochen, er ist noch dabei. Aber der macht das alles für mich und dann krieg ich demnächst mal so ein 50 GB-Batzen und dann hab ich das alles.
Ja, ich hab mir ein paar Sachen schon mal angeschaut.
Ja, ich hab mir dieses ARK angeschaut. Dieses Retain Release. Also diese Garbage Collection-Ersatz. Was heißt ARK genau? Auto?
Magic Reference Counting.
Genau. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Also es hat ja Zaira Kursay ja auch nochmal geschrieben, dass sie das Garbage Collection weglassen, höchstwahrscheinlich, dass es ein bisschen in den Bach runtergeht. Jetzt schon, gibt's ja noch nicht so lange. Und weil auf dem iPhone gab's das ja auch nie. Und das sorgt halt dafür, dass man erstens nicht nur weniger Code schreiben muss. Und viele, die neu einsteigen, die mit Retail und Release auch nicht so klar kommen. Der Max meint es ja auch schon, das wäre er irgendwie, müsste er erstmal lernen. Und ist ja das irgendwie doch nicht so einfach. Ich hab's irgendwie schon eigentlich ganz gut drin. Deswegen, mich stört's eigentlich nicht. Aber der Vorteil von diesem ARK ist, dass sie dadurch auch, der Compiler kann halt bestimmte Sachen gleich wegoptimieren. Also in manchen Fällen muss man einen Retail machen, aber gleichzeitig wieder so ein Autorelease, wenn man jemand anderem ein Objekt geben will, um das man sich aber selber nicht mehr kümmern möchte. Da muss man immer so Retail und Autorelease machen, was ja eigentlich so ein bisschen Counter, also du erhöhst den Zähler, um ihn dann auch im Autorelease-Pro wieder eins frei zu geben. Und das kann der Compiler jetzt alles gleich für dich automatisiert machen und dann auch noch ein Stück schneller. Das heißt, wenn die jetzt ihre dicken Programme irgendwie mit diesem ARC irgendwie compilen, dann könnte noch schon nochmal einen kleinen Speed-Gewinn geben.
Speed-Gewinn?
Ja, meinte der Sirak Usar.
Weil sie es halt mehr so native implementieren und weil der Compiler halt, wenn du mehrere hast, die logisch eigentlich zwar schon so sinnvoll sind, aber sich gegenseitig aufheben, weil es geht halt nun mal nicht anders, dann macht der Compiler die halt gleich alle weg. Und dann sind sie gar nicht erst da. Und vor allem kann er sie halt gleich native und schneller machen. Und weil so, wenn du die hinschreibst, dann sind das ja auch Methoden oder Messages, die da gecallt werden. Und so kann der Compiler da gleich richtig irgendwie Low-Level-Code das bisschen optimaler machen.
Aber heißt das, dass man jetzt überhaupt gar keinen Speicher, also sich verhält wie Garbage Collection, weil es invisible ist, aber keine Garbage Collection ist?
Genau. Sondern es passiert genau in dem Augenblick, weil der Compiler das für dich beim Bauen genau gleich an die Stelle da reinsetzt. Weil er merkt, du brauchst es da nicht mehr.
Also er schreibt sozusagen hin, was du eigentlich schreiben müsstest, nur macht das besser und optimiert es im Zweifel sogar gleich weg.
Also du machst quasi über automatische Code-Analyse?
Nee, nicht ganz, weil die wäre zu langsam. Der macht es ein bisschen stricter. Aber schon so nach festen Regeln, weil es gibt ja schon so ein Regelwerk, nach dem man Release und Retain so benutzen sollte. Und nach genau dem Regelwerk macht das aber halt noch viel penetranter, als der Mensch das so machen würde. Sondern der hält sich genau daran. Das heißt, wenn man auch davon abweicht, dann musst du ihm auch irgendwie Tipps geben, wie er das hinzukriegen hat. Also er kann nicht alles. Also wenn es hier halt so eine Kreuzverweise gibt, genau das, was eine Garbage Collection her kann, die aber auch ein bisschen Zeit bräuchte, um es rauszufinden und so weiter. Auch wenn es vielleicht alles voll schnell geht natürlich. Aber wenn du da mehrere davon hast, dann dauert es halt auch Zeit. Und das kann das Arc halt nicht, weil das würde beim Kompilieren zu lange dauern. Da musst du ihm dann irgendwie so mit Weak Reference, oder ja mit wie war es? Weak Reference Counting, oder weiß ich nicht was, muss ihm jedenfalls so einen Tipp geben, dass er weiß, dass er den einen mal schwach auflöst, damit sich der andere dann löst und damit es dann überall durchklingelt.
Ja und der Syracusa meint ja auch noch, dass auf der einen Seite, also das ist ja das zweite große Ding, was er beklagt, dass Apple da immer noch mit diesem Objective Serum dingelt und jetzt nicht mal so den Schritt auf vielleicht doch noch eine modernere Sprache wagt. Aber auf der anderen Seite hat er auch gemeint, dass sie halt dadurch, dass sie keine Garbage Collection haben auf dem iPhone und so, wahrscheinlich auch dort eine ganze Ecke Batterie sparen oder zumindest mehr Performance aus ihren Apps rauskitzeln können.
Kommt denn dieses Automatik-Reference-Counting jetzt auch in iOS?
So war es, wie ich es verstanden habe. Weil was ich zuerst gehört habe, ist, dass es jetzt mit iOS 5 kommen soll und wenn es dann damit kommt, dass aber auch man seine Apps, die man für iOS 5 baut, dass man die auch genauso für iOS 4 bauen kann und dass es dort auch funktioniert. Weil es ja eine Compiler-Geschichte ist. Das heißt, die Lips, die man benutzt, die müssen dieses Arc gar nicht haben. Sondern es ist ja der Compiler, setzt für dich ja, wenn du vorher Retain hingeschrieben hast und das jetzt nicht mehr machst, dann macht der Compiler ja für dich das Retain. Das heißt der Code, das wird ja trotzdem Retained oder Released. Also das Code-mäßig sieht das alles genauso aus wie vorher. Vielleicht ein bisschen optimierter, aber es sieht genauso aus. Und deswegen geht es halt auch für das Alte.
Ok, aber die Programme müssen halt neu gebaut werden.
Du kannst alle Retains und Releases einfach alle rausschmeißen, einfach mal so komplett. So wie du das bei der Garbage Collection wahrscheinlich auch gemacht hast. Und wenn du nicht irgendeinen komischen Voodoo machst und dann ist ja eh immer schon so ein Zeichen dafür, dass irgendwo was nicht ganz so optimal ist, dann baust du neu, schmeißt die alle raus und dann ist es gut.
Und dieses Argument so, da wo sonst die JVM und so fleißig Garbage collectet und irgendwie noch ziemlich viel nebenher tun muss, um da alles so clean zu halten, das musst du dann mit deinem schön hart kompilierten C, das kann dann einfach so vor sich hinlaufen und wird nicht von irgendeinem Garbage-Collector unterbrochen und verbraucht nicht mehr Strom oder bremst die Performance und so.
Und du hast auch nicht ja diesen Treppeneffekt, dass irgendwie der Speicherverbrauch so ansteigt und dann nach weiss nicht wie viele Sekunden legt die Garbage-Collection zu und dann sinkt der wieder so sägezahnmäßig, dass es immer so steigt und zack, sondern dann so schön gleichmäßig passiert.
Wobei es da ja auch dann die inkrementellen und degenerativen Garbage-Collektoren und so weiter gibt, die alle so ein bisschen das piffige machen, aber es kostet halt auf jeden Fall Performance.
LLVM, das ist wirklich die geile Sau. Da hat sich Apple echt was eingekauft. Ich würde sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich echt einer der goldensten Projekte, die sie je aufgenommen haben in ihrer Firma.
Na, hat denen schon einiges gebracht wahrscheinlich.
Ja, und also nicht nur Performance, so Compiler wird schneller, Compiling wird schneller, aber auch eben... Code wird schneller, Code wird einfacher.
Das ist schon cool, wenn man im Xcode jetzt schreibt irgendeine Zeile hin, die es gleich natürlich sofort droht, weil du noch das Include oben nicht hingeschrieben hast, weil du die falsche Reihenfolge programmiert hast. Dann schreibst du dann ein Include hin, und unten geht gleich das rote Kringelchen weg. Dann merkt man, das Include ist jetzt da, also stimmt der Code jetzt auch. Das ist schon cool.
So Realtime, Syntax-Checking, Syntax-Compiler-Checking. Das ist vor allem nicht ein separater Code in Xcode, sondern es handelt sich um denselben Code, den der Compiler auch verwendet. Weil du ihn jetzt mit BSD-Lizenz auch da einbauen konntest, was halt vorher mit dem ganzen GNU-GPL-Kram nie ging. Konntest du halt in kommerzielle Produkte nicht einbauen.
Schon krass.
Ja, ja.
So, ich guck mal.
Auf den Multi-Zettel.
Wollen wir noch über Google Plus reden?
Ist nicht ganz so schlimm. Und das ist ja natürlich die Nachricht für uns Mac-Freunde, hat ja der Andy Herzfeld da ja sein Designerhändchen scheinbar kreisen lassen. Ja, mit diesen Wortspielen bin ich besonders gut.
Der Andy Herzfeld, wenn du den mehr wissen willst, dann muss man wie bei Folklore dort kommen, mal klicken, so hießen die doch, OK.
Auf jeden Fall muss man, also wenn man was zu Google Plus sagen kann, dann ist es zumindest mal so das erste Mal, dass so ein Google Web App mir ästhetisch gefällt. Also nicht dieses Babyblau und nicht überall dieser, weißt schon, dieses Gebimsel, dieses Intertaste-Gebimsel. Die haben das schon echt aufgeräumt, das ist schon sehr, sehr clean und slick eigentlich.
Ja, das stimmt. Also sie haben wirklich ihre Optik signifikant verbessert. Across the line. Und ich finde auch, also ich habe noch nicht so viel mit Plus gearbeitet, dass ich jetzt wirklich da schon zu einem abschließenden Meinung gekommen wäre. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein verdammt kluger Schachzug von ihnen, weil sie eigentlich Plus ist für sie, ist gar nicht mal so, also am Anfang habe ich echt gerätselt, was es mit diesem Plus 1 so auf sich haben soll. Und dann kam das raus und Google Plus, da habe ich mir so, ist hier nichts besseres eingefallen oder was? Aber dann habe ich es irgendwie verstanden. Google Plus ist halt gar nicht so sehr ein eigener Dienst, sondern es ist ein weiteres kleines Bauteil, was ihnen aber die Möglichkeit gibt, alle ihre Dienste zu vereinheitlichen und unter einen Dach und unter einen schwarzen Balken zu stellen. Und das macht an der Stelle wirklich verdammt viel Sinn. Egal welchen Google Dienst du benutzt, du hast immer deine Update-Count da oben und du wirst immer wieder darauf hingewiesen. Also die Einbindung des Users, des Nutzers von Google, die ist halt enorm angestiegen dadurch. Und das Plus an der Stelle ist eben auch noch so dieses bloggen können ohne Blog ist halt jetzt auch gleich mit dabei. Du schreibst das halt einfach irgendwo da rein und du kannst es eben öffentlich oder teilöffentlich veröffentlichen. Soweit ist das irgendwie alles ganz findig. Und dann ist es ja gleich so als Facebook-Konkurrent hingestellt worden. Der Vergleich drängt sich natürlich auf, weil das ganze Design dieser Timeline so ähnlich ist. Und weil es ja auch so eine Art Freunde-Ding gibt durch dieses Circus. Aber es ist ja eigentlich was ganz anderes. Es ist ja eigentlich eher wie Twitter, dass es auf einem Follower-Modell basiert. Du folgst anderen, die dir aber nicht zwangsläufig folgen müssen. Es gibt zwar mit dieser Inbox oder Incoming schon die Möglichkeit, Leute, die dir folgen, da kannst du auch reinschauen, wenn du wissen willst, was die Leute sagen, die dir folgen, aber denen du nicht folgst. Das ist auch ganz interessant. Sowas gibt es nicht bei Twitter. Ich kann nicht eine Timeline aufmachen, die aus Tweets besteht von Leuten, die mir folgen, aber von denen ich gar nicht, denen ich nicht folge. Das ist sehr interessant, um Leute zu entdecken, um da mal so reinzuschnuppern und zu gucken, was ist denn da so, und dann wieder neue Verbindungen zu finden. Aber, wo ich überhaupt nicht überzeugt bin, das sind diese Circles. Das ist so ein Nerd-Ding. Das ist so genauso wie bei Diaspora mit diesen komischen Aspekten. Und das ist so eine obskure Privacy-Simulation, die eigentlich Quatsch ist, weil...
Versteht doch keiner. Die meisten schmeißen alle in einen Circle und dann ist gut.
Genau. Du kriegst das nicht gemanagt. Ich meine, du wirfst am Anfang irgendwelche Leute rein, aber dann weißt du nicht mehr, wer war jetzt in welchem Circle, wer ist noch nicht in welchem Circle. Du hast gesagt, gut, das könnte man theoretisch jetzt alles noch nachrüsten mit großen Matrix-Vergleichtabellen oder für jeden User, wo er noch nicht drin ist und so. Aber ich glaube, dass das einfach... Das kriegt man nicht skaliert. Das selbe Problem hab ich schon so mit Einladungen verschicken und Adressbuchgruppen und so was. Irgendwann verlierst du diese Gabe, rauszufinden, wer noch in irgendeiner anderen existierenden Gruppe auch noch rein sollte. Also so eine Methodik, die dir dabei hilft, das zu machen. Und wenn man das dann mit Twitter vergleicht wiederum, dass es hier irgendwas privat wäre, ist ja eh Quatsch. Es ist öffentlich und ich will ja was öffentlich kommunizieren. Und diese Circles geben mir im Prinzip die Möglichkeit, dass ich sage, okay, das ist jetzt aber keine Ahnung, jetzt quatsche ich über, jetzt mache ich hier so Apple-Nerd-Talk. Und das möchte ich gar nicht, dass das jetzt nicht jeder liest. Aber gar nicht so sehr, um es zu verhindern, dass es irgendjemand sieht, so im Sinne von Datenschutz oder Privacy oder wie man das auch immer nennen möchte. Sondern es ist eher, ich würde es gerne vielen Leuten ersparen, um mich nicht auf den Sack zu gehen.
Ja, wie zum Beispiel hier Maha, wenn er immer über seine Bahnen twittert oder so.
Genau, wobei Maha hat es eigentlich gelöst mit Maha im Zug, dass er noch so einen zweiten Twitter-Hound hat.
Wem haben wir das zu verdanken?
Ja gut, aber er hat genau das...
Du, mir war fast wieder ein bisschen leid, weil eigentlich müsste ich das tausenden Leuten sagen und das kannst du ja auch nicht machen, das alle Leute nur, weil ich da keinen Bock drauf hab, tausende Persönlichkeiten anlegen, weil das bringt es ja irgendwie auch nicht.
Pavel müsste so einen Piraten... Ne, wohl hat er sich auch gerade schon sehr gemaßt.
Ja, und es müsste Maha dann eigentlich auch machen.
Genau, es müsste auch den Piratenpartei Maha geben und so.
Ja, aber was bleibt dann von Maha übrig?
Genau, wir kommen jetzt auch auf den Punkt. Ich hab diesen Gedanken eigentlich schon von Anfang an gehabt, dann ist mir allerdings jetzt MS-Pro zuvor gekommen, der einen sehr großartigen Blogpost...
Ich finde diesen Nick nicht gut.
Welchen Nick?
MS-Pro.
Findest du nicht gut?
Nee, das klingt irgendwie wie so ein Microsoft-Produkt.
Ja, der Vergleich drängt sich auf, ja. Kann ich aber nicht ändern.
Das ist doch kein Nick. Wer heißt denn der richtig?
Der heißt MS-Pro.
Nee, wie heißt denn der richtig? Komm, sag mal. Raus mit dem Klarnamen. Der ist doch bestimmt auf Facebook, oder? Also ich bin dafür, ihn beim Klarnamen zu nennen, bis er es eingesehen hat und sich einen ordentlichen Nick besorgt hat.
Michael Seemann heißt er und der macht ja auch seinem Klarnamen auch kein großes Geheimnis, auch wenn er generell...
Michael Seemann-Pro, ja.
Ist ja nun auch wirklich völlig egal. Auf jeden Fall hat er diesen Punkt gebracht, den ich auch finde. Ich schaue gerade nochmal nach...
Findest du den nicht, wa?
Was war denn das in seinem... Der schreibt immer so viel. War das überhaupt hier? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo er das gebloggt hat. Schreibt er so viel? Ich weiß es gerade nicht mehr, wo er es... Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall... Eigentlich muss man es umdrehen. Stell dir mal vor, es gäbe bei Twitter die Möglichkeit mit einem Tweet zu sagen, in welcher Kategorie man jetzt twittert. Ich will gar nicht all die Leute einsammeln in irgendeine Gruppe rein tun, um sie da dann zu bespaßen, weil ich meine, dass das das ist, was sie interessiert.
Aber wo haben Sie denn die Texte erfunden?
Ja, aber Texte sind nichts, was auf mich bezogen ist. Texte sind etwas, was auf alles bezogen ist. So was wie eine Konferenz oder so. Aber ich würde einfach eher sagen, angenommen, ich könnte meinem Twitter-Profil sagen, ich rede entweder über, was auch immer, Züge. über Apple, über Podcasting, über Discordianismus, oder über perverse Scheiße. So, ja. Und wenn ich jetzt tweete, könnte ich irgendeines von diesen Labeln oder auch mehrere auswählen und sagen, dieser Tweet ist jetzt perverse Scheiße. Und den Tweet kriegen halt nur die Leute in die Timeline, die mir entweder ist mir egal, worüber du schreibst, ich lese alles, oder mich interessiert jetzt nur die perverse Scheiße. Weil es gibt Leute, bei denen interessieren mich bestimmte Aspekte, aber andere Aspekte interessieren mich gar nicht. Also zum Beispiel bei der Gruber, Daryl Fireboy, würde der sowas haben, der hätte halt zwei Kategorien, das eine ist Apple, das andere ist Baseball. Baseball interessiert mich nicht.
Aber er hat doch zwei.
Zwei was?
ID's bei Twitter. Das heißt, einmal Daryl Fireboy und einmal hat er sich selbst als Gruber. Und als Gruber habe ich ihn einfach nicht genommen.
Ja gut, er ist jetzt nicht so der Twitterer, der nutzt glaube ich Twitter mehr, also nicht so sehr als öffentlicher Kanal. Da ging es mir jetzt nur ums Thema. Aber wie auch immer. Oder bei dir, Dennis, gibts ja auch... Verstehe, verstehe.
Ich versuche halt meine Mitmenschen zu schonen. ZFS oder Bitcoin.
Genau, das versuche ich auch. Aber Google Plus hilft mir nicht, meine Mitmenschen zu schonen. Ja, und es hilft mir auch nicht, die unterschiedlichen Aspekte von Leuten einzusammeln. Und von daher bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob Google Plus jetzt so kolossal irgendwas ablösen wird.
Der Mehrwert bietet sich momentan noch nicht aus.
Genau, weil gegenüber Twitter ist das schon wieder so viel Spam. Diese langen Texte kann man ja auch als Vorteil sehen. Kann man auch als Nachteil sehen. So eine Twitter-Timeline kriege ich irgendwie besser durchgeräuscht. Und diese iPhone-App, die sie da rausgebracht haben.
Also wie du ja auch heute Twittertest oder gestern, dass du eher ein Twitter-User immer noch bist, geht mir eigentlich auch genauso. Diese Facebook- und diese Social-Networks, ansonsten kann ich damit auch nur wirklich sehr eingeschränkt was anfangen. Und der Mehrwert, außer dass man halt mal gucken kann, mit der bin ich mal zur Schule gegangen. Ach, die sehen ja lustig aus heutzutage. So, solche Geschichten, die man da prima machen kann, so alte Schulfreunde stalken. Ansonsten mach ich da eigentlich auch nichts Sinnvolles.
Jetzt weiß ich, wie ich diesen Doc-Beintrag finde. Den suche ich einfach über Flatter. Von mir geflattert, weil die wirklich interessanten Sachen, die flatter ich. Jetzt gucke ich mal, wie er das genannt hat. Channels nennt er das.
Hätte ich auch schon auf dem Lippen, aber du hast mich nicht zu Wort kommen lassen. Aber übrigens, wenn du den Gruber nicht gelesen hast, dann würde dich vielleicht auch noch interessieren, dass du im Activity-Monitor ein neues Tab hinzufügen kannst.
Im Activity-Monitor ein Tab?
Da kannst du einen neuen Reiter klicken, nämlich erst oder zwei sogar. Du kannst Sudden Termination und Sandbox Reiter anklicken, dann siehst du, welche Apps Sudden Termination unterstützen.
Wie war das Reiter? Was für ein Reiter?
Na hier Activity-Monitor, oben die Spalten-Titel.
Wo man sieht, ob dein Programm 64-Bit ist oder nicht, oder wie viel CPUs gerade verbraucht.
Anklicken.
Ja, rechtsklick auf die Spalten-Titel. Und da kannst du dann sehen, wer zum Beispiel Sudden Termination und Sandbox schon unterstützt. Oder wer gesandboxt läuft. Das ist bei mir gar nicht so viel. Vor allen Dingen sehr viel OS X Zeug, logischerweise. Und sehr wenig, also eigentlich null andere Sachen momentan. Aber bei mir laufen auch keine Apps aus dem Store gerade. Also da geht auf jeden Fall noch einiges. Und Sudden Termination ist halt glaube ich das, wo dann das Mac OS sich entscheiden kann, halt mal abzukehlen.
Ja, das ist auch das, wo man sieht, dass iTunes jetzt tatsächlich als 64-Bit läuft, unter Lion. Nicht unter Snow Leopard. Was heißt denn das? Heißt das, dass das iTunes jetzt Coco ist?
Muss ja.
Muss ja, ne?
Das ist Carbon, haben die jetzt noch Carbon? Immer noch?
Nicht für 32, also nur für 32-Bit. Ihrer eigenen Aussage nach. Wieso merkt man dann nichts davon?
Weil es immer noch scheiße ist.
Wieso? Ach nee, iTunes ist...
Und Adium ist immer noch irgendwie 32-Bit, können die gar nichts? Also ich meine...
Kann man das nicht einfach 64-Bit bauen? Nee, die LePurple kann wahrscheinlich... Nee, das kann nicht sein.
Hallo? 2011?
Aber wenn wir mal in den Chat gehen und sagen, hier Irk, Freenode, Adium und dann...
Das war so Fefer-mäßig, erstmal den Kanal weglachen. Wir müssen schon in den Original-Fefer da rein checken.
Nein, wir können jetzt iChat benutzen, wir haben uns ja letztens von Tim und so erzählen lassen, dass iChat ja eigentlich auch kein schlechter Client ist.
Was? Ist da eigentlich was Neues passiert unter Lion? Und warum gibt es kein iMessage auf Lion? Was ist denn das für eine Scheiße?
Aber das hält uns ja nicht davon ab, nicht nochmal dreimal drüber zu sprechen. Haben wir eigentlich schon über Online-Backups gesprochen?
Ich könnte noch was zur Audio sagen.
Gibt es eigentlich eine neue Podcast-Software?
Achso, wo du gerade iChat sagst, da ist mir noch etwas aufgefallen. Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen... Moment, ich sag dir gleich, was mir aufgefallen ist.
Das ist jetzt übrigens die Brotkrumen-Sektion in Mobile Max.
Jetzt noch schnell alles reindrücken.
Es gibt jetzt ein neues Kontrollpanel oder es ist irgendeins, was vorher nur Mobile Mi war. Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau.
Dieses Privacy-Ding.
Nee, Mail, Contacts and Calendars. Nee, es ist nicht Mobile Mi, sondern es ist...
Alles.
Gab es das vorher schon? Warte mal, ich vergleiche mal hier kurz mit Schnee-Lehrer.
Jabber, jabber, jabber.
Nee, das ist neu. Und da sind jetzt alle Logins zusammengefasst. Unter anderem auch meine iChat-Logins. Also alle Accounts, quasi, and other apps. Ich frage mich, ob man jetzt auch als other app in der Lage ist, sein Account-Setting zu handeln.
Soll ja so sein. Das wäre natürlich dann auch sehr sinnvoll, wenn sie das auch als Mac-Appstore-Requirement machen, dass du, wenn du irgendwie Accounts im Internet machst, dass du die da auch eintragen musst.
Singles sein on für Apps, oder wie?
Nee, nur, dass man so seine ganzen Accounts und wo man so Accounts eingerichtet hat, nicht über 1000 Tools verteilt.
Aber gehören die nicht eigentlich in die Keychain rein oder so?
Die Passwörter gehören in die Keychain, aber die Einstellungen dazu, was da noch alles dazugehört, zu zentralisieren, ist schon ein interessanter Ansatz.
Wenn du ein Google-Mail-Account hier drin hast, kannst du sagen, der soll jetzt mit iCal verschrobelt sein. Dann kannst du auch sagen, ich will auch G-Talk mit iChat verknüpfen und Gmail mit Mail ab. Oder das halt auch wieder ausschalten.
Und Twitter-Support gibt es auf Lion auch nicht. Gibt es dann auch nur bei iOS 5, ja?
Ja, hab ich zumindest hier nichts gesehen.
Ist ja noch nicht so richtig verheiratet, alles.
Aber sie sind ja auch erst auf dem Weg zurück zur Mac.
Ja, sollte eigentlich, oder? Dass man nicht zum Beispiel immer Riesenprogramme installiert oder selbst baut, wenn man Developers, dass man nicht immer alles rüberschiebt, sondern nur noch irgendwie die Deltas. Ja, habe ich aber auch noch nicht gesehen.
Apropos Twitter, Tweetbot, ihr wisst schon, mein Twitter Client of Choice auf iOS hat jetzt auch Push-Notifications. Am Anfang hatten sie das ja nur für die ersten 1000, die kamen. Und dann twitterten sie irgendwie gestern, dass sie ja von Twitter irgendwie nochmal, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden, sie schrieben irgendwas von 100.000 lalala freigegeben bekommen haben, wie auch immer, irgendwelche Kapazitäten. Und ja, jetzt habe ich das auch. Jetzt habe ich die Twitter-App gelöscht auf meinem iPhone. Kann ich nur empfehlen, Tweetbot, immer wieder geil, ist einfach mal wirklich die Twitter-App of Choice und solange Google Plus nicht irgendwas ähnliches bekommt, ist das nicht zu benutzen. Also diese ganzen Web-Optiken auf dem iPhone, das ist es irgendwie nicht. Das will ich nicht. So, jetzt ist die Luft aber auch raus langsam.
Aber echt.
Wir haben die vier Stunden schon voll.
Wie viel haben wir denn durchgehalten überhaupt? Wir sehen nicht. Nach dem Reconnect gab es ja einen höheren Drop.
Das glaube ich sofort. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich bei Ladiocast bleiben sollte oder ob hier irgendwie das Alice merkt, dass ich das bald kündigen möchte. Also ein bisschen unklar.
Tja, also angeblich sind es noch so um die 200.
Wirklich.
Tapfer.
Tapfer. Aber uns hören ja auch manchmal nur noch ein paar Leute beim Schlafen. Ja, nee, es gibt ja auch Leute, die hören das ja auch gerne.
Komm, machen wir hier noch mal auf dem Soundboard den Donner oder dieses Flash-Jingle, dann wachen sie nochmal alle auf.
Waren wir jetzt hier vier Stunden zusammen?
Hab ich eigentlich noch ein letztes Lied hier irgendwie? Vier Stunden, ich hoffe nicht. Nee, nee, nee, doch, doch, doch. Haben wir wirklich angefangen? Nicht ganz nah, mal fast voll. Ist das wichtig?
MS-Pro ist in unserem Chat.
Wirklich?
Wie heißt der Matthias wie? Michael?
Michael Pro.
Michael Seemann.
Michael Pro, nennen wir ihn jetzt immer.
Michael Pro, damit kann ich mich auch empfohlen.
Was ist denn das?
Da, hier, so M, ach nee, MB Pro. Mist, hab ich mich voll verlesen.
Nee, glaub nicht, dass er sich hier für unseren Quatsch so interessiert.
Aber ich hab ja, ich hab ja, ich lerne jetzt auch Segeln, ne? Und hab ja dann natürlich standardsgemäß seinen Podcast zum Thema Segeln gehört. Und da hab ich ja auch erfahren, dass man dann auf einem Segelboot, wenn man dann so alleine über die Meere schippert, prima Podcast hören kann. Und da ist bestimmt so eine heitere Sendung, wie Mobile Max auch, genau das Richtige.
Bestimmt. Also für so eine Weltumseblung umseblungen müssen wir einiges nachliefern, ne?
Ja, aber so 4-Stunden-Sendungen, also ich meine, an einem Tag 6 Sendungen. Und dann musst du auch noch schlafen zwischendurch.
Kannst eine komplette Archive weghören.
Und dann kommst du da an und weißt voll Bescheid. Also, hast doch noch richtig was zu lernen.
Wenn du es dir alles gemerkt hast. Und wenn das alles richtig war, was so gesagt wurde, was ja auch mal mit uns passiert ist.
Du kannst ja nach 3 Tagen alle durchgehören, dann kannst du ja von vorne anfangen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt, welche Folge ist das? 1969?
Ja.
Oh, dein neues... Die Porno-Sendung eigentlich. Ja, steht wieder in Jubiläum an. Nächste Sendung.
75? 75 dann überhaupt.
Ich will Schokolade.
75 vielleicht.
Kriegt Mobile Max eigentlich irgendwelche Sendungspräsente immer noch?
Ja, zu Weihnachten aber nur. Und zu Ostern.
Grundsätzlich gab es das, es hat etwas abgenommen. Also es gab etwas... Es gab finanziellen Twitter-Pizza-Support.
Nee, das ist bestimmt so. Wahrscheinlich.
Ist jetzt Sommer, das schmeckt damit.
Weil wir uns nie bedanken, weil Tim das immer seiner Familie oder Holgi zum Fraß vorwirft und wir das gar nicht sehen und gar nicht dazu kommen, uns dafür zu bedanken, denken die Leute, ach die...
Ja, das letzte, was wir bekommen haben, war zu Weihnachten eine Schokolade, die wir uns hier zu viert geteilt haben.
Neulich kam halt diese ganze Kiste mit so unglaublich viel Schokolade. Dann hat das hier für so Dauerbeschmatzungen von mehreren Podcasts gesorgt. Dann ist auch irgendwie erstmal gut.
Letztens?
Letztens, das zieht sich ja auch alles schon ein bisschen. Wir haben jetzt schon wieder ein paar Sendungen weiter, das merkst du dir alles.
Also wir nehmen auch gerne 50 Euro Thunderbolt-Kabel oder so. Falls mal welche vom Laster fallen oder so, ihr wisst schon.
So als Battlespender. Tja, wir müssen uns jetzt glaube ich mal verabschieden.
Guck noch ein bisschen den Affen an.
Aber du bist ja echt auf den Affen gekommen. Oh man.
Es ist vorbei jetzt.
Siehst du mal, wenn du jetzt an meinem Audio-Network teilnehmen könntest, dann, oder du könntest sogar an meinem Audio-Network teilnehmen. Aber du könntest halt deinem Programm nicht sagen, dass es auf den YouTube-Kanal was schicken soll.
Ich benutze Audio-Hideaway.
Wirtuelle Devices, die man auch noch woanders irgendwie sozusagen mounten kann.
Eye-Audio.
Mit USB geht das ja auch inzwischen.
Wirtuelle Audio-Devices, die man woanders mounten kann.
Zeig jetzt doch mal den Affen.
Ja, dann guck mal dir so ein virtuelles Device erstellt. Und du kannst ja dann mir sagen, wo es rauskommen soll.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich hier eigentlich mach.
Und bei mir soll es sozusagen per Eingabe sein und es wird halt per Ethernet, Netz, wie auch immer, zu dir hin übertragen.
Ja, das macht ja hier mein Dante-Netzwerk genau das. Das könnte ich sogar einrichten, nur dass es halt dann immer irgendwie pro Rechner...
Wir wollen dann AirDrop-Audio haben.
Ne, einfach ein Audio-Kanal ohne drauf. Ding, bumms, das können wir machen. Ich brauch halt bloß, der virtuelle Treiber ist halt lizenzpflichtig.
Da fragt jemand, wie man per PayPal spenden kann.
Wie?
Na, das steht alles auf...
Also wir müssten unsere PayPal-Kunden ja eigentlich auch nochmal veröffentlichen auf der Seite dann, Dennis. Also unsere Flatter-Accounts...
Ich kann mal schnell meinen Litcoin reinschmeißen.
Litcoin, Twitter-Accounts flattern...
Haben wir auf der Mobile-Max-Seite, sind wir denn da auch nochmal einzeln verlinkt?
Ihr seid da mit euren Twitter-Accounts auf jeden Fall verlinkt?
Weil wir kriegen ja... Wir werden ja nicht reich von Mobile-Max, ne?
Ne, Rotim fährt hier abends nochmal mit seinem Ferrari rüber zur anderen Seite.
Also, man könnte ja auf der Mobile-Max-Seite auch mal hier die Herren-Podcaster nochmal so auflisten. Ja, jetzt muss ich dieses Ungetümmte von der Mobile-Max-Seite wieder lesen.
Ja, alle meine Webseiten sind ein totales Desaster und alles soll konsolidiert werden. Ich komm bloß einfach mit der Zeit nicht hin. Und ja, das ist das Problem. Demnächst soll eine Webseite mal alles in sich aufnehmen. Und dann soll alles mal neu gemacht werden.
Und wie das immer so ist.
Und dann muss man aber auch mal wieder eine neue Sendung machen.
Aber irgendwo kannst du bestimmt unsere Twitter-Icons plus Flatter-Button mal hinkleben.
Dann könnt ihr hier mal, wenn ich mal hier mal das Theme ändere, dann könnten wir hier einfach nochmal so eine Seite dazu hauen. Oder vielleicht gibt es das Theme auch her. Ich weiß nicht, das hat Max ausgesucht. Ich kenn mich hier mit dem nicht so gut aus. Das ist noch so ein bisschen so ein älteres Theme. Aber eure Twitter-Accounts sind ja hier irgendwie fleißig zu beflattern. Darüber kann man ja ordentlich spenden. Wie auch über alle anderen Flatter-Accounts, die sich euch so ins Gesicht drücken. Aber wir wollen jetzt hier keine große Battle-Session starten, sondern euch alles Gute wünschen. Wie sieht es eigentlich aus mit Mobile-Max in der nächsten Zeit? Wird schwierig im Sommer?
Ja, ist ja in zwei Wochen. Oder wann geht ja auch das Camp los? Kurz danach jedenfalls.
Ist das schon in zwei Wochen? Nee, in drei Wochen ist das.
In drei Wochen. Aber mit der Vorbereitung sind ja schon ein bisschen früh auf dem Acker.
Aber wir kriegen vielleicht vorher noch eine Sendung hin, wa? Oder bist du früh da?
Na, ich bin ab dem Samstag da. Also in zwei Wochen sozusagen. Hab ich vor. Vielleicht sogar auch schon vorher, aber noch nicht so dauerhaft. Also dann müsstest du schon frühstmöglich Bescheid sagen, wann du es denn so vorhast.
Dann einigen wir uns einfach gleich mal drauf.
Na dann einfach Mittwoch in zwei Wochen da, oder? Dann, wenn wir sowieso unseren Termin hätten.
Ist ja nicht Goldmund?
Jetzt muss ich hier erstmal wieder mit diesem Scheiß iCal, wo sich natürlich auch nichts gebessert hat.
Nee, und jetzt ist das mit dieser Leder-Optik, also das ist wirklich, also das iCal...
Oder der Adressbuch ist auch die gleiche Scheiße.
Kunstleder, wolltest du sagen.
Aber angeblich kann man doch jetzt hier so durchscrollen die Wochen.
Was?
In iCal. Hab ich doch gesehen irgendwo. Also wenn du jetzt auf Week gehst, dann kannst du jetzt die einfach so smooth durchscrollen, oder? Mit zwei Fingern. Also gehst in iCal, klickst oben auf Week und machst mit deinen zwei Fingern...
Ja gut, smooth ist was, er springt immer noch eine ganze Woche weiter.
Ja, aber du kannst immerhin mal so einen Blick werfen auf die davor mit zwei Fingern. Also kannst du schon... Immerhin... ist es jetzt nicht so weit weg, so ein kompletter Page-Refresh, dann kannst du rüber schmolen, kannst du ein bisschen zur Seite schieben.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man nicht Zeit einfach als das visualisieren kann, was es ist, nämlich ein endloses...
Ich bin über Apple.
Klickt mal auf Monat, ja, klickt mal auf Monat und dann swipe mal mit zwei Fingern nach links und nach rechts.
Ja, dann wird das Papier abgeblettert und so. Ja, aber warum kann man nicht einfach mehrere Wochen gleichzeitig anzeigen? Ich will einfach die Wochen...
Die haben ja eine Ratte abgeben...
.durch, das verstehe ich einfach, Wochen, das ganze Jahr einfach als Woche.
Und die Scroll einfach, ist über Scheiß.
Wir referenzieren an dieser Stelle auf die vorherige Folge.
Unfassbar.
Man, haben die eine Ratte abgeben.
Das ist alles noch viel schlimmer geworden.
Die haben ja echt eine Ratte ab, ey.
Man kann jetzt halt auch Tages scrollen, einzelne Tage kannst du machen. Das ist so... Könnte man nicht auch mal das Wochenende irgendwie...
Sorry, dass ich mit... Eikall, nein, nein, das ist wirklich schlimm.
Thank you for coming.
War schön mit euch.
Genau, wir machen jetzt ja einfach mal den Kasten zu.
Geht mal schlafen, jetzt ist schon spät.
Genau, was hängt ihr euch hier noch rum?
Genau.
Tschüss.
That's what we have for you today.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.